[Music]
o
w
[Music]
oh
the following is a presentation of the
St Louis chess
club other national titles dwarf in
comparison to the US Women's and US Open
championships in St Louis with precious
points available even the smallest moves
can affect the course of an event
there's one Queen to rule them all with
a Victorious beum toker Genova simply
walking into so lead a fellowship of was
chasing Fabiano caruana but they shall
not pass with another win nearly dooming
their chances of catching the leader as
he eyes his third Crown an Epic Journey
nears its end as hopeful strive to reach
the Mountaintop day 10 of fantastic
chess coming up next
[Music]
e
welcome back chess fans to day 10 of the
US Chess Championship and US Women's
chess Championships held at the St Louis
chess club we start a day in front of
the Chase Park Plaza Hotel which will
host the closing ceremony in just a
couple of days the stakes and tension
couldn't be higher let's go to the
studio and start today's
action welcome to St Louis the home of
Chess in America as the St Louis chess
club proudly presents the US and US
Women's chess championships round 10
coming up
now hi everybody and welcome thank you
for joining us I'm kova and I'm here
with yaser sarahan and Christian Killa
Kate the penultimate round this is it
lot of exciting chess ahead absolutely
hello everyone and Welcome to our show
we are in the penultimate round we in
the fin final two rounds what I call the
championship rounds a champion will be
forged Kate do the honors and tell our
viewers who's in the mix for the gold
medals great let's take a look so here's
the standings for the women's section we
have a clear leader be him to janova
yesterday she scored fifth consecutive
win and she's eight out of nine
absolutely incredible performance Kar
say only made a draw yesterday so she
created a space um and she is at 7 and 1
half point and then there is a tie for
the third place arena crash and Alice
Lee with five and a half points huge
match coming up we'll tell you more but
tell us about the standings in the open
session here we also have a so leader
Fabiano Karana 6 and half again really
good performance from him and there is
the three player who are closely
following him Wesley so lenier Dominguez
and abim Manu Mishra with five and a
half points and tell us about the format
for these two national championships we
play two 12 player run Robins which
means each player plays everybody else
in their respective section we play
classical chest the time control is 90
minutes for first 40 moves followed by
30 minutes for rest of the game and
there is a 30second increment from move
one players are not allowed to accept
draw they're not allowed to offer draw
and we have a traditional scoring system
one point for a win half a point for a
draw and zero points for loss because of
the possibility just remind me what
happens in case of a playoff exactly
there can be a playoff and if there is a
two players if two players TI for first
we have a two game rapid match with 10
minutes and 2 second increment if there
are still tied there is Armageddon and
Armageddon means 5 minutes for white 4
minutes for black and black has the draw
OD not much left but tell us about the
remaining schedule yeah so we have round
10 today round 11 tomorrow and if
necessary playoff on October 18 on
Wednesday Wednesday and we always start
the coverage at 1:20 p.m. Center time
absolutely thank you Kate and Christian
I got to tell you these last two games
these two rounds they promise to be
fantastic because absolutely the top
players are matched up with each other
drill down and tell us what we can
expect It's the final two decisive
rounds and definitely champions will
rise in these two important Championship
rounds let's take a look at the
standings as we enter day 10 and we're
going to start with the ladies section
this is absolutely historical I have to
say beg him toir janova with eight
points out of nine leading finally
creating some separation between herself
and Karissa I Karissa I only half a
point behind so this is still a very
tight closely contested race going into
the final two and let's take a look at
the important head to head this is the
big one it's Anna zansi the five-time
national champion against Karissa Yip
and as you can see one win for Anna two
losses and no draws so this one is
always combative In classical chess and
I have to say Anna has been struggling
in this event especially with her time
trouble situations nevertheless he she's
been having a very good year up to this
point she won the Ken's Cup in dominant
fashion so definitely that was a boost
of confidence anything can happen in
this matchup let's take a look look at
our Marquee matchup of the day in the
ladies section this is the one in
classical chess Irena Crush versus beim
toir NOA and I have to say beim has been
struggling against Arena especially in
the American Cup she got eliminated
twice in two consecutive years by Arena
Crush two wins for arena no losses and a
couple of draws in that one definitely
beg him in tip top shape in this one but
Arena crush is no push over the eight
time National Champion just an
incredible matchup this one is going to
be and let's see what's happening in the
open section as well we have a soulle
leader Fabiano Carana we've been having
a soul leader for a while in this one
but I have to say a pack of hungry
wolves closely behind following wesle so
lenier Dominguez and The Sensation of
this event ABI Manu Mishra just
incredible I have to say but this is in
Bobby's hands and let's take a look at
the important matchups as we enter day
10 this is a big one Ray Robson versus
lener Dominguez lenier is in uh the
chasing pack only one point behind the
leader and he actually dominates in this
head-to-head no losses three victories
for lener and three draws maybe with the
black pieces he going to try to strike
in this one and Ray he's had a very
difficult game yesterday he was
completely winning against Wesley saw
unfortunately for him at the 40th move
he blundered and lost that game another
important head-to-head matchup as we
enter day 10 is this one Hans nean with
the white pieces I have to say he's been
struggling in the last three rounds only
half a point out of three but definitely
he will be looking to turn around his
event entering uh day 10 he's playing
against the three-time national champion
Wesley so and Wesley what a game he's
had yesterday against Ray Robson he was
on the verge of defeat but fortunately
for him turned it around and won with
that impressive night maneuver Knight G6
Knight f8 knight6 beautiful stuff from
Wesley so and of course the Marquee
matchup of today's round is this one
Fabiano Carana the defending Champion
one point in the lead against the
sensation of the event the 14 years I I
cannot believe I'm saying this he's only
14 years of age ABI Manu Mishra just in
incredible performance from The Young
Lad no previous matchups so this one is
going to be quite intriguing to see how
they approach how they strategize this
important encounter and as you can see
Fabiano chilling relaxing strolling
around showing why he's the leader you
know he's ready he's ready to defend his
championship title yeah to keep car
pardon me to keep Cal in the face of
such an important matchup that's that's
tough that's tough but
14y old how easy is that right come on
do you have any experience in this type
of moments you don't right not even
close 14 years old just extraordinary
winning a lot of fans Kate do the honors
tell our audience who the pairings are
for everyone in the fields let's start
with the ladies let's take a look so in
the women's section we have asaran
playing por kashian p kid playing cantes
now a very important match former US
champion playing another former US women
Champion zatonski playing Yip then Yan
playing Abraham and then really the
match of today in the women section
crash playing the leader so far perfect
score for toir chova that's going to be
really interesting and then the
defending US Women's Champion you
against the current US junior girls
Champion Lee absolutely nice pairings
there around 10 pairings for the open so
here we go with board one Fabiano Carana
and abanu Mishra definitely all eyes
will be on this match because if Fabiano
wins and other he could clinch he could
clinch right and Misha will try to get
that win because that can mean he can go
to
playoff so a lot of risking I expecting
then we have aronian playing shankland
Jong playing savian Tang playing SCH and
then two matches very important for the
for the standings Robson playing
Dominguez and niman playing saw
fantastic the players have been fighting
incredibly hard uh through these two
weeks and uh terms of the ladies as we
see beum getting ready for her game
adjusting her pieces making sure
everything is perfect for this really
important game absolutely and she knows
how important this game is for her
absolutely I actually met be last night
and we were discussing a little bit she
was late for one of the rounds and she
got reprimanded uh by some people yes
and she was like nice okay I'm going to
be there in time I'm going to get ready
I I know the stakes are high but I don't
feel it right now so she was having a
very mature relaxed attitude towards
this game we'll see if that will work in
her favor okay well I mean uh
reprimanded for being late I was going
to ask uh priz fund the players are
fighting incredibly let's take a look
they are fighting for a very generous
price Fund in the wooden section we have
$152,000 price fund with first place
winning 40,000 second place 30,000 ,000
third place 20,000 all the way to the
12th Place
$4,000 and in the open section the price
fund there a little bit more ches a
little bit more with
$250,000 here The Winner Takes 60,000
second place 45,000 and third place
35,000 and all players receive price
money with 12th Place $6,000 wonderful
and we are off as far as round 10 is
concerned as I see the opening move one
two one D2 D4 in the game of Arena Crush
versus beum and ab Mishra and Fabiano
Kar we don't see French no no no no oh
French we talked about that in the the
the the the right over right uh
Christian and you were adamant you felt
no French and that Misha was going to
play a sicilian there was no way he was
going to repeat hisen not after
yesterday not after yesterday he wasn't
happy with what he got he got caught out
of the opening and had to defend the
whole game now right of course we know
what the result was we know that he won
but even he said I I had a lot of luck
in this one I'm not going to repeat I'm
not going to force my luck because
against Fabby you're going to get
punished if you get those type of
passive positions and that's exactly
what he's trying to do right now he's
trying to stay active he plays his
typical nidorf and we see the bishop to
B5 check variation variation not Knight
D7 but Bishop 2 at D7 which is a little
bit not necessarily less challenging but
more peaceful option from Black's side
and Knight to C3 it feels like maybe
bishop to D7 was a bit of a surprise for
Fabiano because he didn't instantly play
his move he thought for a while decided
on his options he can go A4 he can go C4
even is a move in that one but he
decided to go with C4 G6 and Knight to
C3 gotcha I I thought there was this
marvelous irony going on behind you what
you you were trashing the French defense
yes and right
behind I didn't see this was great oh my
goodness I thought it was really funny
this was not scripted I did not see this
okay
what only plays butter she's been using
it her whole career she's been playing
it for a while okay I'll give it to tev
you know but you know I'm trying to save
young ABI Manu he's only Generations
will appreciate your effort trying to
save this generation of American players
by telling them don't play the fren fren
defense but I think we may be seeing
Kings Indian defense in Karissa Game
King Indian there's another one uh let's
uh turn our attention and drill down a
little bit on that Fabby versus Mishra
because I've got to ask you Kate you
know I'm a classical player Bishop B5
check Bishop D7 Mishra saying what are
you doing you're you you want to trade
pieces uh with this bishop and uh help
me develop so why is that uh in your
favor and Bobby says it's not in my
favor I'll play C2
C4 we can trade on my terms on my terms
but is this a trade that is good for
white I mean after all after the trade I
mean it's White's Pawn structure that
gets compromised I mean it's a double
Pond after all and you you you lose a
little bit of central control now that
you've Tak you tra right but the pawn is
also controlling some really important
squares and I agree with you
wholeheartedly it does control the
square C6 which is a natural Square for
my knight so if I were to continue with
the move A7 A6 Knight C3 Knight C3 again
if you want to trade I'm happy to
improve my knight as well exactly so
your knight is out here I don't know is
it is it why why que E2 Queen E2 yes
Queen E2 and why is the Knight so uh
happy I don't know I it it feels like
you've traded a c Pawn which I think is
a pretty good Pawn for an a pawn and I
don't know I I've got an Rook on the
open file you know how all that works
right but I think I may be very fast
with my development let's say I Castle
here good move castles and I don't know
let's say I go E5 or if you don't go E5
I'm going to go D4 immediately okay
I you got me then I'll go I'll I could
have committed myself earlier but same
thing and you know we're playing our own
little game here but I'm just the the
bottom line is what I'm asking
is would you feel happy about this trade
of a c pwn for an a pwn usually not but
I know some variations in for example um
check over variation where you Sicilian
but you recapture with Queen on D4 and
sometimes you do play C4 and you keep
that Bishop on B5 so I've I have some
experience recapturing on B5 with that
pawn and that pawn can be very strong
coach drill down for us on this one
because I'm a little bit confused what
would happen in case of the players
following our analysis with Kate that we
just had it's definitely a playable
option for a black the problem is after
A6 I will take on A6 I don't think I'm
going to
go that's a little bit different so the
idea being that after this trade I'm
going to get the night back no matter
what the problem is I'm giving you this
E5 and there's no more D4 to open up the
center like this in this typical fashion
I don't want that I want a better
version and your knight anyway on B8 is
much better placed than A6 in fact
because you immediately want to go to C5
targeting that D4 Square so what I want
to do I'm going to take question is what
are you going to take with the Rook with
a rook with aook I like the Knight on C6
but now I go D4 immediately that's the
trade you take right I take you go
Knight F6 I would assume I go Knight C3
you go G6 right right I go Bishop E3 you
go Bishop G7 we castle castle castle
castle do we agree on that yes
everything this is very typical this
point exactly already seems to be really
bad after Queen to E2 for black I have
remarkable much easier play I'm going to
go Rook fd1 Rook ac1 put my uh Rooks on
the open and semi-open files I have
ideas of E5 once a rook lands on D1 so
you will have to address that as well
and the problem is what do you do if if
you go Knight to C6 for example move I'm
no I don't want to exchange that I have
to work with a lot of squares and with
this particular Square B5 because
there's no more Pawn on A6 to attack it
so this is a very nice almost an outpost
right because it's so well defended I'm
going to couple the action of The
Outpost on B5 with the potential outpost
on D5 so I'm going to get those nice
jumping around your position Rook fd1
rook ac1 and the key difference in the
position is that you don't have that
many squares for your pieces as black
let's say you get a queen to A5 I have
ideas of A3 followed by B4 you still
don't find those squares for your pieces
so it's a slow but steady Advantage for
white and generally players with the
black pieces don't like to see this type
uh of instances appear on the board
that's why Wow after C4 we see Knight F6
not Bishop takes a B5 that often Knight
to C3 G6 and now finally uh Fabiano
decides to take on D7 which sort of
surprised Mishra let's take a look and
see if he's going to make his move
quickly because this is one of the main
lines in the position I'm a bit
surprised that he has he did take with
after some hesitation though slight
hesitation but still 1 hour 32 minutes
obviously showing that he's in his
preparation he knows what he's doing and
he probably prepared this I have to say
he didn't win necessarily the opening
battle but he's showing that he knows
exactly what he's doing and this is
against a player that is maybe at the
current time the most well the the best
prepared player on the planet Fabiano
Carano he's definitely uh in the top
three I would reckon we do have Castles
by the way fabby's last move was castles
and they are in the theory Knight C6
Bishop G7 it's like a a Brookie buy with
uh with a trade of one pair of minor
pieces we'll keep an eye on WE us say
that in the Maran you don't want to have
the bishop right so I understand the
trade the light s TR main game or at
least the top rated game in this
position according to the database that
I'm using is Carana versus
mvl and in fact fabbi lost that game W
so maybe that was one of the stem games
that abiani used in his preparation
thinking that oh okay maybe this is the
type of position that Fabby doesn't feel
comfortable in if he lost a game uh this
was loss in 2016 and I'm not 100% sure
if it was a rapid Blitz or classical
game but still a loss is a loss
signaling that maybe you're not that
comfortable in those type of positions
very intriguing matchup up to this point
absolutely and in that fight for the
second place positions we've got two
very key games one Hans nean versus
Wesley so and we know that Wesley was a
very fortunate recipient yesterday
against Ray Robson Ray is one of those
players who really had a lot of bad luck
in these uh years's us Championship
could have it left a lot of points on
the very ni game yesterday with
positional sacrifice of Pawn Yeah the
whole C4 B4 Knight C5 A4 that rayan cork
he really deserved more let's turn to
the game and see uh what's happening in
the Hans nean versus Wesley game okay
again a Joko piano everybody's favorite
it would seem C2 C3 A5 rookie1
castles kind of inviting those Bishop G5
variations that have oh so popular no on
nean uh sticks to his guns Knight D2
Bishop E6 and we're up to date with the
play again this is just all the starting
point I would say of this uh Theory what
uh we would say the Tabby of positions
are let's jump to the other game that is
so important for our standings uh lanir
Dominguez very very quietly in second
place no not bothering anyone just
picking up some points here and there
undefeated at uh plus two he's up
against Ray Robson and the the best time
play well no I was going to say one of
the best times to play a person is after
you know like they've lost a winning uh
game you lose a game it's fine but when
you lose a a winning game it stings that
much more yeah it's very discouraging
for the player absolutely Berlin defense
D2 D3 let's not go into the Berlin
ending I don't have anything specially
prepared says Ray Bishop C5 Bishop takes
Pawn takes and this has actually become
a kind of a go-to I've seen a lot of
players uh uh use this line I'm more
familiar with ideas of B2 B3 then I am
A2 A4 uh coach the move A2 A4 by Ray
Robson is this the latest Wrinkle in the
Berlin it's a novelty novelty it is a
novelty yes A4 is a novelty at move
seven night B uh D2 has most in this
position Bishop to G5 uh H3 other stuff
but not A4 okay that that is quite
intriguing the question is and I guess
the the answer might be that you want to
play Knight to A3 later instead of
Knight to D2 and keep this bishop open
because anyway you want to land on C4
right the whole idea behind uh White
play is that I'm going to try to put
some pressure on E5 and stop Black's
play on the king side um make his pieces
be a bit more passive with Knight to D7
things of that nature focus on the
defense of the Pawn on E5 so that's
probably the idea behind it in most
instances uh and by the way this is a
slow game right this is not one of those
super Dynamic positions in which every
single move matters every single Tempo
matters you can do things slowly and uh
you can experiment as well this seems to
be a useful move that anyway a lot of
the players with the white pieces played
later on in the game to counter
sometimes black expansion black
suspension on the queen side with A5 now
the question is if you do give me one
more move maybe I will play in fact A5
myself
to take even more space right so I'm
expecting right now the reaction from
Dominguez is going to be that he's going
to go A5 himself really after like 30
minutes of think of course first of all
let's familiarize ourselves with the no
let him Ste a little bit he's going to
think for a while and then most likely I
think that that will be his reaction A5
just for the simple fact once again that
I see this structure very often from
different move orders and generally
black wants to go see D5 B6 put all the
pawns on the dark squares and then use
uh the dominance of the light Square
Bishop there's no more light Square
Bishop for white because he just took on
C6 so I'm going to use that to my favor
and of course white is going to try to
maneuver Knight to C4 maybe B3 Bishop to
B2 depending on how you place your
pieces as well and at the right moment
if possible I would like to uh open up
things with the move d4 and that's why
we generally see the pawn coming to C5
to stop that so these are the moving
pieces that I'm seeing in this position
again I think the reaction is going to
be
A5 intriguing uh for me uh as a
classicist I see the move A2 A4 I'm
thrilled and delighted I I I take me to
school that's wonderful A2 A4 what does
that have to do with the center I would
play C5 myself and I would think after a
move like Knight A3 Bishop G5 I'm simply
better with black probably the engines
are laughing at me you know like you're
not better with black and I'm like yes I
am and way we would go because I would
say your night needs you you know you
should have stopped me from pinning you
and all of this other good stuff and I'm
not afraid of H3 G4 and my next move
actually is going to be Knight to D7 so
let's say you go Knight C4 Knight to D7
and my idea is my strong point is E5
maybe on a good day I play F6 Knight f F
96 for me these variations is all about
the fight for the D4 square if white
gets to play D4 Advantage white if not
black is fine you know I don't really
have much experience in this so I see A4
and I'm like is that novelty is that
theory I don't know okay and let's uh
turn our attention to the leaders in uh
the ladies group a huge class I mean
simply absolutely extraordinary Arena
versus beum and we've just got to pick
it up uh what has now um Kate jump in
with me here you imagine yourself to be
in bacum shoes I mean this is a very
very big test there's no question about
it black pieces with Arena uh
Grandmaster Arena Crush in the field you
kind of think to yourself you don't even
want to have these thoughts but I get
past the today's challenge right if I
survive today right tomorrow white I'm
very happy so your approach to today
game would be to be solid to be solid
absolutely she's playing the nimzo
Indian as black perhaps the most solid
way of meeting Juan D4 by the way the
move Bishop D2 coach that's a little bit
of the latest wrinkle because if you're
playing a Rubenstein Bishop D3 Knight F3
and or Knight E2 probably 10,000 games
right right Bishop D is something that a
lot of players have been trying recently
uh some players at the elite level as
well Wesley mostly with the black pieces
this was Fabby versus Wesley from Norway
CH yes this past year I analyzed this
position quite a lot I was helping Faby
during that tournament Bishop to D2 is
testing but if black knows what to do
they're going to be quite safe Rook to
E8 is is a wrinkle I did not anticipate
B6 is the main line B7 B6 yes okay B6 in
the main line and uh now that I finally
waited for you to commit at least to
that square B7 now I take on D4
right this is usually how things go you
take take Bishop D3 and then we get
these type of structures these type cars
bad structures I can see that in this
particular position the move Rook E8 is
attractive uh for black because she will
be controlling the E4 Square uh the in
fact I think Bishop D6 is the main line
in that position in that position
thereafter but with the same idea to
control that square E5 that's key
because at some point white is going to
try to go Knight KN D5 if you give me
too too many tempies right um and that
might be problematic and that's why I
don't even think Bishop to B7 is the
most precise you immediately go with
Rook E8 and Bishop to D6 just to Simply
control so you go B6 take take Bishop to
D3 now you can go Rook to E8 castle and
Bishop to
D6 that's the most uh yes yes that's I
think the most uh precise move order so
Rook Rook E8 looks like a move that we
do like in this position yeah so maybe
playing bit early is not much a
difference uh one of the ideas I've
always noticed about an early rookie
eight is it does in case you play A2 A3
does give the bishop Hide
Away uh none of this has happened
because the players took a different uh
route Rook E8 Rook C1 uh by Arena and
she's probably has it in her mind that
the move B6 she could uh I don't know
potentially trade off
her weak Bishop I don't know uh why
would you put your Rook on C1 if not to
coordinate an attack against the C7
square but Rook C1 is on the board is
this are we in theoretical Waters here
uh well she played A6 A6 right so beging
played A6 which she's trying to achieve
a better version than what we just
discussed and I will explain to you in
just second
for example if you do take on D5 and you
go Bishop D3 just normal play like this
now I go Bishop to D6 and A6 is a more
useful move than B6 right we were
looking at position with a Pawn on B6
because immediately I control the B5
square right so no more Knight B5
Shenanigans none of that also I haven't
committed to B6 maybe I can go B5 maybe
I can leave the a Pawn on B7 play C5
Knight to C6 and that pawn on B7 is
going to support my knight on C6 so it's
a much better improved version compared
to the pawn on B6 now the problem with
the move A6 not necessarily a problem
the tradeoff with the move A6 is that
you're giving white one extra Tempo and
now I can go C5 right that is the big
question how are you going to approach
this move C5 the general response to
this is to immediately attack it with a
B6 but now I can go Knight W4 and I have
ideas of this Nature by the way C5
nobody has played so this would be a
novelty in this particular position but
it is the engine Top Line and by the way
this is not a very explored line right
there haven't been as many games only um
eight games in fact in this position in
the DAT base not a lot Bishop to D3
would be an opportunity as well the
problem is the idea behind this whole
setup is I'm waiting for you to move
your Bishop so then I can take on C4 and
force you to lose a Tempo basically take
take and now once again again A6 is
perfectly placed to support B5 I'm going
to go B5 Bishop to B7 C5 as well this in
fact looks like a very good position for
black already so big moment right now
after the move A6 C5 is I would say the
most testing option in this position but
you know Arena it very much depends on
what her strategy is because I know
Arena and she generally likes to play
this type of slow quiet position
strategical grinds in which she will
just simply be able to improve her
position uh better and understand the
position better compared to her opponent
that's what she's looking for C5 already
throwing a gauntlet in the position
making uh the nature changing the nature
of the position to a much more Dynamic
one so we'll see if she goes for that or
just keeps the position tight with a
simple move such as A3 Bishop D3 C takes
D5 things of that nature uh yesterday we
saw a very rare guest in our tournament
experiened the BOGO Indian and I liked
it and after the move C5 when I played
the BOGO Indian as black one of the
things I was looking to do was to trade
two sets of minor pieces I would play
the bishop to B4 check I trade the dark
squared Bishops and I'd look to trade a
knight when I see the move
C5 I taking a page from my BOGO Indian
experience I would likely play like this
takes takes now you're welcome to play
B4 Bishop D3 later you can tell me what
you would prefer there goes my two uh
pieces and then I would like to play
Knight C6 and I want to play E5 and if I
get in the move E5 I feel like equalize
I mean the bishop on is very happy once
E5 is played right now if you stop me
from playing E5 somehow I don't know how
if you stop me then my Bishop light
Square Bishop is dormant passive but you
can understand why those two traits
because the move C4
C5 gaining space on the queen side maybe
something that Arena would like to do
get into those technical positions that
she really does excel at I think she's
just superb in those but that would
be why I might pause you know the if
black gets in that move E5 well then I
do like the position for black if white
captures on D5 because right if white
captures and black captures on D5 I feel
like black really has everything they
want the bishop can be out the A6 move
is very useful exactly the other goes to
D6 exactly what Christian said so I
think that's the only way I wouldn't go
as white exactly if I were white in this
uh ex Zach position by the way I would
find myself attracted to the move Queen
B3 and what's the idea of Queen B3 well
give me give me your Bishop if I can get
you to play Knight C6 then well I don't
know if the Knight is actually so super
well placed there I would play Play
Bishop D3 in a way we go but if you
retreated the bishop Bishop uh went to
D6 now with my Bishop on D2 I can
actually uh snap a pawn uh broad
daylight robbery no discovered attack no
discovered attack you may want to go all
the way back and then okay now I'll
start to Aspire to play moves like
Bishop D3 and E4 yes I'm certainly aware
that C5 might equalize a game but uh a
key moment going on here and let's go to
game of Kiss Kissa Y where is she
against Anna zatonski oh yes uh and
again this is a game that the two
players have played where there's been
no draws between them they they've
always had decisive games MH and guess
what it's not a king's Indian it's a
perk but Karissa gets her setup that she
used to play exactly the fianchetto uh
Bishop on the king side and uh well this
line of the perk actually I respect for
Anna a lot I uh I think that this is
actually one of for me when I play
against the perk I think it's ch she
just 25 yeah okay that I feel is a
little bit helpful no what she's doing
is she's what is she doing she's playing
against her opponent's tournament
position yes right right her opponent
needs to win at least she thinks that
she needs to win right to catch up with
begging there is no fight for third
place like it's either one or two for
these two ladies because the nearest
competitor is 2 and a half points behind
them so they don't have to worry about
uh being getting the bronze medal right
they're fighting for gold or silver so
it's all in for Kisa that's why we're
seeing the perk that's why she's taking
so many chances she thinks she needs to
win this one and an i is saying okay I
know what you want I know what you need
right so I'm going to play something
very U tight I'm not going to take any
risks I'm going to Blackmail you with
the tournament situation right now
that's that's what she's doing I mean if
you want to draw sh I'll take it no
problem but I know that you want to
force matters I know that you will try
uh to do something wild and rash and
maybe I can take advantage of that right
that's what Anna is doing with this
trade on E5 this whole strategy of C3
much more of a compact very peaceful way
of playing against the PS there's much
more aggressive ways you can go F4 you
can go D4 E4 F4 uh you can do so many
things against the perk that are much
more aggressive than this but again
keeping it tight playing against her
opponent's needs in the tournament
that's a funny way of putting it
blackmail Kate sometimes you play
against lower rated players and it seems
like they're trying to Blackmail you and
make a draw and you know you have to
take risk game actually a check youth
Championship last round I was like I I
kind of wanted to win I don't know if I
needed to but my opponent also played
this kind of setup and I was black and I
won positionally because white really
tried for the draw and that's also not
maybe the best strategy because
especially with white you are kind of
used to play for a win and suddenly when
you switch that I think you can start
making some inaccurate moves yeah I like
the idea of playing for Advantage with
white not to go all in and risk
everything but I like the fact I like
the idea of how you just put it uh
Christian this idea that Anna's playing
a little bit of a role of a black mailer
here you know you're going to have to
Carissa we know what what the tournament
situation is you're going to take
excessive risk I know that go ahead and
go crazy on me and I'll I'll try to
upset you I see that you've got the game
of Ray Robson and lenir on your board
and you're right A4 A5 was Ray's Follow
That was it makes sense right because
again we see this move A4 but we
generally see it later and that's why I
anticipated lenier to answer with A5 he
did not he played a completely different
thing so uh after A4 he decided to go
with this move Bishop to E6 immediately
and by the way we're watching the game
uh between Ray Robson and lanar
Dominguez Bishop to E6 A5 H6 and now
Knight bd2 and the idea being that once
I established this control uh on the
queen side with the move A5 and I'm
establishing my presence right now B6 is
going to be a little bit more difficult
to be played for black B6 sometimes I'm
even going to counter that with a move
A6 taking even more space on that side
the ideas the basic ideas remain the
same I'm still going to try to focus on
that E5 square and the potential opening
of the center with D4 that's why we see
the move Knight to D2 we're expecting
him to follow follow it up with B3
support that Knight to jump to C4 put
more pressure with a bishop coming to B2
and then at the right moment uh D4 so
these are the typical plans I'm
surprised that linear allowed this
expansion with A4 A5 definitely Ray
Robson is the better prepared player I
have to say in this position and what I
mean by that he knows the positions
better because he analyzed this uh
special idea with A4 A5 it's a novelty
it has never played so definitely a
slight Edge out of the opening for Ray
so I have a question Christian if as
black I go let's say something like B5
you're never going to capture on B6
right B5 is I'm not no no no for sure
not but the problem with B5 can IM go D4
yeah I'm I think you need to start
actually so let's start with C5 I start
with C5 yes yes yeah I like this much uh
much more than that let's go B very
agressive very and now let's now you go
B5 right maybe I will take in fact
really I'm fan okay are you ready AB so
you're going to take with am okay Bishop
to B2 Knight D7 St that's a very
important uh move don't take on A1
because que A1 PA you lose the pawn you
don't have time to reinforce the defense
of the Pawn on E5 I feel a chill PA it's
like Halloween is in the air just you
have to go here
change and then I would assume that this
Knight comes to C to create some more
weakness now by the way you played H6 as
well I didn't play H6 he L played H6
you're blaming lener I see what you're
doing right but now it seems that you
have to play F6 and if you do have to
play F6 in conjunction with the pawn on
A6 already a bit a I feel like if I get
C5 pawns and B5 but there are a lot of
weak squares once white targets the E5
Square I just I just have the feeling
that I like I like the C5 idea and I
like the B5 idea but I just think you
need to get castled and Knight D7 and do
a little bit more prep on the B5 it's
interesting that the engine really likes
raise position right now after this
sequence of moves that we just put on
the board so this C5 B5 uh seems to be
um a bit too
fast you're opening up the position on
my terms let's go back to the Fabby uh
Mishra game and see how things developed
again this was a uh an invitation to
open Sicilian by Nish Mishra shall we
dance to the tune of the night or no
said Fabby we're going to play
bation uh Bishop B five check the light
squar Bishops got traded we are in one
of those positions where we have a moroy
buying Pawn structure Pawn on uh C4 E4
the difference light Square Bishops are
missing in principle the idea behind the
bind of E4 C4 is I got positional space
so when there's a lot of pieces on the
board that extra space in the center
favors white if we were to trade all the
minor pieces off and just for example
only have four Rooks the bind would
disappear there would be no bind there
would be nothing that you could be proud
of so every minor piece trade is
generally speaking a step down for the
player with the B right white also can
be enjoying the D5 Square for the Knight
and potentially attacking on the queen
side with that kind of three against to
Advantage right so the more we trade the
less kind of options to accomplish
either of those plans now the normally
speaking I'm looking as black to play
moves like Rook on F to C8 and literally
on a good day the minority attack with
A6 and B5 usually
it's nice if I can ever get in E6 D5 but
if I play E6 prematurely it often times
happens that I just end up with a
backward Pawn on an open file and it's
like why did I create a weakness in my
position uh we can expect Fabby to go
Rook fd1 Rook ac1 exactly bring the
Rooks into the middle of the board and
and then a lot of maneuvering is gonna
happen I wanted to ask Christian that uh
in the current position statistically
speaking how do things shake out do does
white win 52% of the game 60% white is
doing quite well um in fact black never
won in this position never won no 33% of
the games and there's only six of them
in my database so not that many wow 33%
were won by white after the move Bishop
to D2 and
67% were a draw I I would have never
guessed those percentages at all it
makes some sense and this is something
that I wanted to mention as well I feel
like Fabby got the type of position that
he wants he's not necessarily looking to
take too many risks right he's in a
great position just simply don't lose if
you don't lose if you score one point
out of the next two games I have a
feeling that's going to be enough for a
playoff to win the championship even to
win the championship I think one out
of I don't see anybody scoring two out
of two no all got to do a score one
oh behind somebody has to score one
point behind so one point for Fabiano
out of the next two games and
specifically he's playing one of them
against Wesley in the last round so if
he draws this one and then draws against
Wesley Wesley and Mishra are out right
right so only lenier with the black
pieces he needs to beat Robson and I'm
not sure who he plays in the last one
but those ain't easy tasks
right I have to say one out of two I
think is going to be enough he has that
in the back of his mind right this is
the perfect position uh to play for that
because you not risking as much you have
a nice marroy bind you have an easy plan
Rook C1 Rook D1 B3 H3 maybe Knight to D4
at the right moment Knight to D5 you
don't have a lot of weaknesses and uh
there's not a lot of ways in which black
can complicate matters in this type of
structures no weaknesses in the position
for white so from a practical
perspective
that is a great spot to be in for
Fabiano and by the way we were just told
that linear plays none other than Hans
Neiman in the last round who just to
make things much more that's a spicy
pairing so I have to say now that uh I
know that if lener wins his game with
the black pieces and I feel this is the
big one the big test for ler Hans you
know is a bit unstable especially in the
last few rounds so there's definitely an
opportunity on that one specifically
when ler has the white pieces right but
today's game against Ray with the black
pieces it's very very difficult take us
to this current position theoretically
speaking after the move Bishop D2 to my
eyes the move Rook f8 to C8 is the most
natural that is a move yes it has been
played by by uh Sergey
Kasparov okay Alonso moano I've never
heard of Alonso moano I know who ser is
but he's not Gary Kasparov yeah that's
it and how did that game continue Rook
ac1 right very just typical Queen to
d8 and we were saying all these moves
are very natural Rook C1 B3 Rook D1 and
uh played from there Knight to D7 by the
way that game was one Rook fd1 all very
standard moves for this structure Knight
C5 Queen to B1 A5 was uh played Bishop
to E3 already the engine is saying
saying that it's Advantage white close
to a plus one point Advantage so once
again I feel this is a good position
good outcome for Fabiano out of the
opening right okay keep that one in
speaking of Ray Robson and lir one one
one more look uh sure there okay not too
much happened just we have A5 H6 uh
Knight D2 and Knight to D7 inviting D4
then he'd castle and he'd be a kind of a
happy guy I guess yeah maybe even Queen
to F6 here perhaps this is what he's
getting ready for M Queen to F6 Knight
to D7 is an intriguing move I like it
the big question is what do you do after
B3 right castle and now Knight
C4 F6 at some point or do you try to
defend it in a different way no I think
at F6 is a a reason but maybe you have
did I play H6 if ever I'm going to play
yeah so this is why what we're being
told by the engine is that once I gear
up for the attack against E5 right not
F6 in fact Bishop takes C4 would be the
preferred option and my question is what
if I take with a B Pawn and now B5
yes Kate has been sight of Rel yes from
advocating for some time and at last the
engine approved engine improved and
finally Wesley SL Hans neon then we're
going to take a look at all the other
games but these are our Marquee match
ups for the open so uh we have another
Joo yes H once again with the white
pieces not a great um history for him in
the Joo piano this tournament we've seen
what happened yesterday against Fabiano
that was a painful defeat so A4 Knight
to G3 this is what we have the question
is what if I go D4 I've already taken a
lot of space on this side why don't I
close things on the other doesn't this
forcibly remind us of the game of leavon
aronia and Wesley so that was where it
was like Knight C4 Knight A3 and I was
like utterly confused by what leevon was
doing that ended in a draw yes when I
think about these Joko piano games
Wesley so comes to mind as one of the
most experienced players actually for
both colors both sides yeah he really
has a lot of experience yesterday
looking he analyzed some games for chess
base in the variation that Fabby played
against Hunnan yes uh and one of the
variations he was looking instead of
Bishop A7 was Bishop Bishop E6 the land
that he just played today so he's he has
a game there with Lenard Dominguez so
he's quite familiar with this variation
exactly and nothing gives you that great
confidence you need at the chessboard
like that kind of experience like oh I
played this against Magnus and he he
barely made a draw against me and then I
played it against Fabby and I managed to
win so that that experiment that
knowledge and that preparation that
Wesley brings to this particular
position makes me
wonder about hans's choice but okay that
it is what it is let's go and take a
look at the other games that we haven't
been uh paying attention to uh let's
jump to the game of leavon check the
leevon game yes yes I think you should
check that did he just steal a a pawn I
I think he
did not sure exactly what but I think he
did
in uh uh open sunlight of day what is
this just a second d65 look
okay look at Sam right now his head is
Sam oh my goodness he blundered the pawn
yeah I see the head sh the swivel there
H2 H3 now uh much like beum the move
Rook e E8 looks like a required kind of
move because after all there's always
this E4 takes D5 Knight takes E5
business right could also D4 be a
possibility I know I'm giving up that C4
square but also I'm creating a Tempo on
that Rook exactly so uh
D4 but one thing's for sure the move
Bishop E6 looks like a blunder and Sam
again my Sam he's Furious Furious
absolutely and Knight takes E5 by the
way that's
not the most common tactic I have seen
this before but uh to your point Kate I
think D4 would have been
better than Bishop E6 and how was your
intention you wanted to recapture with
the pawn I thought with the pawn yes and
then the Rook you drive my Rook I don't
want to like antire Knights right if
they but you you you did mention the
drawback of your idea which right so I
will go now Bishop E6 now Bishop eex
okay so you know those those crafty Cil
ion players you know I'm eyeballing Rook
takes C6 is a
possibility I just think it's a
different game all together let's see
what happened because tactically it's
not that simple because that C file look
uncomfortable for a little bit but
Bishop E6 natural move just to develop
the bishop but Knight takes E5 rocks his
world and let's understand why if we
take with the Knight Pawn on B5 we take
with the bishop shall we uh Rook takes
E5
now obviously if we target this
Pawn that's a freebie that's a that's a
pawn and a very good Pawn at that D4
Queen F3 so we've got to do better than
this for black um Knight takes E5 takes
if we take with the Knight Knight takes
Rook takes some kind of Knight
F4 that's the business that's the
business I'm looking for Knight F4 or
and or queen takes D3 now if you do play
D4 I got a feeling I can't win the pawn
on B2 like this is a fork
that goes all wrong Knight takes B2 and
oops you're just simply trapped um it
looks to us our our first take uh
Christian that Sam blundered a pawn and
getting compensation there there's no
get getting compensation is a hard's no
it's not obvious comp what the the best
line of play is you lost the pawn that's
it okay you're Pawn down no compensation
zero compensation but give me the my my
my my best play like the best move is to
take okay and I'll take on D5 take on D5
and now Knight E G4 that's your best
play right but to be honest I mean this
this looks ugly take a look at this I
take you take on E3 I take on F s that's
a nice exchange sack King h8 King h8
already after F takes C3 you take this
Pawn on D3 the problem is after Queen to
E1 this Knight is going to find its way
to H4 and G6 at some point with a Pawn
on H Pawn can be dangerous right you're
going to have to give back the exchange
it's staying there forever no I'm I'm
going to go Queen D7 and take it off the
board I don't I don't want that fond to
live doesn't work doesn't work you don't
have time for I don't even get the time
to give you don't even have time for
that oh man and even if you do I mean
again you're just PA down no this one is
looking Grim for Sam and you know he's a
fighter that's why he was shaking his
head he was so upset because he doesn't
even get any glimmer of hope in terms of
compensation right now this is just
going to be a pawn down for the
remainder of the game and he's going to
try to defend this ugly situation he's a
fighter we know that but I have to say
from a psychological perspective that
game yesterday took a toll on him
they're losing the Mish obviously and
Christian can you just tell us so what
was the correct move instead of Bishop
E6 Rook e of course Bishop E6 is a
blunder we see now but Rook E A the you
know what the funny part is is Bishop to
E6 was played before no there's only two
games and somebody else fell into this
trap with Bishop to E6 uh Rook to E8 of
course yeah just defend the pawn on E5
is is the main move in the position
right uh and now we see some
transpositions Rook to E1 look he's such
a well-prepared player I think he knows
I think he knew this move Rook to E8 he
probably just didn't think actually I'm
kind of curious let's see for how long
did he think about this move Bishop to
E6 okay he spent around 3 minutes 2
minutes and a half on this bishop to E6
not an instant blunder but not an
instant blunder yes but I mean right now
it's so oh he goes for this Knight G4
okay okay all right well I mean you have
to be practical what will give my
opponent the most difficulties and maybe
Knight E5 to G4 even though we know it's
bad for black gives the best Hope by the
way look at that uh nice shirt of
leevon he got memo it's a it's a blue
jacket type of day yeah there you go
leavon can always be counted on the
height of fashion um what I wanted to
say so unhappy I'm sorry but you see
this is so p yeah um last year's US
championships was the disrespect US
champ I loved it I loved it everybody
was getting trashed it was great this US
champ these US championships something
very strange is happening blunders in
the openings blunders in the openings
and if you told me before we came to in
into the studio today that Sam Shanklin
one of the greatest theoreticians in
America today would be you know upon
down with no compensation up to 12 moves
I'm saying just a second are we talking
about the same Sam shackin I mean we are
seeing some opening catastrophes not
that this is a catastrophe cast but just
if you think about the Andrew Tang game
right Andrew Tang did not capture a pawn
that was for free yeah it's just so so
amazing uh 0 G4 uh exercise a little bit
elaborate a little bit more on this one
you like the the engine Christian Light
capturing twice all the way down to F7
sure I can take on E6 take on F7 I can
so just take on G4 that's an option as
well now you have to take back with a
bishop you no longer have the option of
taking on G4 the pawn is on
G I'm lost how much did I give up I was
thinking if Rook takes E6 and hg4 but no
I'm a piece down right you're going to
I'm only going to get might as well do
the same thing take on F7 sorry you were
giving us the other option uh take on G4
Bishop takes G4 Bishop takes G4 and now
you can go uh Queen to E1 even this
gives you a very good Advantage because
after Knight to D5 Rook to E4 I'm
setting up first of all the attack on
the bishop G4 you cannot go to E6 H now
I will rip it off yeah exactly this is
over right Queen takes C6 I take two
pieces a couple of Pawns this is looking
good nothing so you don't have that
square for the bishop where do you go if
you go to F5 Rook to E5 finishes the
game right that's double attack you have
to go Bishop B6 you're losing so where
do you go you don't want to go to C so
if I go to H5 the same thing if you go
to H5 for I ah and then Rook to E5
you're losing lot of tricks lots of
tricks and not a lot of squares for your
pieces it's problematic for black right
now well the other problem if I go to C8
do you have Rook D4 exactly that's the
one I'm afraid of exactly exactly yes
now Rook to D4 is an option I can even
just play the simple Rook to E5 perhaps
Rook D4 C6 C4 I have Queen F6 I think so
so maybe that might be problematic but I
can take the pawn like this if I really
want to really really want to Queen to
E5 Bishop to E6 Knight to C4 Knight to
E3 at some point you're going to lose
this Pawn so even this is much better
for white but you can do even by the way
he took on G4 he did Bishop takes G can
you go
F3 that's keeping the pawn just to keep
the pawn right yeah F3 do you go Bishop
F5 or do you go Bishop C8 whenever you
go Bishop F5 I will have the same idea
whenever you take on E5 so I have one
more move to prepare my defense right
Queen to E1 you cannot take because of
uh Rook to E5 right we've understood
this right Bishop B6 Rook takes C6
that's the problem so H takes G4 we're
expecting Bishop takes G4 and then we
will find out whether he's going to go
F3 or queen to E1 I really like this
move Queen to E1 but it's not easy to
see this idea of Rook to E4 and
understand the fact that that Bishop is
in fact very badly placed also you see
the move Knight to F6 and Things become
a little bit dangerous not necessarily
dangerous but maybe you're not going to
end up that extra Pawn up that you
really wanted at the same time now you
have to shift your attention you go Rook
to D4 and where does the queen
go if you go to E8 I have ideas of
Knight E4 right that's problematic the
bishop on G4 is is in trouble yeah you
canot go C8 and to C8 yes but now it's
this grip that I'm talking about you
cannot develop your pieces Rook to E8
you lose F7 F7 Pawn so you have to
defend maybe with a move Bishop to H5
then I go Knight to E4 I'm getting this
grip in the position very quickly at the
expense of my extra Pawn but I can use
that as a token to get a different type
of Advantage I'm giving you the material
advantage back you are able to establish
uh equality but unfortunately from a
strategical point of view you are um on
the defensive with the black pces Sam
Shanklin scrambling to survive early
days here going to look at two of our
remaining uh games that we haven't
checked in checked in on Jeffrey Jang
not having a successful tournament Sam
Sean also came is traded already yeah
also came into this event did uh Sam
again he won probably a career defining
uh event uh the Fisher random and uh
you're right a lot of pieces got traded
tuck tck tck all pretty standard stuff
and boy I have to tell you the players
just know so much
Theory and they just Blitz their way
right only got extra time this is the
first time Bishop I thought that he
actually took few minutes to think
exactly they some times I think the play
the modern-day players they zip right
out of the openings into the endings
because their preparation is so deep
Bishop F5 what can I say three versus
three two versus two slight Advantage
for white because I just feel I'm a
little bit better developed I can play
Rook to D1 Bishop F3 maybe I'll play for
G4 and you know a rook invas I do feel
that uh I agree with you but I feel like
Sam knows what he's doing I mean he
prepare this line so he will play maybe
some 86 Rook C8 Rook C7 and say oh this
is this is draw yeah yeah I work this
out to a draw and then finally our uh
last game Andrew Tang uh and under
London London uh he comes in as the US
Open Champion as how he qualified up
against darush darush says you know he's
a very very strong player formidable
player as darush but somehow he gets
into these championships and he doesn't
show his best qualities it's like Fabby
you know had an even position the whole
time and Fabby kept playing consistently
playing for dar's time trouble and we
know that is a problem that he has it's
very difficult for for players to kind
of optimize their performance to prepare
it so they you know play the best at
this particular event absolutely and I
feel like somehow we're not seeing the
best of uh darush and he's struggling
he's up against Andrew tang and again
London system but Andrew is playing
London and move five and he already lost
minutes
that's that's strange B3 Knight C3 C2 C3
if you're going to play a London system
is white these moves B3
C3 don't mesh well with the bishop
coming to F4 what am I missing here uh
in this game between Andrew tang and
darou I mean did Andrew Tang uh do
something wrong because B3 and C3 for B3
is not really a move right we play
Knight C3 here I know he was exactly yes
after Queen to B6 yes so he was thinking
at this point he got surprised by this
early on E6 C5 Queen B6 without the
Knight on F6 right most of the times we
see it in that nature and that's why he
played it so quickly uh that is that is
this was his preparation Knight to C3 is
the best move in the position not B3 B3
is PA B offering the pawn on B2 I don't
think you want to take it no after
Knight to B5 I think you're completely
busted yes two and a half
points no Knight B5 Knight C7 Rook B1
there are so many threats in the
position you cannot survive this uh you
don't have those ideas with Knight D4
that we saw in the stem game the first
one sh
Sam Sam Shanklin black pieces now that I
remember another opening catastrophe for
and and that Sam didn't take advantage
of right that sort of set the tone for
Sam's tournament situation he did not
perform well after that so Knight to C3
was in fact the best move in the
position so you think maybe Andrew was
worried about offering that pawn again
because what if uh dariush can capture
it again maybe yeah yeah yeah cuz he
spent 30 minutes on that3 he did he did
spend a lot of time yes that is very
true and I'm just saying that the com if
you're playing a London system the
combination of the moves B3 D3 is white
inside of five moves like come on you
don't you just don't do that and right
now black has in fact uh at least
equalized in the position again it's
still the London it's still a very safe
position you have you're with white you
have an extra Tempo you haven't made any
huge mistakes right in the position I
would still say that it's equal but the
trend favors Darius in this one
absolutely let's take a look at all of
the ladies games uh we're going to go as
always to our our tournament leader beum
uh we're just going to check in and see
how uh Arena handled this combination of
Rook E8 and A6 she didn't go for
anything spectacular she didn't go for
the queen B3 move that I was advocating
or the expansion in the center with C4
C5 that the engine light instead develop
transferring to Bishop D3 Mainline Sky
which is basically what black was
waiting for soon as you move the bishop
then I capture the pawn and it feels
like we can get into some kind of a
Queen's Gambit accepted position where
maybe this Tempo has been lost by White
Knight
E5 uh by the way I'm surprised by
86 me too what was why do we need to
play 86 Knight D7 castles I'm thinking
everybody their brother their sister
plays for C7 C5 here
Castle's
H6 Kate I I said it first I I'm not sure
because 9 G5 is not a threat Bishop
cannot go there either um H7 H6 well
obviously I can't play
E4 I would probably be tempted myself to
play A2 A3 and just ask uh black if they
intend to give up the bishop but Knight
E5 shows some ambition here by Arena
because say okay she can get this um uh
Pillsbury attack with F2 F4 if uh beum
isn't
careful right and if beon captures that
Knight on E5 let's take a look Knight
takes E5 takes I'm assuming the Knight
doesn't want to go to D5 because of
Knight takes D5 so I have to go back to
once again now I
get4 um I don't like it I simply don't
like it for black I think this bishop is
a little bit passive and I do see moves
like Knight C3 E4 and I I shy away I I I
I shy away from this especially because
of the tournament situation I don't want
to give my opponent a free attack
against my king and here again I would
probably want to fall back on the Move
C7 C5 we we we don't understand H6 coach
yeah no not
are you trying to make me explain it no
no H6 doesn't make a lot of sense to my
eyes either I mean what did we discuss
from the beginning we said you play A6
you wait for Bishop to D3 you take take
and then immediately you go B5 bishop7
followed by C5 that's what she was
supposed to do in the position H6 just
simply is a loss of tempo I mean there's
absolutely no reason why you would put
that pawn on H6 Knight to E5 unless you
want to play E5 right I understand
that Knight G5 uh especially coupled
with the action of the bishop on C4
against the pawn on F7 I understand that
but the reaction from Arena was Top
Notch to E5 that's the best move in the
position don't take on E5 because take
take Knight D7 let's say F4 this is
starting to look bad right you're
cramped easy attack you're really
cramped in the position as black this is
an easy attack F5 at the right moment I
even have ideas of transferring this
Knight via E4 to the king side Rook F3
or queen to F3 Queen to not looking good
right for Black's chances and this is
not the type of position that you want
to play she reacted in the best way you
have an uncomfortable situation so start
looking for counterplay and do it fast
and she played the move C5 uh this is
the type of player that she is also she
doesn't really like to defend in this
type of cramped positions she's always
looking for something active and this is
the right solution in this particular
case go C5 put some pressure in the
center I like this move but again I
don't like that move H6 the combination
of she was doing fine now she's slightly
worse still the position remains very
complex uh but this move C5 the last one
that we've just seen is the important uh
step in the right direction from begy if
after the move C5 uh Arena Crush Was to
play A2 A3 okay and try to win the two
Bishops how does that how would that uh
well I can start with C takes D4 right
you cannot take on B4 because I'm
actually taking Knight on E5 not not the
one on C3 right not here because then
you can take but here that attacks the
bishop as well this is very good for uh
black right so now you probably have to
take recapture yeah and now that I
isolated Queen Pawn Yeah uh my diagonal
to go back to f8 is an option you can
also take on C3 though I'm not 100% sure
whether I would do that or not the
engine is saying yes Bishop takes C3 no
problem but from a practical perspective
I don't like this move so Bishop mostly
because of Bishop takes two Bishops but
okay two Bishops and you have to be very
concrete you have to go B5 but I'm
starting to see some Queen F3 ideas I
don't really like it I don't like
playing chest like this right so I don't
think she's going to do that if she goes
A3 I think we're going to see something
like this right which by the way again
iated Queen Pawn the engine is saying we
don't like this position is not fun
Bishop B1 A7 exactly right that's can be
very dangerous I think I think you were
talking you were showing it is that you
both had the same idea Bishop B1 queen
queen very typical idea yeah Bishop A2
Bishop B1 Queen to C2 that's a problem
and the issue for Black's position is
that you don't have B5 as easily to get
this bishop out because of this move
Knight to C6 Queen F3 combin que F3
Knight C6 it's not looking good uh I
have to say if they go to this position
I will start being worried for uh
Black's chance
now take a look at Carissa's game for a
second just toep those important two
games for just a second because this
absolutely crazy this is the game
between na Nazi p and Talia cantes it
started off with this H4 you can tell us
the story of this H4 that you saw just a
few years ago and you were shocked yeah
that you can actually play like this
against kn6 G6 but you can and it's one
of the main lines it's amazing B5 and we
go into this some sort of a bank Co
style uh with this move H4 included is
considered to be a better version for
black H5 Naz is throwing caution to the
Wi she like okay I've had a rough go in
this year's championship I might as well
have some fun right and that's exactly
what she's doing right now G4 Bishop H6
okay get that pawn as what why not H5
Bishop H3 Knight F6 Queen D2 you know
what I'm doing I'm coming to check Queen
H6 and throwing the kitchen sink I'm
coming to Checkmate You Queen H6 Knight
G5 Rook F4 sacrifice and Checkmate
caveman chest that is the way to go in
on the other hand Talia she also didn't
have such a great tournament so she's
now I'm capturing everything and I hope
I
survive I'm going to die with a fulltime
that's exactly what she's doing King G7
long Castle it no long castle Yeah she
played it they're having fun right now
you know somewhere pal beno's turning
over in his grave and he's saying you
know I created a Frank Stein what the
heck is going you can't play H4 H5 you
can't Castle long in a b Gambit is white
it seems like you can by the way guess
what's the computer I was about to say I
saw the three zeros and I'm going like
it's obviously an equal position
obviously they should see the best move
in the position yeah no that's not going
to happen because I was thinking what do
you want to do for a black actually in
this position it's not going to go D6 I
would probably play D6 and Rook h8 just
just to defend my King I don't I'm not
sure and Bishop but these are the type
of ideas that are coming right Knight G5
Rook G1 Bishop to E6 at some point so we
may need that Bishop on C8 yes just to
cover the E6 Square this game doesn't
matter as much for the standings but
it's such a fun game to play right now
see that's why and I really do mean this
that's why I really think there ought to
be in chess constantly in all of these
national championships brilliancy prizes
agree because even if you're having a
terrible tournament like these two
ladies you can have a lot of fun and win
a brilliant game and you know win a
thousand bucks I don't care I just don't
want to be the judge then all the
players come screaming to me well you
didn't see my game that was also
brilliant and this was brilliant and
here we have a I think that's nassi uh
she's Che out all the games kind of
thinking not sitting next to the board
right uh seeing all the monitors okay
let's go around the horn here and uh
we're going to start with your favorite
opening um Christian the French defense
and I think these are also having fun Ru
Yen and uh tatv uh take us from the top
what's the theory say about this uh
steinet uh variation of the or the most
classical variation I want to say of the
French but this one involves Rook B8
that move is a little bit peculiar for
my eyes I mean A7 A6 Bishop E7 I've even
seen morich play lines with B7 B6 but
Rook B8 okay that's a wrinkle that I'm
not familiar with Queen A5 and Away you
go B4 Knight D2 usually the fight in
these particular lines really revolves
around the D4 Square mhm Bishop a A6 now
this is a move we can support right
right the bishop on C8 that's a bad
Bishop you do want to trade that Bishop
for White's light Square Bishop but
white getting ready to push that F5 Pawn
there it all goes and something tells me
that yeah that everybody has played I
want to say so accurately up to now that
I got a feel that they're still in the
theory uh oh you're not usually white
gets not in theory what when white gets
F5 in French that's usually signals that
white is doing really well okay help me
out here Kate I'm a French defense
player I don't want to see the move F6
if I I want a castle right that's what I
want to do I want to save King but I
just know that whenever I castle and
there's a Pawn on F6 I don't know what
to call it but it ain't
safe I'm going to so I have to if I'm
tev I I have to oops sorry I did it
wrong chop it off the board I have to
chop it off the board chop it off the
board
and you know stop you from playing F6
but if I do get to Castle put my knight
on E6
well I'm not unhappy take it away Kate
what is uh Ru yyang going to do I'm a PA
up right so I'm thinking about playing
Maybe not immediately but A3 is like a
move I would like to do because if you
recapture I recapture with rook and I'm
very happy yes right but now you would
probably play B3 and the Knight is still
active on C5 so fair I play B3 right yes
uh only because I really don't like
activating my opponent's pieces and I do
like well my Rook could be activated on
the B3 Square so oh you know what
actually let's play that B3 okay you got
it A3 B3 if I go C4 here C4 okay I'm
keep shutting everything you're trying
to do I keep shutting you down sorry I I
knight uh D3 Knight to D3 oh okay
um very very
cool very cool I'm I I didn't know if I
should
be I'm a pawn Grabber gosh I just it's
it's my worst my most Bas self but I am
a pawn up you got to kill me if I do get
castles if I do get castles of kind of
happy M Rook F4 Rook F4 and away we go
Rook F4 Knight E6 and away yeah well I'm
not even castled yet I'm getting ready I
me you're preparing the red carpet
treatment for my Ki uh we'll keep an eye
on that one again just before I I go on
a break I just did want to check in one
more time with the game of Fabby because
again this game between Fabby and Mishra
so very very important for uh first
place
we did
see uh A7
A6 okay that's kind of standard stuff
right uh Kate we're we're eyeballing uh
B5 possibilities Faby play a move Rook
B1 that's already something that black
can nibble on because we were thinking
that the Rooks belong on C1 and D1 but
you can also place the other Rook to C1
right have Rooks on B1 and C1 and try to
push for that B4 okay and and uh one of
the things I was explaining that
strategically speaking that black
aspires to trade minor pieces so the
move Knight G4 has a very concrete idea
Knight E5 let me trade a pair of knights
and then then the bind be becomes less
oppressive um coach uh after the move
Knight G4 just a quick how do the
engines feel about the position um in
fact uh close to equality after after
Queen we to and again this is a slow
position I wouldn't say it's necessarily
equal by any means uh it's it's a
complex position middle game position
and both sides have their chances uh but
I do like what black is doing as you're
uh saying the grip is not as oppressive
after we exchange some pieces right in
the position and then I can start
focusing on opening things up with B5 at
the right moment of course and white is
going to do everything that he can to
stop that probably at some point he's
going to go A4 try to uh put that grip
on the position Knight G5 we're
expecting I mean you just play the move
Knight to G4 you might as well follow it
up with knight uh E5 I guess one more
option would be to go crazy with a move
F5 but I'm not convinced this is the
right choice at the same time he could
look he's
young he's ready you know he's ready to
fight why not a win and we're talking
about one of the great historical
stories of all time absolutely year old
DE the question is how much he wants to
risk right right if he really wants to
play for that win or if he's just like
okay let's just keep a draw and maneuver
because F5 is clearly saying like I'm
going to risk and I'm going to go for it
wow big big big uh moments there after
Knight G4 Queen E2 uh we've come to that
uh uh moment in our broadcast when we
get ready for a break but before we go
on a break normally we going to take a
look at the specials that are available
at outique stl.com this one is the US
Championship oversized button Downs try
out a brand new look with one of these
oversized button-down long sleeve shirts
from the 2023 US champ championships
this thick collared shirt comes in both
men's and women's Styles sporting on the
Hem either the logo of the 2023 us Chess
Championship open field or women's field
respectively the official logo of the St
Louis chess club can also be found on
the nape at the neck you know I need one
of those shirts and I want the ladies to
sign their shirt I want the open remind
me of the opening ceremonies to get all
of the signatures you mean the closing
the closing sorry yeah that
one the closing uh as we go on break I
want to tell you so a peek ahead we're
going to have a very very special guest
in studio coming up and I think you're
going to enjoy our guest see you on the
side of the
[Music]
break Alice thank you so much for
joining me today I want to ask you a
little bit about your chess upbringing
there's been a lot talked about you in
the media but I want to hear again from
you I started playing chess when I was 6
years old um so my brother was going to
the school chess club and I went to law
also because my parents just wanted to
drop us up at the same time um so after
I started playing in the chess club I
was actually like one of the very worst
and uh for me it was just I lost a lot I
was kind of upset but um as I kept uh
actually not losing every single game I
became more motivated and eventually I
played in my first rated tournament uh
that summer and from there I think it
was just I really loved the game which
allowed me to continue to uh enjoy chess
while playing it very nice and how did
you get into playing a lot online and
how do you combine that with u studying
over the board yeah um so I think
especially in the recent years there's
been a lot of uh new chess resources
both online and also books published um
so for me I did go over some uh books
for example the 100 end games you must
know um and Mauricio Flores uh construct
book um I also use like uh some online
tools for example chess Tempo and chess
AO um I think they have a lot of great
resources and for me uh I think
especially in this new generation uh
where everything is just so much
stronger it's really great to have all
these new resources and you're spending
a lot of time online could you give me
an approximate U amount of time that you
spend for day working on chess um so
actually this year I'm doing online
school so it makes it flexible for my
schedule um so I guess before high
school started I was spending like a
couple hours a day on CH sometimes more
especially during the summer when I was
playing in a lot of tournaments uh now
the high school is started uh it's more
work um so I have to I guess find a new
balance since for me it's my first year
and I haven't really had to do something
like this in the past um but I hope that
uh at least I'll be able to find some
sort of balance between school work and
chess and I'll be able to at least play
well in this tournament you've had some
amazing results lately congratulations
for winning gold medal uh at the women's
world team championship how was that how
did you feel that moment yeah so that
was actually like the first tournament
that I played in uh like internationally
on that stage so I think it was really
great for me to be able to do so well
there and of course it was like a really
great experience to be playing on the
first board against such strong players
um I I definitely wasn't expecting to uh
win the met there I was just hoping you
know I could at least do okay um but uh
for me it was great that uh I was able
to have like really good results and it
was my first like really really strong
it was a really great experience for me
do you feel nervous at all or did you
feel at that time nervous because you're
you know representing the United States
and it was your first competition of of
this kind yeah I mean uh so beforehand I
actually thought I was playing on the
second board so like okay not as much
pressure and then when I went there I
was like oh I'm playing number one okay
um so it is a team event and there's
something nice which is that um even if
you don't have your desired result you
can still hope that your teammates also
do well um of course there's a little
bit more pressure as well because you
want to win for your team um but for me
I was just like trying to focus game at
the game and I was able to like find I
guess uh a good start and then after
that I think I just got a some good
results very very awesome
congratulations again for that I want to
ask you one more thing regarding this
tournament um so last year as you
mentioned maybe your result wasn't as
great but you've had a great uh year
where you've improved a lot um I think
you were supposed to get your
International Master title very soon and
this year you're one of the favorites do
you feel any pressure at all or have you
been able by now to deal with all your
emotions and are you just going to take
it a day a game at yeah uh so so last
year I think a lot more inexperience and
this year I've played in like a lot more
strong tournaments so I have slightly
more experience I mean uh for me I guess
I am one of the top Seas but I don't
think I'm like the very favorite so
that's something that's kind of nice
because I don't have so much like
pressure that everybody expects me to
win um and I guess for this tournament
well I think winning would be nice I
it's also extremely hard because the
field is so strong um and for me I'll
just take it one game at a time and try
to play my best very nice thank you so
much Alice I wish you good luck and
looking forward to your
games
yeah um it's amazing what the club has
done for chess in general because I mean
it's already been 15 years and they've
done countless uh national championships
tournaments for juniors helping around
schools and they've just grown the game
so much across the United States I think
if I look at my own career and I look at
American chest in general we in a much
better place than we were 15 years ago
and so the contributions have been
immense and of course it's all thanks to
Dr Jun singfield and Rex
singfield I would say that S luia Club
is like a rock in the ocean of Chess and
we know that it's it's there it is there
it will be there I think it's sense a
hope that the the game of chess will
always stay flat by the mere fact of its
existence I think it it it sends
positive waves across the
[Music]
globe
the St Louis chess club is the Premier
chess facility in the United States we
bring the educational benefits of Chess
to thousands of students across the St
Louis area we also promote Chess at the
highest levels hosting all levels of the
US championships as well as high-profile
tournaments that attract the world's
best players become a member and enjoy
perks such as free classes and lectures
weekly tournaments and so much more
visit St Louis chess club.org to claim
your membership
today the World Chess Hall of Fame
located in the heart of St Louis's
historic Central West End want to know
why chess has intrigued people around
the world for nearly 1,500 years stop by
and learn about the impact of Chess from
our three floors showcasing the art
culture and history of the game the
World Chess Hall of Fame has something
for everyone to enjoy for more
information on current exhibits please
visit World Chess h.org
[Music]
the St Louis chess club Scholastic
program brings the educational value of
Chess to kids and schools across the St
Louis area active in over 100 schools
throughout the St Louis city and county
the St Louis chess club has been able to
reach over 85,000 students in both in
school and after school programs we
created the select chess training
program and the junior select chess
training program in order to elevate the
skill level in students across the St
Louis area these students receive
professional training from Grandmaster
verua niobian other programs include
chess cops a partnership with the St
Louis Police Department looking to
improve relationships between atrisk
kids and police officers in the St Louis
area with over 600 students playing
chess over the board since
2019 the St Louis chess club has also
created a chess merit badge for the
scouts BSA quickly becoming one of the
most popular badges with more than
250,000 Scouts earning the badge since
2011 students of chess can also pick up
a copy of read and write chess thanks to
Club co-founder Dr jeie Ken sinkfield
anyone can learn how to understand chess
notation in no time we view chess as a
valuable educational tool learn more
about our Scholastic programming by
visiting St Louis chess club.org
education
St Louis the chess capital of the United
States boasts the worldclass St Louis
chess club and the World Chess Hall of
Fame it also plays host to an
award-winning shop dedicated to chess
merchandise All Occasion gifts and
plenty more at Q Boutique you can shop
both in store and online for chess
merchandise autograph Collectibles chess
campus souvenirs and much much more from
quirky greeting car to luxury chest sets
there is something for everyone at Q
Boutique and all purchases go right to
benefiting new exhibitions and programs
at the World Chess Hall of Fame
dedicated to exploring chess and its
immense impact on art and culture
located on the first floor of the World
Chess Hall of Fame enjoy a shopping
experience like no other and become
everyone's favorite Gift Giver if you
can shop in store make sure to check out
Q bouti stl.com for a wide variety of
gifts for everyone to to
[Music]
enjoy the St Louis chess club is the
Premier chess facility in the United
States and is among the best in the
world thanks to co-founders Dr jeie
Karen sinkfield and Rex singfield the St
Louis chess club is a nonprofit
organization committed to promoting the
game of chess locally and
internationally we bring the educational
benefits of Chess to thousands of
students across the St Louis area
promoting cognitive development critical
thinking concentration and analytical
skills the St Louis chess club welcomes
chess lovers of any age and skill level
to come and enjoy the game of chess we
also promote Chess at the highest levels
hosting all levels of the US
championships and the American Cup as
well as high-profile tournaments that
attract the world's best players
including the prestigious sinkfield cup
Ken's cup and many more all tournaments
can be streamed via our YouTube and
twitch channels that also include over
2,000 chess lectures for anyone to enjoy
become a member and enjoy perks such as
free classes and lectures weekly
tournaments merchandise discounts and so
much more visit St Louis chess club.org
to claim your membership
[Music]
today the World Chess Hall of Fame
located in the heart of St Louis's
historic Central West End want to know
why chess has intrigued people around
the world for nearly 1,500 years stop by
and learn about the impact of Chess from
our three floors showcasing the art
culture and history of the game
landmarked by the world's largest chess
piece sitting outside our front door the
World Chess Hall of Fame has something
for everyone to enjoy including various
exhibitions monthly concerts and much
more whether you are a beginner or a
professional there is something for
everyone to learn here at the World
Chess Hall of Fame enjoy free admission
to our rotating exhibitions in our
Galleries and sign up for chess events
family-friendly programming and art
classes and don't forget to stop by our
award-winning gift shop Q Boutique and
Shop a wide selection of Chess related
merchandise for more information on
current exhibits please visit World
Chess h.org
hello everyone and welcome back to our
live coverage of the 2023 national
championships we have our first result
in round 10 but first let's take a look
at the standings start with the ladies
yes let's take a look so we have a so
leader here beim to chova five
consecutive wins absolutely fantastic
performance so far eight out of n i mean
everybody accolades I mean you can't say
anything more and for
she's saying to herself I've got 7 and a
half out of nine why aren't I in clear
first if she was in the open section
with that amount of points that will be
enough she secure first but now she's
second and then we have a two-way tie
for the third place arena crash and
Alice Lee with five and a half points
and in uh the open section uh the
current standings here the leader is
Fabiano Carana with six and a half
points and Then followed by group of
three people wesle saw Lenard Dominguez
and ab Manu
with five and half Jeffrey Jang as you
see and Sam Sean have already agreed to
the Hing of the point those two players
came incredibly well prepared they just
zip through what I want to say the first
15 moves and both gain time on the clock
uh very balanced Affair throughout uh
early draw and uh let's go Around the
Horn uh take it away uh Christian uh
what caught your eye in this round t
let's talk about this one right the
aronian versus Shanklin actually we're
going to talk about all of them um this
one I think we left it after Bishop to
G4 and F3 was the move uh chosen by
aronian Queen to E1 was an option as
well Bishop to F5 and queen to E1 so he
did spot this idea of Queen to E1 very
important one Bishop to G6 once again
you cannot take on D5 because of Rook to
E5 and there's no way to defend both
pieces you can go Bishop to E6
unfortunately that drops after Rook
takes D6 so that's a problem he played
Bishop G6 C4 solidifying uh the extra
Pawn in the center Knight to E4 Queen to
D4 this is what we have right now Knight
to F6 is the move that I expect in the
position it's uh the easiest way out if
you want to put it that abolutely I'm a
pawn up I want to exchange pieces how do
I do that Knight to F6 and the thing is
if you do take with a queen the problem
is after Queen to C3 very natural move
it's a very natural move we're entering
most likely into this end game unless
you want to allow me to push if you try
to avoid the queen trade then I push D4
Rook to D1 it's looking good right as
you said Knight takes F6 check on theard
yes yes and if you do take with a G Pawn
the problem is I can just simply go
Queen to F2 you're not touching the pawn
on D3 anytime soon because of Rook to D1
setting up the pin that's game over
right so I'm still a pawn up I do expect
him to take with the G Pawn just because
of the simple fact that he wants to keep
that grip on the Square D4 with the
queen there I'm expecting G takes F6
still a pawn up for leevon Queen to F2
is coming at some point I'm going to
move that Rook from E3 and I'm going to
exchange the Queens it's looking really
good for leavon and unfortunately Sam is
simply just a pawn down in this case
let's see what happened in the Fabby
versus Mishra game we left it off
somewhere around here after Queen to E2
we were uh yeah getting ourselves
excited hting with ideas such as F5 this
is an interesting one and you yes
or yeah I took it very deeply I was
having fun with the computer the
computer at Knight D5 Rook on A8 to E8 e
takes F5 Rook takes
F uh H3 yeah Knight E5 and it wanted
Knight takes E5 yes Rook takes E5 some
crazy stuff actually was Knight E3 funn
oh Knight E3 here okay Knight E3
Knight D4 que this is some computer no
yeah this is computer energy and I I was
showing you this line B5 Bishop C3
because hey if you're going to analyze
deeply you might as well go all the way
Rook E4 and I turned to you and I said
Christian after F5 this is the best you
can get with white are you happy with
this your your your major pieces are all
in the first Rank and black has got his
pieces in good shape he did not play A5
and you know it's such a difficult
question to answer In the Heat of the
battle right how much risk are you going
to take both as ABI Manu and as Fabby uh
in this instance as well because again
it's the last couple of rounds you don't
have a lot of room for error and none of
the players are willing to take huge
risks in this case look I don't think
Mishra came into this game and said I
need to beat Fabby at all costs with the
black pieces to try to catch him no he's
having a fantastic event so far
if he finishes first obviously that's
incredible if he finishes second that's
also Sensational right so he's not
taking as many risks that's why I don't
think he played the move F5 but that's
where uh Champions are forged that's
true you know you've got to take if you
want the championship sometimes you just
got to take risk those are decisions
very difficult decision it just felt
like that was a moment it was a moment
Perhaps Perhaps absolutely F5 was an
option he played Rook fc8 Knight D5 and
now we have Queen to D so he's saying
okay I'm going to take it slowly I'm
going to defend I'm going to stay a
little bit passive for the duration of
the middle game and then at the right
moment maybe I will find a way to strike
back oh yeah Bobby I think is happy with
the position no big major weaknesses in
his Camp right now but Fab is losing a
little bit too much time now ask you a
good point he has 45 minutes whereas
Mishra has 59 minutes so wise Mishra can
come out of this opening Pat himself on
the back and say you know I went
toe-to-toe with one of the greatest
theoreticians in the world and I was
ahead on the clock and this is only move
14 so still plenty of moves to go so
impressive thus far uh continuing our
look we've got the game of Ray uh Robson
and lanir lanir comes into today's round
in second place thinking to himself okay
Ray has to be a little bit wobbly after
losing uh from a winning position
essentially against Wesley so uh I'll
play solid and I'll hope that Ray you
know Miss time something maybe Ray will
just get into a lot of time trouble by
the way we didn't mention it but we've
got our two time trouble uh players
against one another players playing on
one second on one increment yeah who who
do you like in terms of getting the time
travel more you got to put your you got
to wage on one of these players who's
going to get into time trouble between
or they both I feel like Ry know what
he's doing because he prepared this A4
A5 move so he should be more familiar
with these positions right so I would
guess that lener is the one who's going
to get first into time trouble okay well
it's early days and we've just seen the
move rookie 8 still a very balanced
Affair in this one we're going to go to
Wesley so again uh he comes into from a
fortunate position let's let's be fair
uh hey you know in second place like
this is this is like great if you're
very happy for surviving yesterday's
game right and you know maybe
opportunity is knocking he's playing
against Hans nean when we left it we
left it in a position very similar to
this one H H6 H3 was played uh a move
that you kind of aspired for but I think
your approach was different than the one
Wesley took he said I want to recapture
the queen I've got this really ugly
pawns on E5 and E6 but they are
controlling key squares and the fact
that they are doubled means that the
dynamic potential of the queen is may be
worth right and we can also kind of
Target that pawn on D3 because if I
recapture with Pawn on D4 then that pawn
is covered but right now the queen is
targeting it The Rook can develop and um
attack it so let's just say uh I'll play
the most obvious move I defend B2 I'll
defend more importantly I think F2 I
just don't want to see you know you know
something crashing into my position on
the F2 Square maybe Knight D7 here and
I'll Target the C7 F okay Knight to D7
now I actually have to think what I I
want to do this queen is just I find the
the the the the queen simply too
powerful and I want to play the move
Knight E2 I don't want to hang my Pawn
on F2 first though I see that you've got
your own Ambitions so I'll curtail
Knight C5 for the time being I'll just
develop my Rook M Rook ad8 oh boy I was
actually thinking you were going to play
Rook A5 Rook ad d8 you know I can almost
resist everything but okay uh Rook E3
because I do once again want to get rid
of this this I think very powerful Queen
on the D3 Square on the D4 Square sorry
mm now we are actually surviving or kind
of accomplishing that Knight E2 I
thought I'm gonna get my knight C5 I
want to be really Happ by the way Queen
C2 Knight D7 we only permit ourselves to
say this once per broadcast these guys
are really really good so instead of
Rook d8 maybe after Rook C1 I'm going to
play B6 first B7 B6 B7 B6 because I
really want to get that Knight to C5 yes
you do and that makes a a really a a lot
of sense to me
I will once again I'll go for the same
stuff Rook E3 Knight E2 I'm assuming
your Queen's going to go backwards and
again I I feel that this Pawn is just
like I don't know I've got to do
something including moves like Rook D1
and D4 just I mean I hate UND doubling
your pawns but I don't like the weakness
on D3 either so I'll trade off my
weakness for your weakness and
maybe we'll we'll call it a balanced
game Christian uh over to you and uh
tell us what caught your eye in the open
section well let's look at the Ladi in
the Ladi section yes yes let's take look
at What's happen there uh we left it off
in this game between Irena and beg him
some around here C5 we said we like this
decision by beg him A3 was an option she
played the move Bishop to B3 a little
bit more strin but okay again the
followup should have been and this is by
the way not an easy move to make B5
apparently is the best move in the
position Knight C6 allowing Knight to C6
to my eyes this is not practical right
but she played the move Queen to
E7 which allows A3 so I'm a bit worried
about her chances right now because we
were discussing after this A3 you take
take and then maybe you get the bishop
back how do you get the bishop back now
you don't get the bishop back right so
you have to go to uh D6 the problem is
F4 right now looks very
attack also Rook to E1 looks very
tempting you cannot touch the Knight on
E5 taking with the Knight obviously
that's losing after not so attractive
either and with the queen on E7 I mean
and The Rook on E1 things are starting
to look a little bit dangerous up yeah
exactly uncoordinated in the position so
I'm not a big fan of this last move
Queen to E7 and I have to say again I'm
looking at the time beim generally plays
quite quickly right now she's taking her
time so there's definitely she's feeling
the pressure uh and the position is not
easy either so Arena definitely got what
she wanted out of the opening let's see
what Anna versus uh Karissa are doing in
this important matchup and we have this
one this is the position and I do
remember this game between begim and
Karissa from the 2021 US Women's Chess
Championship it was a very similar
structure coming from the Kings Indian
with uh G3 and it was a squeeze by begim
with the white pieces in the exact same
structure right now we see Karissa
spending some time she uh played this
move Queen to H3 F3 seems to be the
right decision in this position you want
to defend against Knight G4 Knight G4
ideas of that nature and then you can
always get the queen to G2 to try to
exchange the Queens still seeing Anna as
having a more comfortable position for
the simple fact that you have some
pressure on the queen side you have some
more space on the queen side and I don't
see Black's attack on the king side
right I don't see the compensation for
the lack of space white slightly better
again we were discussing the strategy of
these two players at the beginning of
the show Karissa definitely wants to get
a victory in this one Anna is a little
bit vulnerable in this one she hasn't
really scored very well in the
tournament Karissa wants to take
advantage of that Anna says okay I'm
going to Blackmail you with the
tournament situation I know you want to
win I'm going to play a very uh peaceful
very simple position I want to keep
things simple keep the structures
symmetrical and that's what she's doing
in this one I like what Anna is doing so
looking at these two games beg him not
doing very well right now against Arena
definitely arena with the higher chances
and Anna Karissa still battling this
very complex situation well as you came
into the show you uh said in the
head-to-head matchup between Arena and
beum Arena's actually maybe beam's most
difficult opponent yes yes and uh not
not and we were talking about the
challenge that that she would have the
mindset that she would have and you said
just play solid because take a look I
mean two wins no losses two draws three
out of four meetlo said two out of three
a great those four games were in fact um
the American Cup okay and she eliminated
her twice not once but twice in the
American Cup so definitely a very diff
difficult opponent for exactly and do
and then again as you were just pointing
out the Karissa uh matchup between an
satony they've never drawn one another I
mean decisive games for all around out
of the three they played three out of
three F2 F3 on the board by the way in
the in the game no not yet Queen to H I
mean it's Anna she's going to spend some
time that know but one thing I was
actually looking at Anna has 40 minutes
which is a lot of time giving move 17 I
was expecting maybe a little bit less
yes yes still Karissa almost 20 minutes
more than Anna but definitely Anna
keeping it close and that's important
because again Anna has been allowing
herself to go down through last 5
minutes with 20 minut cost her points
that's not practical you cannot play at
the highest level of this competition
like that no exactly I wanted to turn
our attention in the game of Jennifer Yu
and Alice Lee Alice Lee came into this
competition it's clearly one of the fa
we Alice Lee was having her life oh yes
and a very very good pick insightful
shows understanding not even close
because uh beum and Carissa ran away
with the tournament but she's up against
the defending Champion Jennifer you you
know Jennifer is you know I that they're
just players who love to fight and I
look at Jennifer's games and it doesn't
matter if she's like in the last place
she's she's in an Armageddon
she's just fighting all the time and
it's great incredibly strong at the end
of the tournament I think at the US
Championship she always wins like last
three rounds or something she just have
she just has really strong finish she's
up against uh Alice Le she has the white
pieces castles let's just uh catch up
with what they've done at this exact
moment you know you just got to like
White's position wh's got this uh Cent
Pond duo in the middle of the board it
would be very very nice if we could
somehow now establish a knight on E5 and
the other Knight coming to F3 she played
E5 now this is a very committal decision
of course and her intention was to
settle on two key outposts the D6 square
and the C5 Square in return Alice says
hey I've got a pretty out pretty nice
Outpost myself KN F4 and let me
eliminate your knight too and I'll go
back now the question is you want to
take my knight no G2 Bishop is very
strong on e4 Rook A7 an indication that
just a little bit uncomfortable with the
pin the same time she just didn't want
to give up the a file by just moving
away Knight H4 and we've caught up with
the players your immediate take on this
one if you would rather have white or
black I would rather have white you like
the space I like the space I like the
bishop I'm not sure how to continue but
now seeing Knight H4 I feel like
Jennifer wants to play F4 and F5 okay
just to push and get a active position
uh the other way I would look at this
this move I mean she hasn't given up her
ambition of getting a knight to the D6
Square so I'm going to make a very bad
move for Alice that is a very bad move
Alice that will not play that move but
one idea that uh Jennifer could have is
finally get to the D6 get to the D6
Square you know but eliminate the night
on the way so that the E6 Pawn uh gives
up the control of the F5 score and the
Knight settles comfortably on D6 I like
Jennifer's position too but I'm I'm I'm
a little bit un undecided about the move
E4 E5 that's one of those things I'll
tell you in five moves whether or not it
turned out uh to be uh a good decision
because it allows a lot of captures and
that frees up Black's positions exactly
right so sometimes maybe we can wait but
I think Jennifer is doing okay here more
than okay for sure Rook D7 by the way an
indication that Bishop takes Rook takes
she's
not ready to uh allow the Knight to F5
uh
ashria uh versus interesting position
very open wow I'm just still how did the
players get here somehow there was a
knight on F5 that's interesting and talk
talk and
H I think black is actually doing pretty
okay here yeah because it's getting the
Knight to C5 yes the Knight can come to
C5 maybe the queen can I don't know even
settle on the H4 Square I could get that
those moves in I think I'm prefering how
fast are you so if I go Queen F3 right
now okay oops um I will
allow okay I I'll start with Knight C5
cuz I want to bring the you want to go
Queen F3 in this case okay let's go
let's have some fun Queen H4 gift me the
bishop I want to bring my Rook to
E8 maybe so I can if I want I can
capture on E5 let's try it let's try
let's go Knight B5 Knight B5
and F5 okay D6 D6 okay I do get to uh
fasten a knight on on the D3 square
but should I play Rook D1 or Rook d8 or
not as a
[Music]
Prelude I'm having trouble here I I see
two attractive options right Queen can
come to C4 Pawn can come to D3 and I can
just make developing moves so let me
make a developing
move no Queen D5 excuse me Queen D5
apologies you got me Queen D5 you didn't
even see that move yes that's a good one
no that was because I was leaving a Pawn
on pre uh the training is don't leave
Pawn on pre uh Queen C4 uh jump in on
this one uh Christian how does uh how
how do the how does the engine like the
ashria versus ausa Battle let's take a
look uh
equal zero zero you're okay I'm not
coming to you anymore exactly but I'm
coming to you right now right all right
I'm going to quiz you quiz uh put
yourself both of you in Fab's shoes
right you're in the situation where
you're a point point up going the last
rounds excellent now you're looking at
this position this is the Hans Neiman
versus Wesley so game how do you
assess I well black just did a great
thing for himself he went A3 takes B2 so
he improved his pond structure
tremendously okay how would you assess
his chances Wesley's chances to win
this
game win is strong I wouldn't say it's
winning no I would say maybe more
comfortable all right yeah I also think
that it's slightly better for black I
like the pressure on but both sides have
weaknesses that the the E pawns are
doubled and C7 is vulnerable okay
perfect now you go back to your board
and you have this position and by the
way excuse me not this position cuz he
just played the move Bishop to C3 was
the last move that we've seen take and
take with the B Pawn wow that's Knight
B6 is coming be careful a remarkable
move Rook a B8 was played so now you see
that Wesley slightly better may be
playing for a victory with the black pce
against Hans nean you have the option of
signing the score sheets basically right
now Knight B6 Rook C7 Knight D5 Rook D7
or Rook C C8 Knight D6 then that's your
draw right you at least eliminate or
very close to eliminating Mishra right
at least for a Ty for the gold medal of
course for the gold medal or you can
also play this move C5 that was just
played in the position of Pawn sacrifice
wow and throwing the gauntlet
immediately and he says yeah you know
what I want to clinch the title today
he's playing C5 and this is a great move
best move by uh the engine by the way
the idea that if you do take with the
pawn you're opening up the dile and
that's more than enough compensation in
fact that's decisive compensation for
White Knight to B6 Rook to C7 I can
start with H3 I can also throw in this
nice idea Knight to G5 where do you put
the Knight if you go back to F6 E5 is
coming but I can also throw uh Rook D1
first where does the queen go E8 most
likely E5 E6 domination complete
domination this game over right E6
Knight to D5 is an option as well but
this is more than over so what do you do
after Knight G5 you took I attack your
Rook you save your exchange Knight G5
yeah Knight a yeah Knight I don't have
many squares if you go here and you try
to go Knight D7 I go once again Rook D1
Queen E8 what else Queen E8 F4 Knight D
Knight D7 Knight D5 everything comes
with Tempo Rook to C8
E5 I'm breaking open the position I'm
checkmating you right now it just
doesn't feel nice at all no not at all
not at all and this having all the fun
exactly so C5 is the position right now
that we have on the board Fabiano is
really taking matters into his own hands
right now he wants to win this one he
wants to win the national title today uh
I Christian I agree with you that D6
takes C5 is wrong I'm looking at Black's
Rooks on B8 C8 yes I have to open up the
position for my Rooks Knight C6 to E5
with the idea of Rook takes C5 Knight
takes Knight takes F4 yes okay how I'm
again I'm not a very happy Knight D7
question is how how happy are you right
take my knight is on D5 I continue yes
you just continue I continue pushing I
want to break the position open as f as
possible your knight on D5 is really
good yeah this position looks fantastic
and the problem is after you put the
Knight on E5 it's very beautiful and
everything but I do have ideas of Queen
E3 at the right moment F6 Knight is
coming to E7 as well with a check so you
have to worry about that Queen coming to
H6 there's a lot of pressure in the
position against black species doesn't
seem like you're well coordinated I was
happy with the Rook on C8 but the Knight
on D5 turned out to be a beast yes and I
like Christian when you were talking
about the C5 move and whether Fab is
going to repeat or not I was thinking
that you know of course uh maybe with a
draw he can also be clinching the title
here but he's looking forward to play
the candidates he wants to play the
world championship match he wants to win
it like he needs to practice those
difficult situations and not just settle
with someone who is even uh lower rated
than he is exactly well I mean leavon
Aron and also very similar philosophical
approach that you want to be forged in
you know battle and the more difficult
battles you're you're you're you're
facing and playing uh the better you you
are when the the candidates in the world
championships come around because you
well in those critical moments exactly a
great uh move by C5 by the way what
should Mishra play because the
variations that you were showing best
move Knight F6 is the best move get rid
of that Knight on D5 but this is not a
move you make almost you almost never
make this move because you see this you
kind of stop that's it right you stop I
mean do you go do you really want to
play with this Pawn on D6 not especially
I don't think so no no I first of all I
don't see him touching this Knight and
going to F6 right like from a practical
perspective this is not the move that
anybody does just for a simple fact that
you allow that pawn on D6 that's a thorn
in your position for the remainder of
the game not looking good yeah so even
okay objectively white is better but
even from a practical perspective the
position becomes extremely difficult to
play with black there's just simply too
many things hanging in the area and from
my own experience when I see these type
of positions I usually see them collapse
for black within five to 10 moves
exactly so the next sequence of moves is
going to be extremely important whether
Mishra is going to be able to calm the
position down maybe at the expense of
some material disadvantage but at least
not get checkm not allow Fabiano to
break through to his great credit Mishra
did not collapse against Sam Shanklin
and he had every right to collapse in
fact he fought his way back and won the
game we're going to take a quick break
why because we have a special guest in
studio we want to get set up for that
special guest we'll see on the other
side very
shortly
[Music]
yeah
yeah um it's amazing what the club has
done for chess in general because I mean
it's already been 15 years and they've
done countless uh national championships
tournaments for juniors helping gr
schools and they've just grown the game
so much across the United States I think
if I look at my own career and I look at
American because in general we're in a
much better place than we were 15 years
ago and so the contributions have been
immense and of course it's all thanks to
uh Dr J singfield and Rex
singfield I would say that S luas Club
is like a rock in the ocean of Chess and
we know that it's it's there it is there
it will be there I think it's sense a
hope that the game of chess will always
stay AF flat by the mere fact of its
existence I think it it it it's sense
positive waves across the
[Music]
globe the St Louis chess club is the
Premier chess facility in the United
States we bring the educational benefits
of Chess to thousands of students across
the St Louis area we also promote Chess
at the highest levels hosting all levels
of the US championships as well as
high-profile tournaments that attract
the world's best players become a member
and enjoy perks such as free classes and
lectures weekly tournaments and so much
more visit St Louis chess club.org to
claim your membership today the World
Chess Hall of Fame located in the heart
of St Louis's historic Central West End
want to know why chess's intrigued
people around the world for nearly 1,500
years stop by and learn about the impact
of Chess from our three floors
showcasing the art culture and history
of the game the World Chess Hall of Fame
has something for everyone to enjoy for
more information on current exhibits
please visit World Chess h.org
the St Louis chess club Scholastic
program brings the educational value of
Chess to kids and schools across the St
Louis area active in over 100 schools
throughout the St Louis city and county
the St Louis chess club has been able to
reach over 85,000 students in both in
school and after school programs we
created the select chess training
program and the junior select chess
training program in order to elevate the
skill level in students across the St
Louis area these students receive
professional training from Grandmaster
verua niobian other programs include
chess cops a partnership with the St
Louis Police Department looking to
improve relationships between atrisk
kids and police officers in the St Louis
area with over 600 students playing
chess over the board since 2019 the St
Louis chess club has also created a
chess merit badge for the scouts BSA
quickly becoming one of the most popular
badges with more than 250,000 Scouts
earning the badge since 2011 students of
chess can also pick up a copy of read
and write chess thanks to Club
co-founder Dr jeie Karen sinkfield
anyone can learn how to understand chess
notation in no time we view chess as a
valuable educational tool learn more
about our Scholastic programming by
visiting St Louis chess club.org
[Music]
education St Louis the chess capital of
the United States boasts the worldclass
St Louis chess club and the World Chess
Hall of Fame it also plays host to an
award-winning shop dedicated to chess
merchandise All Occasion gifts and
plenty more at Q Boutique you can shop
both in store and online for chess merch
merchandise autograph Collectibles chess
campus souvenirs and much much more from
quirky greeting cards to luxury chess
sets there is something for everyone at
Q Boutique and all purchases go right to
benefiting new exhibitions and programs
at the World Chess Hall of Fame
dedicated to exploring chess and its
immense impact on art and culture
located on the first floor of the World
Chess Hall of Fame enjoy a shopping
experience like no other and become
everyone's favorite Gift Giver if you
can shop in store make sure to check out
Q bouti stl.com for a wide variety of
gifts for everyone to
[Music]
enjoy the St Louis chess club is the
Premier chess facility in the United
States and is among the best in the
world thanks to co-founders Dr jeie
Karen sinkfield and Rex sinkfield the St
Louis chess club is a nonprofit
organization committed to promoting the
game of chess locally and inter
internationally we bring the educational
benefits of Chess to thousands of
students across the St Louis area
promoting cognitive development critical
thinking concentration and analytical
skills the St Louis chess club welcomes
chess lovers of any age and skill level
to come and enjoy the game of chess we
also promote Chess at the highest levels
hosting all levels of the US
championships and the American Cup as
well as high-profile tournaments that
attract the world's best players years
including the prestigious sinkfield cup
Karen's cup and many more all
tournaments can be streamed via our
YouTube and twitch channels that also
include over 2,000 chess lectures for
anyone to enjoy become a member and
enjoy perks such as free classes and
lectures weekly tournaments merchandise
discounts and so much more visit St
Louis chess club.org to claim your
membership
today
[Music]
hello everyone and welcome back to our
live coverage of the 2023 national
championships well as promised we do
have a very special guest in studio the
founder of the St Louis chess club Rex
singfield Rex they just allow everybody
in
studio welcome welcome welcome well you
were trying to get a special person you
couldn't find him so you got I know I
know we we we we did our best Rex
seriously uh as we were coming into the
show we started talking what do we want
to discuss about and I said well just
you know the the the list of things that
you've done from the St Louis chess club
the World Chess Hall of Fame the S St
Louis University your uh truste there
then it started to become like Rex what
aren't you affiliated with here in St
Louis and you found one thing well I
said Washington you but there are a lot
of them that I'm not affiliated with a
lot of hospitals a lot of colleges yeah
there's a whole bunch of them none of
them want me so
you Rex I just got to say the studio
that was built here it's just fantastic
mean I know this is your first
experience what do you think with the
new cameras the whole thing I it's great
what's really special about it those who
got the world's three greatest
commentators I was
fishing for that compliment I saw the
hook
I very very Rex another national
championships they're they're brilliant
they just get better every year the
players came out they're fighting so
hard what's your looks like we're going
to have a repeat National Champion right
with possibly in the open section right
yeah the way Bob is doing a point ahead
exactly yeah and I think he's doing well
today in the game you were saying
exactly get was your pick at the
beginning
Rex am I not supposed to be notice I
said we're not piing notice that I said
am I not I didn't say aren't I people
say that to sound intelligent but it
actually makes them sound stupid okay I
vented on that um you've dodged the
question am I not supposed to be
officially
neutral yeah I don't know I didn't want
to put you on the spot so let let's C
that question all right okay one of the
things that you are on is the US chess
trust one of the things that the US
chess trust does is administer the
Sanford Fellowship one of the things
about uh the Sanford Fellowship is over
the years you they've given away so many
of the scholarships for the trust then
the trust has supported check this out
wow of all the Women's Champions of the
US Champions these are are winners of
the Sanford uh chess trust they get a
special um amount of money a large
amount of money to do training and you
can see you've just we have all the
crush Curry s Alice Lee Jennifer youu
they're currently playing in this
tournament exactly Alice Lee and Mishra
14 years old every one of them I know um
I mean it's almost like a a crystal ball
if you want to know who the future
champion I of American chess are just
look at who won the Sanford F we're like
a a training tournament here you know
exactly exactly so congratulations onk
you that performance now let's talk
about uh the um the St Louis uh chess
club for just a moment I mean coid
ruined everybody ruined everything we're
coming out of that we caught up last
year we had the 14 player Fields we've
got the grand chest T finishing the S
phield cup I know that's something that
you really enjoy I enjoy it right and uh
tell us about uh what's coming uh for
the
club in the months have St Louis rapid
and Blitz coming up exactly and then the
sinkfield cup I think that's the biggie
tournaments for the year then yeah
that's the Finish we get to hear
Christian Chilla one of the world's
greatest commentators
well him
back we already had Wesley So Yesterday
doing him a solid I mean you
know Wesley loves me I mean thank you re
for this compliments I really appreciate
that for sure right okay so you got the
grand chest tour that's completed but
that will be continuing uh next year I
know that one of your great Ambitions is
you know a repeat of 1886 at St Louis
hosting a world championship so that's
still on your uh that's still on my wish
list okay but I think we have to get a
St Louis to be in
it might be and I think we're we have a
good possibility of that exactly two or
three by way yeah so we have a
candidates coming up we will have Fabian
Karana there who already qualified we
may have hiara Kamura there who may
qualify by rating I believe uh how
amazing is that for I mean American
chess and the possibility for having a
world champion I think it's it's just
wonderful the only thing would be more
wonderful is I if I
qualify but that we don't have to worry
about that just a second let me call up
Vegas in the betting line yeah no but if
we have two candidates there that's
wonderful and uh be the second time for
Fabby think it be the first for Caro
wouldn't
it he qualified C before and we're still
not sure whether Hikaru will make it
right we got the Isle of Man of man is a
big one that's coming up hikaro and
Fabiano actually are final for position
in that one as well well but yes Fabiano
guaranteed he qualified through all the
memes necessary the World Cup a rating
probably he's going to qualify through
that as well and he's playing the Isle
of Man as well so he's trying to qualify
through every single means possible
exactly good for him quick question for
you now now we're going to get some
controversy we're going to poke you a
little bit um bad boy of Chess Hans nean
he's in the tournament you love it you
love it you think it's great to have him
in competing it's great to him he's
gotten a lot of bad undeserved press
he's been unfairly criticized uh from
many news vehicles around the world I
think it's just ridiculous right and uh
we have no experience with him cheating
there's no one here that I've ever heard
say he's a problem that way CU he's
demonstrably not a problem that way
exactly that is absolutely true I'm so
happy you said that that was just thank
you I was hoping I got
that you did it really good Kate you
have more questions for our founder yes
uh I mean one thing is really the US
championships for me you know I transfer
Federation I started to play for the
United States and playing those
championships and growing through the
chess of playing against strong players
I'm just very grateful for everything
you do for us and for women's chess also
because I know you are supporting the
women's Olympic team national team
actually I think the next year we are
planning some camps to have together so
I just want to say that we really Direct
benefit we're trying to do a lot more
exactly for women they deserve it and
chess needs it well one of the things
that you've done is you've opened up
your own home I mean fabbi had a
training camp there and I think the
ladies uh jealously said okay we'll have
a training camp at
your you're going to be hosting the US
Women's team before you know it Wesley
was there for a month some years ago my
grandson who's now 10 was five at the
time and Wesley played him of course
toed with him and so I asked him later I
said so what do you think about Wesley
he says oh he's good but I beat
himy and you know the club also
organizes a lot of like summer classics
spring Classics a lot of other
tournaments to grow new talents new
generations of chess player so what do
you say about Alice Lee and abanu Mishra
I mean such Superstars yeah I mean
you're talking about new Talent we've
got some incredible new Talent right
here and but if they keep coming along
at that rate it it's just hard to
imagine know what's going to be there
and how good they're going to be Rex I
just want to say thank you so much for
everything you do it's absolutely uh
wonderful and uh keep it
up just keep it up you're both very kind
you still don't know what the hell
you're talking about we got that uh here
are our current standings as we're in
round 10 of these national championships
the late LS have just been incredible
chaos absolutely be to here janova
storming through that tournament five
consecutive wins eight out of nine I
mean this is a dream tournament for her
and for Karis s whoever who however draw
made a draw yesterday so now she's seven
and a half points out of nine and then
there's a two-way tie for the third
place Ina crush and Alice Lee with 5 and
a half points and in the open section
Kate uh Fabby the boss Fabiano Carana 6
and a half points and now having a
really Pleasant position so he may be
going to S and 1 half points uh but then
there is a three-way tie for the second
place Wesley so lener Dominguez and
abanu Mishra with five and a half points
absolutely and that game Faby and Mishra
so crucial as you see our tournament
standings Mishra with the black pieces a
point behind but at the moment suffering
because of this move F2 F4 Christian
sure he's in trouble that Knight yes and
we've seen the reflective powers of the
Knight on D5 versus the Knight on E5 and
it's a oneway ticket absolutely you put
it brilliantly and that's the key
difference in the position that Knight
on D5 compared to the Knight that's
being chased down the board this Knight
on E5 and while you start moving your
knight away and try to escape I'm going
to uh continue my attack and that's
exactly what Fabiano is doing F4
beautiful move by Fabiano very natural
move at the same time but I have to say
these positions these attacks are not
easy you miss one bit you missed one
tempo and then everything goes to waste
that's not the case up to this point so
his timing as well in this game
Fabiano's timing I mean it's impeccable
and take a look at this night to D7
immediately by the way he took on D6 he
hasn't even thought he probably already
calculated while Mishra was thinking
about the position take take and now we
expect F5 Black's idea is as you were
mentioning exchange Knight trade them F5
you cannot go Knight to F6 because I
take take take on F7 intera with the
check I pick up the Knight after that
and this is game over all sheo there's
absolutely no coming back from this so
it all makes
sense I expect F5 I don't think we're
going to see anything else what Fabiano
is looking at right now is ideas for
black to try to cement the position as
is and get an active Knight on E5 as
well it's a beautiful Knight but
unfortunately you don't have that many
targets it's a very defensive piece for
the moment it's a good defensive piece
but that's all it is and my knight on D5
on the other hand it's an offensive
piece it controls the position very well
but it also has the potential of jumping
to E7 maybe jumping to F6 getting
involved into into the attack against
the blacking and that's critical for
this position something like Queen E3 we
were discussing it we were actually in
this position uh few moves ago when we
were analyzing the queen is coming to H6
might keep this option in my pocket do I
want to take on G6 and jump with the
Knight to F6 to give a check and maybe
uh do the Checkmate via H7 or do I go F6
support this attack with a queen coming
to H6 and then also have ideas of Knight
to E7 it looks like a dominant situation
right now for Fabiano and by the way
guys if he wins this one and lenier and
Wesley with the black pieces don't win
games we have a champion CHR I have a
question because I feel F5 of course
it's a very direct move but it this like
a move that gives that E5 Square can I
wait and start with Queen E3 or is it
really necessary to play so quickly that
move F5 because it is committing in one
way I just don't want to allow the trade
of the knights that's why I play F5 F5
look it's an attacking move but it also
is very much against that move Knight to
F6 but if I play Queen E3 Knight F6 and
I go Knight B6 right you can go Knight
to B6 but again Rook to C5 and we see
the difference the Knight on B6 is
beautiful but it doesn't have Target it
was much better on D5 so if I go Rook F
D1 now reshuffle to kind of Target at D6
right Queen E7 maybe Oh e f no it's a
problem it feels like you're getting
something as black right well well again
if you just compare the Knights black
just achieved something remarkable the
Knight on D5 got chased away and the
Knight on F6 is now a great Defender and
actually an attacker of the E4 Pawn if
you go back to the original position and
you see that the the pawn goes to F5 and
you and you don't get to play Knight B6
strangely enough the Rook on B1 happens
to be perfectly placed and you don't get
to play Knight F6 the Knight on D5 lives
and once again after Knight E5 that's
the that's the crazy point is that you
could easily just compare the knights
and say that they're equal Until you
realize that Knight F6 check is so
powerful and there's no Knight F3 check
that in fact the Knight on D5 is much
Superior yeah is a much Superior Knight
and I love this idea of Queen E3 and
queen H6 and I also love the idea
frankly of F6 and Knight E7 check and
queen H6 G7 check oh it's it it feels
like Mishra is in in in bad in a world
of hurt but again it's all about that
timing you missed one bit you missed one
tempo you allow me to exchange the
knights and I'm back in the game right
my structure is fine for the moment your
structure is a bit in shambles as white
but you have the dynamic play and
whenever you have the dynamic play you
have to play active moves you have to
play moves that create tension in the
position that create threats in the
position and that Force black to defend
and that's what Fabiano is going to try
to do it's funny attacking moves cover
up weakness is right like when when
you're giving your opponent Checkmate it
doesn't matter that you're Rook down
you've got double pawns Triple pawns
doesn't matter you're on the attack and
F4 Knight D7 takes takes F5 uh go you
know Whit's going places uh let's check
out uh the other two games uh because
again lanir giving Chase and Wesley
giving Chase what's happening in those
games uh Chris they look very very uh
compact this one very uh balanc this one
dry to my eyes I mean I understand why
it has a slight Edge because the Bishops
are better right once again we comp the
quality of the pieces this bishop is a
defensive Bishop but it's a very good
defensive piece right it covers the dile
it covers the E5 uh Square so I don't
have any weaknesses I didn't create any
weaknesses as black so I'm not expecting
much more uh for white I think we're
going to see some trades VI the a file
that's going to be an easy draw in my
opinion for Dominguez definitely he
doesn't have chances I don't I I don't
feel he has any chances to win this game
the action seems to be in the Wesley so
Hans nean H versus Wesley okay this is a
little bit different because at least
Wesley has something to work with again
we see a battle between uh the
weaknesses right E5 and E6 the double
pawns are somewhat of a weakness but
white in return has a lot of weaknesses
as well D3 which uh is a backwards Pawn
the pawn on A2 is a weakness as well and
I can transfer my pieces on the a file
try to create more tension on it it's
still not enough the material is still
quite limited uh the structure is still
quite compact for both sides that is not
enough for a big Advantage for black at
the same time it's all about the tension
build the tension up up to the point
where your opponent has just a few
minutes on his clock still has a lot of
things to cover and solve and then you
know create more problems for your
opponent that's the ticket to success
for Wesley so and he will try because I
think he's looking at Fabiano's position
he sees how dominant the situation is he
needs to win he needs to follow through
if he doesn't win then that's it again
is the champion so he needs to stay
close within Striking Distance and let's
not forget Wesley is the one that has
his faith in his own hands if he wins
this one he'll play with the last round
match with the white pieces against
Fabby we know he can beat him right
Wesley has defeated Fabiano at the
singfield Cup last year with the white
pieces so he can do that he can
definitely do that as you can see he's
looks a bit distracted he's looking
around he was looking around just a
second ago perhaps looking at Fabiano's
position I think he will try to pile on
the pressure on Hans in this one well
the script writers of Hollywood may be
on strike but I tell you somebody wrote
the script brilliantly for round 11
tomorrow uh when Wesley will cross
swords with Fabby hopefully it will be a
game where the championship hasn't
already been decided but I must say that
I like Wesley's position to my eyes it's
kind of easier to imagine C6 B5 you're
kind of creep playing with it idea
Knight C5 to put pressure on that D3
Pawn Yeah Knight C5 also this Rook on on
C3 even though it doesn't look like it's
doing too much in truth you can imagine
The Rook uh swinging to B3 and that Rook
on A3 will be hitting both of the
weaknesses on D3 and A2 I feel it's much
easier to play Wesley's position I agree
and you know talking about Good scripts
for tomorrow I think there are very good
scripts written for round 10 in the
women's section as well so what if we
look at the game between um enena crush
and beim to janua which is really
important for the standings no question
it when we left it we really thought
that b the combination of a few moves by
beum age6 kind of
question Queen E2 a little bit Queen E7
pardon me a little bit questionable
there uh and we thought KN E5 and Arena
was for Choice takes takes F4 this is uh
very famous Harry Nelson Pillsbury from
the turn of the century 19th century and
we had a lady who came to the World
Chess Hall of Fame and says I understand
my great-grandfather has an attack named
after him I said wow who what's the name
well my name is
Pillsbury well yes he does this was
really cool F2 F4 well we don't have to
look too deeply into the position to
understand what arena is looking at
Knight E4 Knight D6 that's like a magnet
F4 F5 that too is like a magnet with or
without E4 E5 I think you also even
mentioned that you found yourself
attracted to uh Rovers and queen G4
Queen H5 in short arena is for choice
and that's also captures that Knight
because she doesn't want to allow
exactly what you said the Knight E4 but
she is giving up a pair of Bishops yes
she is and Arena said you know I don't
really have to go all in on the King
side I don't have to go E4 F5 in fact
I've got a beautiful Outpost yeah sure
maybe I'd rather have a knight on D6 but
the look Rook looks pretty compelling
and The Rook just easily slide it to D1
D6 now we double the Rooks on the D file
and I think white is enjoying some very
nice Advantage because now we can even
kind of push the bishop to B1 or
immediately go as you are drawing que D3
and go for that Checkmate because the
Knight moved from f8 to B8 so it's no
longer St in that 87 square and again
just to remind our viewers who are
joining us late shame on you but as we
started our show we did point out that
Arena arena is kind of like not the best
opponent for beum our tournament leader
as they have played four times in their
head-to-head uh matchups and uh Arena
scored three out of four this position
look I'm sorry to say again as you see
yeah look at that hat to hat two wins
zero loss
and two draws for arena Crush they're on
they're having different paths in this
particular tournament but it sure feels
to me like Arena's the one in the
driver's seat she gets to play Queen D3
provokes weaknesses around beam's King I
I really really don't like it coach how
bad is it oh it's really bad it's really
bad it's really really bad I didn't
think three I this is plus three
Advantage right now Bishop to C6 again
uh White is doing whatever they want in
this position yeah Queen to D3 that idea
that you mentioned I can even start with
ideas of B4 myself right and just
solidify the position as is on that side
Bishop to E1 is an interesting idea that
the engine is recommending it's all
about improving the pieces right this
bishop on C3 right right now facing the
pawn on E5 you know it's not the best
you can improve it right how do you
improve it that's the diagonal to do so
uh through Bishop to E1 Queen to G4
Bishop to H4 seems to be the idea and to
be honest once you see a queen landing
on G4 let's say let's make some moves
right A5 A5 sure why not I I cannot take
that pawn let's assume I cannot take
that pawn queen to G4 A4 right right
Bishop to H4 it's game over it's game
over guys I mean queen to f8 I go F5 I
open you up like this just to give you
an idea Rook takes jues might be an idea
but you don't have to be over zealous
about it I don't need to be over
of course why not Queen to G4 E6 is
coming Bishop takes G6 is a big problem
again Bishop G6 I've increase the
quality of all of my pieces that is
something that I always tell my students
try to look for those type of ideas
whenever you're playing your own game
which piece can be improved oh the
bishop on C3 okay how do I improve it oh
via H4 okay let's go there so that's an
interesting uh move that Arena has at
her disposal again it's a position in
which beim doesn't seem to have an
active plan that might be very
problematic because okay I understand
you put a rook on d8 yeah try to trade
the Rooks for black but you cannot a
problem that's the problem Queen H3
threatens mate that's that's a problem
yes if threatens mate that's your
Rook mate so it's a double attack
exactly very extreme you don't have Rook
d8 I mean you will have Rook d8 if you
play G6 but that weakens your position
even further
so yeah I don't see the plan for beging
uh this is all Irena in this particular
matchup and wow guess what that opens
the door for Karissa hey I can jump over
uh be him with a victory so I might as
well try to do that and guess what she's
winning right now
really was position exactly how did the
pawn get to H4 oh so she played H4 and
and right now I mean don't touch that no
you play G in the worst case you would
play G3 G4 look it I would I would never
P that PA I'm a pawn Grabber and I
wouldn't like to take that pawn sorry
but Bishop to B5 Rook h8 that's where
the Rook is going anyway Bishop to C4
Queen to F6 that's where my queen was
going also Knight F4 is on her agenda
she's helping right now Karissa achieve
the maximum out of her pieces once again
right there is only one The Rook on A8
that's not playing an active role for
the moment everything else even the
bishop on Bishop H3 he's ready to go to
H3 you take the Knight this is really
bad for Ani right now and Karissa with a
victory and a potential loss by begim
she will surpass her in points and if we
look at the head-to-head for the last
round as well that's going to be an
intriguing one because Karissa will be
facing ruang Yen but guess who begim is
going to be facing Jennifer U the
defending Champion so she has a very
difficult finish ahead of her self right
now difficult position against Arena
Crush tomorrow another difficult test
against Jennifer Yu Karissa is looking
to take full advantage of that difficult
Finish Line wow and uh if I'm Jennifer
you I'm just
relishing the chance to upset uh the
tournament leaders I just I'm looking at
Arena's uh position I just have to say
uh by the way I love the idea of Queen
G4 Bishop E1 and Bishop H4 it forcibly
reminds me this marvelous book my 60
memorable games by Bobby fiser he's
playing against dein petosan Fisher
suffering he's going ah this is terrible
I hate my position I want to do this I
want to do that petrosian's pieces are
so good suddenly petosan stirs a pot and
uh a good piece became better it's like
Bobby says what's up with that then
Petrosian stirs the pot and and also a
very good piece is improved and Bobby is
like what the hell
but you know like all the guy does is
keep improving his pieces and if you
look at the bishop on C3 we understand
exactly what um right uh Christian meant
The Bishop's view is blocked and I
really like that we start with Bishop E1
because if we start with Queen G4 we
kind of allow maybe that Rook d8 right
right so with Bishop E1 I'm not allowing
to Rook d8 so I'm waiting then to
immediately play Queen G4 and Bishop H4
exactly i' I've made an illegal drawing
of my arrow I'm saying the bishop on C3
stands behind the pawn on E5 but if I
could leap over the pawn and just put my
Bishop on F6 is like Splat it's game
over so the idea of Bishop E1 and you
know to go Queen to G4 and Bishop H4 and
then put the bishop on F6 is so
compelling and then to the point that
you're making you do it in an exacting
way you play the move Bishop E1 just as
you were saying so that the move Rook d8
is met by Queen D3 and we've already
seen the double attack of ma on two MA
in two black is really suffering for not
having that dark Square Bishop big time
to really control the D6 Square exactly
exactly and I think arena is fully aware
as I do think bam is also fully aware
things have really gone off the rails
one of the things that I find a little
bit awkward for myself if I was in white
shoes I mean I just can't help but make
the move Queen D3 immediately Kate it's
one of those things when I get you to
play G7 G6 I just like look across the
board and I
go wait till my dark Square Bishop lands
on the
F6 I don't want to hear that ever
again the evil cackle you know my my
Bishop is coming to F6 you know I'm very
scared right now
all right so that's how you were in your
times while you were playing and getting
those nice advantages I can't do it
as by the way we spoke about Jennifer
you what if you look at her game because
we talked about her having a really
strong finish and now she started to
attack on that King site as we were
expecting by the way Queen D3 in that
beging game was played also I I I for
arena I just don't know how you avoid
playing that move it's just so
compelling uh jumping back back to
Jennifer U versus Alice Lee very much uh
I love what Jennifer did there somehow
she
finagled and waited uh for the Rook on
A8 to move away from the a file only
then did Jennifer open up the a file so
Rook was improved we were talking about
uh trying to get the Knight to F5 and D6
no Alice isn't going to allow that but
the second idea that we talked about was
running the F paon up the board and we
have caught up with a play players right
now your take who improved their
position uh of their pieces uh uh Kate
so I'm worried about the queen being
trapped on G4 but right now right well
if if I can get H3 maybe King G2 and H3
hold on uh big uh big uh big problem
with the bishop right the queen is
attacking the bishop so uh for me this
is a very perplexing move by Jennifer
because I kind of thought that her
intention was to take on uh E6 if you
take with the Knight then we have the F5
square right and a D6 Square similar to
Ina crash game and then if you take with
a pawn well maybe I'll trade but and a
lot of light squares are weak there but
but but to my mind you know this is a
double attack and it's very very serious
like I don't think Jennifer started this
whole kingside operation with the
ambition of just simply Trading mhm no
no that's not what you to do you're not
happy here but on the other hand if you
what defend but it's not not easy
because exactly now the PA captures on
F5 I'm not I'm not going to discuss
Knight F4 as as a way of maybe tripping
you up as well
but tell me how Jennifer doesn't lose
material after this move Queen G4 was it
a blind spot I mean it feels like
it I'm looking can I capture on E6 first
okay now now the big difference is a
moment ago the Knight was ready to go
there exactly I was much happier to
capture when the Knight was on H4
exactly now you've allowed Knight takes
E6 and with the Knight no longer
defensive but offensive role and if I go
even like Queen E2 you jump with that
Knight immediately to F4 uh things
Alice Alice
looks maybe that was just a this looks
dangerous for Jennifer I don't know if
we can get a bird's eye view of the uh
players there I see Jennifer is like
over her uh pieces and looking like a
hawk I a coach I think uh uh there was a
blunder there was a Miss uh a miss here
for for for Jennifer and allowing Queen
G4 oh yeah yeah no Alice uh looks pretty
good in this position after Queen to G4
I don't really see what you're going to
do as black exactly that's why excuse me
things looking good but you had uh Bobby
Mishra yes the Mary matchup in the open
section he did play uh through with the
attack Queen to G5 I that's a good move
it looks good yes it definitely looks
like a good practical move and now Rook
to F4 came on the board and Fabby is
essing um what is called caveman
chess what you want to do is basically
triple down on the file right take on G6
and take on F6 and you're saying that
your opponent doesn't really have a lot
of ways to stop you from doing that so
for example knight5 looks ni probably
we're going to see this move actually we
just saw this move being played we
expected it take on G6 take on G6 Rook
to F1 I'm going to double up B5 B5 sure
why not Queen to F2 or perhaps right now
that uh you play this move B5 maybe
Queen to E3 is an idea as well I was I
was seeking to defend with the move Rook
B7 yes that's a very good defense so now
maybe I can redirect my attention to the
H file whoa that's not fair Knight F6
Queen
H Rook I was going to go Rook B7 but
he's going to go Queen H3 Rook H4 and
he's this for example try to defend
against checks that's a problem takes F7
right take take you can try to hide but
you're not really hiding uh so this one
and it seems like Fab is on the right
track because he signaled his intention
with his move Rook to F4 he understands
that Knight to E5 is coming on the board
but seems that his plan is well put
together already in his mind in his
brain he knows what he wants to do and
the engine is saying he's completely win
at this point so with good moves with
Precision which he hasn't lacked in this
tournament I have to say his Precision
has been off the charts it it it really
H is his accuracy has not only been
extraordinary but one of the things that
we understand about Chess if your
opponent doesn't make any mistakes you
can't win right and the number of
mistakes that Fabby has made in the
previous nine games in my opinion you
can't count them on two hands I mean
maybe on one hand his accuracy his form
has been Stellar but then he always
finds the critical Moves In Those
difficult positions right like with Ray
Robson he found that I think it was like
Knight D4 Knight F4 in the end game like
the just best continuation just close it
then make a draw exactly yeah yeah no he
made Sam Shanklin Sam winning position
but he had played so incredibly well up
to that moment I think he just I think
he just thought I can win in this way I
can win in that way and he didn't
realize that he actually was still on a
narrow path and if you think about it
even in that one at some point it felt
like it's getting dangerous for him and
then he shut down and make a per check
immediately pulled sacrificed a rook
that was a very practical decision
so except that one maybe you could arue
that the game against saman he had one
moment that we didn't spot it with the
engines with uh every help that you can
have we didn't spot that moment he had
one D4 at some point uh that was giving
him a very significant Advantage but
those are the only two that I can think
of right outside of that he maximize the
potential of every single result that uh
he had up to this point by the way guys
uh this game well for Carissa it's just
Anna versus Kissa seems to be going
downhill very quickly soon looks like a
forced
Checkmate so many pieces around that
wait a minute yeah yes this bishop we
were
anticipating Queen takes Bishop F1 but
play Just Bishop
F4 Bishop
F4 yes okay let's let's try it out let's
try it out knightes KN takes no you can
recapture my Bishop you have a check
well Bish takes I have Knight E2 and
queen G2 okay so that's the Checkmate
get him
Kate all right let's try to defend like
this somehow but now I capture on F1 and
I have Knight H3 o yes yes yes you do
that's a
Checkmate that's my co- commentator
everybody no Christian will argue that
he has a weak chess engine I'm not going
to make such arguments
okay let me try this one I mean this we
are
doing you're doing great you're doing
great terrific terrific what do you auor
this move we have to stop Queen takes F7
so we got to we got to go Rook f8 on
this one king H or Rook a we we think
the H Rook might bring something in the
fure well okay okay all right again do
you have any threats I that's the thing
I I don't know if we do Bishop H2 check
maybe let's try defend like
this yeah Bishop H2 check is just not
there okay actually uh Christian instead
of Rook a a f8 okay shoot if I move back
and if I play Bishop E3 check mhm are we
going to capture that guy or not no no I
don't think so interesting I don't think
I want to
capture I don't know why but in general
I want to keep my knight around I feel
it's a good defensive okay just a second
Knight F4 Queen F7 King
H6 what's he going to do about the G2
he's got Rook B2 but D1 is hanging I
thought how does he defend
G2 all of karissa's pieces it's like uh
this the perfect position right right uh
bees to honey I mean they're just
swarming the white king not looking good
a lot of things seem to be working her
way right now we're going to expect uh
well let's see by the way Rook d8 seems
to be a winning move that is a very
natural move right you bring another
Rook to the
Bishop F4 is a very good move there is
this move Rook to D3 though um wow which
by the way is not an easy move to see
wow and then it seems like this is
forced right now take take take on H3
and get to this position which is still
better for black but not enough no
developing that Rooks r seem natural R3
is a really strong move yeah so let just
go Rook d8 eliminate that get another
attacker into the game how do you
improve your defense you cannot it's
it's over this is over yeah so Carissa
still needs to be kind of patient here
right maybe not go immediately for
checkmate like I did but just say like
okay let's develop The Rook first that's
one of the strategies you do all the
time in the world though 36 minutes
against 12 minutes with a decisive
Advantage she knows it she feels these
type of positions she's actually won
quite a number of games in this style so
she's seen this type of situations
before I don't think she's going to make
is this one absolutely I I I completely
agree as well uh I just wanted to check
in on Arena because what arena did do by
the way is she did play the move Queen
D3 and I I mean I just find that move so
compelling uh because it does force you
to play G7 G6 and all the dark squares
all the dark squares around your king
are are compromised with the move E2 E4
E3 E4 what's the idea behind that well
now the queen is ready to come over uh
tackle the H6 pawn and we're back to our
uh beautiful plan you know I was just
thinking when you were saying that you
really enjoy that black is going to play
that G6 and like suffer forever because
of the dark squares I was just briefly
watching yesterday Trevor no Noah show
and he was talking about the Germans
have this word Shaden Freud yeah which
are people that enjoy that other people
are suffering exactly so I was like okay
yes
uh yeah and this is really I mean
because I think you play enough chess
games you get into those positions where
you look at a position you go oh my
goodness my opponent is going to plant a
knight on F6 or a bishop on F6 and
there's nothing you can do to stop it
and it's just like this realization that
you know you're almost helpless and it
it's extraordinary because up to this
exact moment in this tournament
everything has been going B's way
everything has been going Carissa's way
this is the first time she's been
wrong-footed beum as and it's terrible
actually I don't think she's difficult
even for black to find good moves here
play even Rook D Knight D7 no I just rip
it right off right so you can place
anything on the dile so maybe bishop B5
but that's really helping me move the
queen somewhere where I wanted to go
anyway which was something Anna just did
by the way which I found terrible for
Anna uh she made this move Bishop B5 she
forced Carissa's Rook to move to a
better Square she made another move
forcing the queen to a better square and
so forth and so on so Bishop B5 okay I I
get it you want to play Knight C6 and
Knight D4 but I am unfortunately for
beam's fans I am uh moving with a Tempo
Bishop H4 is coming with a Tempo I
position is really coming at any moment
it's all it's all terrible so it goes
back to Karissa for a moment as we pick
up on this game from Carissa one of the
um annotations I made for inside chess
remember when you're attacking MH think
of your attack as a
party okay just make sure you invite
everybody to the party so I really do
like this move Rook d uh Rook A8 to d8 a
lot because you're getting everybody uh
into the party and in this case and The
Rook on D1 is also one of the few pieces
in White's camp that is actually really
active and can become active on D7 in
the future yeah and we also see Rook D3
as a very important um defensive by the
way we did see a move Karissa played the
move Knight H5 to F4 she did not play
Rook over I think we see Rook D2 right
now Rook D2 on the board yes okay so but
wa that Bishop on H6 can be looking at
that Rook mhm
greedily um I don't think I can exp well
I don't think I can exploit it maybe I'm
wrong I take I mean you can take on G2
with the Knight if you really want to
it's going I have H3 that's at least
going to give you an exchange
right but King H1 it's still not clear
that I went in exchange um I'm not
greedy if I do play Rook D wait wait
wait sorry when did you decide not to be
greedy I wanted to play
Rook and yesterday just yesterday late
at night I said to
myself that's a lie if on Bishop bishop2
where were you guys going I take it away
H1 H1 King H1 I didn't see the when did
you no I didn't oh that's why I agreed
with you Rook 88 looks very nice there
you go um Christian
where's you you you drag this back to
this position well first of all back for
just a second okay um can we take on G2
if you really want to be greedy in the
position with the Knight with the Knight
yeah and then the idea is to make a
check and take the Rook you still have
Rook F2 right Rook F2 is a defensive
move yeah true so do I have a way to to
get that exchange if I really want to I
don't think it's enough to be honest I I
I don't think that's enough for I'm just
saying that I wouldn't want to cash the
chips in too soon after Rook to D2 um I
agree I just uh Bishop H2 is on the
board which is on board Bishop takes G2
so we're I'm a little surprised that
karisa is playing so fast like she sees
something in the position that she
really lik something so show let's see
what it is that we're missing takes G2
what are we missing well you can go
Queen E3 now oh maybe she can also just
capture on G2 Knight takes G2 oh my
goodness Queen E3 check is very good
guys yes this one that's it this one I
can see oh that's it that's it okay
that's really very direct yeah beautiful
yeah it's over wow I think you have to
play with we are looking for checkmates
which is great material hey look I can
do that you well so unfortunately for
Anna but that's now I'm not even sure I
need the I can actually go Knight H3
yeah I'm actually thinking too like how
bad no this is terrible for was played
Rook takes G2 is played but Knight H3
I'm thinking let's let's finish this one
off Knight F2 and then
bishop3 and now we're threatening a
discovered check against the queen oh
this is so sad this is terrible but we
are also threatening Knight D1 that's
right because then I blocked The Rook
defending the bishop on F1 so you're
threatening Knight D1 check so King H1
and I grabbed the bishop on F1 oh that's
that's super
nasty oh
my I guess that's a good thing that's a
good thing I guess that's a good thing
in this context oh my goodness so
Carissa and she did give check night H3
uh dinners on uh dinner for Arenas on
Charis
should Arena win what we think is a
winning position and it sure looks like
karissa's winning this one as well
Bishop takes D D2 Rook takes G2 on the
board by the way she played Bishop
Knight H3 check King H1 Bishop E3
immediately first yeah with this idea of
Knight check and Knight check and queen
takes F1 just put your pressure on
opponent like Anna knows that Knight F2
is coming and you don't have even Rook
B2 or something to prevent it because
the bishop on F1 is hanging absolutely
over yeah no um this is dominating
performance from Karissa but I have to
say she was aided by performance um this
is not great I mean she think Pawn takes
H4 that was that is the cause of all the
troubles that Anna had in her game in
five moves from an equal maybe slightly
better position for white completely in
shambles in five moves Christian I see
that you have a game behind you leavon
Aron and Sam Shanklin leavon was winning
out of the opening you were mentioning
you know we have to invite uh people
everybody to the party body to the party
he's inviting all his buddies he's got
three buddies a lot of them on this side
look at this completely dominating of
course Rook to D7 I think the game is
pretty much over I'm trying to
understand King G8 is Queen to A7
doubling up on the seventh if you do
take a pawn unfortunately that's too
late that's a checkmate by force uh and
there's actually no way to defend
against it the best thing you can do is
to exchange the Queens but then my
friends are really coming right C5 C6 B6
A5 this is pretty much over Rook to E4
we're expecting Rook to D7 I guess Rook
to F7 is the question but then again you
can take take Queen to A7 what do you do
next okay I'll go back maybe I'll go to
D4 as well protecting everything
attacking the pawn on F6 if you do try
to defend again any sort of Queen trades
favor me I'm pushing my pawns promoting
and I still push my pawns promote in the
next few moves I'm surprised to see that
Leon is only one Pawn up it feels like
he's he two or three pawns up yeah just
complete absolute control going on here
and he took on F7 by the way yeah in
fact this might be uh done very quickly
so perhaps we can see the bird's eye
view just to see uh the shake of hands I
think we're going to see a shake of
hands for Sam Shanklin I boy don't we
know this so well of our own tournament
experiences Kate when you know you just
had this Dreadful
Dreadful um loss against Mishra from the
previous
round you spiral you just go on tilt and
by the way uh
Karissa uh is currently our new
tournament leader yes uh eight and a
half points out of 10 right and uh by
the way um Arena played that move Queen
H3 she followed it up with Queen takes
H6 and uh she's currently just uh
cruising as well so we may see a change
of leaders in the women section I think
it's a it's it's an absolute actually is
what I'm expecting at this moment as
Arena looks like she's dominating the
position back to the game of Fabby for a
moment we saw Rook oh this I do feel
like we have to stay with this one just
because it's going to be over and this
is the first victory of leevon aronian
in at this tournament so again yes Queen
to
F2 and and Sam is not a player that
usually plays all the way until
Checkmate if he knows the game is over
he's going to shake hands um he he's a
fighter but in this position there's
simply no
chances m but you really see him
resigning right now not even in in a few
minutes I think we should stay with this
one I think he's the closest one to uh
to
finish and uh Queen back to E5 defending
F6 that's the best he can do but like
you say I mean it's all about the three
pass pawns C5 starting with C4 C5 the
thing is at some point once I get my
Pawn to C6 I can even take on F6 yes
exactly just to just to indic oh even A5
A5 A6 is coming I thinking about playing
A5 instead of C5 just to push the pawn
that's kind of farest away from the King
invite everybody to the party exactly uh
to to butress the point that you were
just mentioning Christian A5 so from a
Black's point of view this best chance
of counterplay would would lie in
playing H5 H4 exposing White's King and
just to play it as crudely as I possibly
can A6 H3 Queen takes
F6 and this is more or less what you
were indicating two passers that are
just ready for uh promotion will over
overwhelm a rook I'm getting a queen yes
exactly so
A6 a pardon me A5 by the way F5 being
played okay that releases the queen from
it there's no queen of six ideas so we
can expect A6 yep stops Queen takes F6
too leavon doesn't have to be asked
twice uh yeah and he's not spending too
much time on his moves either I once
took uh liberties with anat karpov anat
karpov had sent me an annotated game
where he had such a position and I wrote
on his behalf let's get those doggies
moving and a lot of our readers for
inside chess wondered what Western's
carop had been seeing as a young boy by
the way let's get those doggies moving
Queen C7 we will see C5 is it time to
maintain all friends on the board or do
we go B6 no let's go C5 keep our friends
we keep our let's keep everybody on the
board right no be no 6 A7 you like the
friends and the thing is C5 also opens
up the idea of I queen to A2 check Queen
A2 check look at say Sam is just
disgusted is is disgusted miserable
right now I mean look it's been a tough
event for him sure it truly has been a
tough event for him right I think he's
left a lot of points on the board as
well it started off with that game
against Andrew Tang yeah where he missed
Knight E4 missed Knight E4 by the way he
not want to keep all the he gave up one
was his bit disappointing I don't want
to see that c c friend Trump off the
board no you don't want to lose your
friends um for leavon aronian uh let's
be fair I mean he comes in as a huge
rating uh favorite in the top four most
certainly and this event I could say is
a great disappointment as if wins today
and obviously he's a very big favorite
to to precisely that it'll be his first
and only win of the tournament and there
it is B7 and our congratulations to
leavon as he climbs to 50% but he's
losing a lot of rating points here lanir
and you know he's a great
player he feels something is missing in
his play right right no but this is a
good way to bounce back to finish the
tournament yeah in his usual style I
mean we've seen this type of
performances like in this game from Leon
so many times right in our commentating
career he's been around the block a long
time right he's such an amazing player
whenever he's in uh good shape he hasn't
shown it up to today's game but I have
to say very confident finish in today's
game definitely uh a point to be proud
about uh for leevon in this one and we
have a tournament leader in studio with
a you
Christian as Carissa yep joins us
Karissa congratulations a big victory
for you definitely a difficult one
yesterday you had a good position
yesterday but unfortunately you weren't
able to convert that one but finally you
got the full point home and the way the
other important game looks it seems like
you might be the clear leader going into
the final round your thoughts and your
emotions right
now um honestly I didn't take too close
of a look at begum's game but it did
look like Arena was doing pretty well so
um I mean I'll just let that play out
and mostly I just want to focus on
playing a chess um yesterday I was like
really
disappointed uh for like not being able
to convert that position but I figured
there's uh two rounds left the
tournament's not over yet and today I
just had to bring some good sh which I
think went okay oh you definitely did
bring that did she surprised you with
her opening Choice playing this uh
peaceful setup with C3 and then
immediately take on E5 or were you happy
uh to see
this um yeah so I was expecting okay I
was totally surprised by Knight bd2
first of all and then there was like
this moment where I was considering
whether or not I should play D5 to stop
E4 completely or just go into some s
modern um but I figured that you know D6
is sort of like the positions that I
know best mhm and I'd probably be able
to sort of find a way through it um yeah
I don't really love this for black
honestly like d takes E5 these lines
they sort of feel like White's always a
slightly better with little to no risk
it did feel that way up until she played
a g Tak H4 exactly yes later on in the
game yeah so I was trying to like put
some pressure on her King side and yeah
I felt GT H4 was just uh weakening the
dark swears too much and it really let
me um sort of coordinate my pieces more
I feel and it feels like she was making
moves that uh was attacking your pieces
but it was also helping you set up uh
the best on your pieces on the best
squares in the
position yeah I felt like um
Bishop B5 Bishop C4 that sort of
sequence of moves she was running super
low on time
already um and yeah I just think Queen
C5 just doesn't really work so after uh
Bishop H3 Queen E7 Queen takes F3
White's kind of finished over on the
king Side Y yeah and you finished in
style after that with Knight to F4 you
never gave her any chance to get back
into the game tomorrow you will be
facing ruang with everything on the line
the champion ship is on the line your
strategy
tomorrow um you know I can't say too
much cuz who knows rang might be
watching this
later but um again hopefully I just want
to you know give it my best chess and if
it goes well it'll go well and if it
doesn't then um that's just the best I
could do guys join the conversation what
to say Carissa seriously congratulations
you uh your games with Anna in the past
no draws you guys have been all decisive
games uh thus far and what can I say
just really impressive chess K I do have
one question Carisa we were talking
about maybe Anna trying to play kind of
like a mind game with you trying to play
something very equal knowing that you're
going to push you're going to risk
you're want to you're going to really
try to win that game would that be your
strategy were you going to really uh
Risk Everything to win this game or
would dby okay work for
you um yeah that was definitely
something I was worried about and I
wasn't going to like um I was going to
try my best to sort of keep a
complicated position with lots of pieces
on the board but if she kind of insisted
on you know going to like an equal end
game or something then I would just be
I'll just take the draw MH very good
your way yes and a big game tomorrow
Karissa uh good luck and uh we'll be
watching
thank you absolutely as a a huge game
there Carissa takes the lead in the
tournament let's just jump into the game
style with black pieces we talked about
her being really dangerous in King's
Indian defense and now again she started
that attack on the king side yeah
exactly and here's our uh new standings
with that Victory by Carissa Carissa
enjoying a half point lead with bam
still playing yeah of leaders here so
Karissa eight and a half points one uh
half a point um above uh leading the
tournament next to be to janova well
said and in the open section K can you
do it
again so here we have still the leader
Fabiano Carana with six and a half
points exactly and that chasing pack but
it's all about fabbi versus Mishra
because Mishra is in that that chasing
pack of wolves this 14-year-old Phenom
what's going on uh Christian it's not
looking good for Mishra and this one and
it hasn't been looking good for a long
time I think we left it somewhere around
after Rook to F4 and we were saying he's
looking for caveman chess approach he's
trying to double up or maybe even triple
up on the f file use ideas of Queen to
E3 and then Discovery attacks as well
against the queen on G5 and that's
exactly what he did Rook to C5 Queen to
E3 Rook to f8 Queen to H3 as you can see
he uh shifting his focus on the other
side uh you know Rook H4 is coming Rook
H4 is coming you afraid of takes and
take Knight F6 is coming up for example
if you make a normal let's say B5 why
not take take of course you cannot take
back with the F Pawn you lose but taking
uh leads to a Checkmate as well so this
is problematic you have to sacrifice The
Exchange the problem is this doesn't
solve your your situation there's
absolutely no compensation I'm still
checkmating you again I'm going to take
on G6 and then I'm going to go Rook to
H4 for example let's play a stupid move
right B5 I take you cannot take with the
F Pawn and now Rook to H4 comes you're
still getting checkmated and in fact how
do you defend against this you can start
with King to G7 by the way Rook to E8
was played we're expecting this move to
come uh along on the board I'm starting
to see some ideas okay you he probably
wants to take with the F Pawn just to
keep the H file closed okay that's why
he moved the Rook off the f file so he
wants to take like this I was looking at
Queen e66 Jack I know do do you have a a
beautiful photo finish there's no
there's no Checkmate right no there's no
photo finish the Knight only five
protects against that right so what can
you do how do you increase the pressure
first of all okay what if I go this
threatening Rook to f8 yeah and come
back with Queen even to F2 looks good if
you go Queen to E7 I invade yeah
then I go Queen H6 this looks good then
I go rookie it's over I'm going to
interrupt you to say we have a always
fashionable guest in studio leavon
aronian over to you Christian leavon uh
welcome back to the show the last time
we uh had you you made a last
year okay that's mean y that is very
mean of you but you said that you're
looking to learn in these very tense
situations and today I have to say it
feels like we've seen the old leevon
back in the game just an impressive
Victory from you how are you feeling
right
now very good uh you know because uh I
was uh not too optimistic with my
tournament cuz I've been uh just not
getting a play and today as well I think
he kind of tricked me with the move
order so I had to settle for this bishop
B3 very obviously I mean it's not uh not
not a very manly way to play but I
thought uh I mean if I allow him to play
Knight D2 G5 you know I I didn't
remember what I what I really intended
there but then I got lucky cuz my
opponent blundered the Knight takes on
E5 and then uh in this complication it
seems that white should be better and uh
somehow um I I managed to convert that
Advantage so you mean at this point
obviously it was a big blunder with the
move Bishop to E6
and we could see it was this a shocking
moment for you because we know Sam for
so many years he's not a player that
generally blunders in this
fashion oh yeah of course I mean it's
very surprising because he's a he's a
very knowledgeable very consistent and u
a very good player absolutely but it
still required uh some Precision for you
to convert because he was trying to make
it difficult this move Knight to G4
trying to change uh the D Dynamic of the
position but you did find this idea of
F3 Queen to E1 I think this was a very
powerful move give us your thoughts um
about this position and this particular
sequence yeah I couldn't really figure
out if if I should settle for D and take
on F7 or should I settle for this
position it's very difficult to
understand which one is actually uh you
mean this one and take on F7 yeah cuz
this is also kind of interesting great
Advantage takes and Knight C4 Knight E5
I saw this stuff
uh but but I told to myself you know I
don't
know what if what if uh what if it's
nothing and and I'll regret it so I
thought not to spend too much time
thinking and I saw this F3 Queen E1 C4
should be slightly better for me because
I play Knight E4 uh and queen D4 came as
a surprise actually the the move that he
played because I thought uh instead he
should play play Knight H5 and the
position is far from Clear of course MH
mhm uh you know I mean it's better for
me but after Queen D4 it's already that
U I have no chance to go wrong you know
I'm more or less uh uh playing in a safe
and en Joyful Joyful mood no absolutely
and you show that with your last
tournament few moves uh to finish off uh
the tournament still one round to go
still plenty of chances coming your way
for sure but we were talking about this
position and yaser was telling us this
story about inviting all of your friends
to the party you are definitely inviting
all of your friends on this side to the
party and uh you did all the way until
there was a coronation congratulations
Leon uh we'll see you tomorrow thank you
thank you FKS yeah our congratulations
to uh leavon I'm going to jump quickly
to the game of Hans nean and Wesley so
because again Wesley is one of those
players uh trailing by a point and if if
Mishra could do some upsets you know he
could be in there with a shout when we
left it we're more or less here no I
think the queen would just came back to
D6 and we thought that uh Wesley was for
choice we just didn't know exactly how
much so I'm toing and throwing back and
forth and then came this big moment with
D3 D4 and Wesley spotted what he thought
was an opportunity to sacrifice an
exchange and I must say it's very easy
to lose your nerve you you see Knight E5
you see Knight takes absolutely scary
and whoa that wait is that a force
Checkmate or just going for a draw I was
about to say I thought Knight E5 was his
in his intention he went Queen takes F3
and he just went for a
Perpetual wow wow um wait okay that kind
can we go again Queen E2 yes so you
think okay so this is the check check
check Queen E2 yes and now can I go Rook
F2 what are we missing let stop let's
stop and think I think check and E5
check oh that might be a problem yeah
how are we we don't want to play G7 G6
we know that
then we've got another check so do you
think that is what wesle missed yeah no
I think he just wanted to make a draw
you think so but like he not better I
think he was ready to make a draw uh but
for us surprisingly not no for us
Christian The Exchange sacrifice looks
very compelling and after the move Rook
takes D4 I'm and it looks like the
players are are claiming a three move
repetition and Wesley is certainly ready
to accept it we thought that Wesley
sacrificed the exchange with the
intention of Knight E5 why didn't he
follow it up with Knight E5 yes Knight
to E5 is an option the problem is I'm
going to go Rook to d8 and that's going
to change the Rooks right you go Knight
takes F3 I would say or do you want
Queen takes F3 no Knight takes F3 check
of course okay let's go King H1 and
let's say you do have to be careful I
mean queen B3 is coming and that
actually protects a lot yeah I was going
to say Knight G5 Rook f8 Queen f8 yes
but I I think I can start like this
that's the problem and there is a draw
is agreed yeah I I've won what only one
Pawn for the
exchange yeah it's not that much it's
not that much and the the problem is
that if your attack on the king side
doesn't succeed then you're in trouble
um for the simple fact that the material
is very limited I thought Wesley had an
advantage and then he just forces the
Perpetual quite the surprise for me me
let's jump to the game of Fabby for a
moment again Fabby is enjoying the
proceedings he's a full exchange up that
move Queen E3 that um was proposed by uh
Christians on the board he's looking to
make a discovered attack against the
queen queen mistress Queen drop back to
d8 H3 like that just Mak yeah sir I
think I hate to interrupt you but I
think we have really cool game now with
Nazi pinza and Talia Cervantes can we
just take a look absolutely again uh
these two players have not had a
successful tournament but boy they're
trying to create a brilliancy aren't
they we were talking about that
brilliancy oh and black just lost the
queen so some okay so essentially Nasi
was throwing the kitchen sank the Rooks
are attacking ready to somewhere
sacrifice on H5 sometimes even playing
E6 to kind of weaken uh the G6 uh pawn
and maybe sacrifice uh Rook on G4 for
the Knight Queen
D3 I'm not a fan why do I play Queen D3
I'm just walking into a
discovery I mean just okay yeah I mean
the the big question had to be Queen
takes E5 doesn't it okay I'm sorry I'm
just trying to understand Queen takes E5
okay then we have Knight takes H5 okay
Pawn takes Rook takes and now you're
threatening Rook
and6 check Queen H6 there I mean okay
um do I want to bite with F5 you
probably still play Rook takes eight G4
as well okay but this looks terrible
because she did play Queen D3 Knight H5
and whoop there goes the black queen
and well Queen takes D3 or is eyeballing
H7 it looks like White's cuz black has
Che on C8 but the king is kind of very
safe on B1 just a second can I even play
for a forcing mate what do I do check
you got a take right check this looks
good if I go to F7 he also capture the
pawn on H5 but that opens up that's a
Checkmate that that opens the rook and
that's all she wrote so maybe it's just
I mean maybe it just game over yeah nzi
threw the kitchen sink and and it worked
and it worked doesn't always work uh
Christian doesn't on the board but guys
becking might actually be back in the
game no way yes we thought she was all
but this is the position that we have
right now look at this Pawn on C3
where's your Checkmate right we've
simplified the position a little bit
let's take a look at the bird ey View
and see exactly how these ladies are
experiencing this moment right now
because this one is not clear at all
anymore and take a look at the time 4
minutes for arena 16 minutes for beim
still a few moves to go uh six for arena
seven for beim but this one is no longer
easy because we used to see the dark uh
the black queen s passive and now it's
pretty active on H5 and I mean that pawn
on C3 with the supporter on B4 those
pawns are very dangerous so what if I go
C2 and Rook to C3
okay so who's on turn black black to
make black knight to A3 uh Queen to D3
were just uh played C2 Rook to C1 let's
go Rook to C3 right right okay you go
Queen to D2 but your Rook right now is
completely stuck right I'm not your
camper no I let's say I go A5 right by
the way A5 A4 and then if I manag to go
Knight to C4 you might be in trouble I'm
sorry but this bishop was supposed to be
on F6 from and by the way uh I I believe
na P won her game from the position of
the white Talia cantes the white king it
looks like a victory uh for Nazi I mean
in this game we were cherishing that
Arena has a really nice position all are
restricted cannot do anything and
suddenly this Rook on C5 well it's not
only that but this black queen as you
were mentioning was active why isn't our
Bishop on F6 why aren't we simply
checkmating uh beum I'm telling you
Bam's got more lives than a cat this is
round 10 and she's used nine maybe she's
using a 10th life we did not expect this
uh to be her game but right now things
are turning uh definitely the clock it's
all about the clock yes and we've seen
Arena have some difficulties with the
clock in this particular game in this
particular tournament as well remember
that game against ashita she was winning
but again in time trouble situation she
uh completely um mess it up in that one
and this one looks very close to that
scenario right now right I have to say
against Jennifer youu also yeah oh in
the H of the battle allowing that move
uh Rook to uh B2 that was just
incredible by the way C2 is on the board
right she's throwing the gauntlet right
now and again the challenge is there
yeah maybe the engine is saying that
white is still slightly better the trend
who do you prefer in this position Play
No for black of course black with that
pawn on C2 right well and and again from
the position we thought you know it was
close to plus three right so Arena
somehow she's like she she she's not in
the best of form and as you were just
describing her game with Jennifer youu
especially I thought that was a
remarkable A3 A4 A5 A6 a takes B7
opening up the queen side H4 move that
has nothing uh no linkage with your
previous moves and he were saying how
she easily can can attack on the king
side right but now there is no attack so
one Carissa Yip is definitely back in
our hotel room saying whoa whoa whoaa
whoa whoa whoa whoa what happened to my
lead in the tournament I mean I was
supposed to I mean whoa whoa whoa whoa
whoa still this one is not over very
very complex I mean the position is very
very
absolutely with Wesley so drawing uh if
laner were to draw his game because we
think Fabby is winning 100% like it's
just then he's got the tournament see
what else I don't see what else is
happening in the linear game right now
Robson is just is dry we were expecting
this trade on the a file and now sure
you're trying to keep the Queens on the
board but I'm chasing you around exactly
Queen D1 Queen to C2 I think a draw is
inevitable in this inevitable in this
one and that leaves us with the Fabby
versus Mishra game which is close to
being over because I'm ready to go to f8
and in fact what if I go to f8 right now
what do you
do
crickets don't ask me boss I mean that
okay Queen E7 what
else I've got to I've got to at least
stop Queen F6 check if I want to I don't
think I want to you don't want to play
Queen F6 and by the way Rook to E6 seems
to be very strong as well in fact why
don't I keep the Rook on the sixth rank
that might be much more active oh hold
on sorry I think he did already play
Rook f8 no just Rook C7 no uh Rook C7 is
the move and perhaps we can see it on
your board so that we see the cameras
above the players as well I mean this is
about to be potentially the championship
game is right here right here if he wins
this one and he seems primed to do it
it's yeah it's
over Fabiano defens his title when have
we seen the last title defense in the US
championships because it always changes
you know yeah yeah yeah yeah whether it
was G or Hikaru traded some some
titles trading blows here and there by
the way we're hearing that lir and
Robson are repeating the position so
we're probably going to see a draw in
that one and Wesley kind of traded a
few Arena crash she probably won a few
times in a row back to back yes yes yes
she was dominant for a very long for
sure but uh by the way Ray Robson uh
lanir uh some some um repetition
repetitions there's a repetition we've
seen in the Ray Robson we we we we
didn't uh resolve the the the question
of the round who was going to get into
time trouble between Ry and um lanir uh
neither of them because how was that
possible two time
trouble
atcts too simple the position was too
simple and I have a feeling none of the
players really wanted to destabilize it
too much right I think Ray is not happy
with his result up to this point and
he's not willing to take any more
chances mhm especially against such a
solid situation right and lener pretty
much the same but then again for Ray as
we see the handshake Ray reveals some
very key uh novelty at A4
uh now the theoreticians around the
world will all be busy trying to analyze
what Ray uh um crafted uh back to the
game of Fabby because I wanted to ask in
this position yourself Kate
uh did you what would your approach be
would you trade him off Rook f8 Queen E7
Queen F6 not really you know I was
thinking about a similar plan to what
Karis say did I would just go a H4 H5 H6
is if possible and I force you to weaken
the pawn or if you're going to capture
on H5 gck and life is good I like your
H4 H5 idea a lot Queen B4 by the way uh
immediately pressuring the pawn was
Fabby choice I think he
has is I mean it's a it's a question
stend the pawn on C3 right so maybe if
uh Mish plays Rook D7 uh Fabian could go
H4 yeah as well uh we have special guest
in studio uh Christian as our one of our
commentators joins you nazzi P Nazi uh
welcome to the show we haven't seen you
in a while it was a tough event up this
point but today you uh through a caution
to the Wi you just wanted to have fun it
felt like was that the
case yes hi guys I've missed you so much
it's been a really long time true
yeah I guess today I felt like playing
very aggressively and figured neither of
us have anything to lose and let's just
play some crazy game and it worked out
pretty well for me yes absolutely and in
fact take us through your preparation
was this H5 and a couple of Pawn
sacrifices part of your preparation was
uh this over theboard how was
it it's all over the board I didn't know
what to do after
B5 after yeah uh I I I did prepare H4
line but I was just not expecting her to
go into this Beno kind of line so in the
variations I prepared I was uh ready to
sacrifice Pawn on H5 so here I figured
since I already wasn't up an extra pawn
it would hurt to sacrifice my own why
not why not and that opens the lines
towards her King and uh how are you
feeling about your chances right now
especially after long Castle making the
move long castle that must have felt
quite
good yeah I was very optimistic I'm
shocked to see that it says double zeros
I thought I was much better they
us yes and where do you feel like you're
finally taking over the
initiative it seems like your play is
much easier she was looking searching
for her counter chances on the queen
side but they just weren't really
happening uh and finally you broke
through and it's still triple zeros by
the way it seems with this move C3 which
is unbelievable and very uh difficult to
think that this is
possible but she did not find that she
played the move Queen to F5 and finally
you broke through and this Knight D6 to
finish off things was a very nice touch
tell us a bit about this tournament what
went wrong what are you going to do to
adjust what is your uh attitude going
into the final
round so I started pretty well and then
after after the rest day I felt like I
forgot I was playing a
tournament I completely got out of the
Zone I guess and I lost three in a row
which uh against Bim uh yes she played a
really good game and I deserve to lose
but the other two games I definitely
should have not lost so that was hard to
recover from but um I'm planning to
finish strong well you're a fighter and
you showed it so many times guys any
questions for Nazi no just a
congratulations on a very very
entertaining game uh Nasi and good luck
we really enjoyed you pushing the pawns
and just trying to attack and Talia on
the other side these games are fun to
commentate on absolutely thank you guys
absolutely as we prepare for our time
pressure we're going to be taking a
quick break and we're going to see you
on the other side don't leave for more
action of round 10 of these national
championships
[Music]
hi Fabby thank you so much for joining
me today uh can you tell me a little bit
about your chess upbringing yeah it
started when I was pretty young I was
around 5 years old uh and I was living
in New yor York at the time uh so it
started after school with other kids
from uh from the chess club it was a
very a very small Club very few uh
players very few kids were interested in
chess but we had good coaches and uh my
first two coaches I remember from those
early days as well um Bruce pondini and
Miran Sher who sadly passed away a few
years ago but they were like very
instrumental in my early coaching and
very prominent in the New York circles
so a lot of the kids I grew up with also
became very strong players like Robert
Hess is is of course a houseold name he
was one of the one of my competitors
when I was a kid and also one of my
friends and Mark Arnold and other other
players from the New York area became
either very strong players or grand
Masters so it was a really good scene
chess scene to grow up in uh and of
course the the Marshall chess club is is
famous as like one of the oldest chess
clubs in in the world and um dedicated
to Frank Marshall in in New York so it
was really good to like grow up in that
atmosphere being being able to play
strong players even as a as a kid to
play uh International Masters or feed
Masters or players of of quite a strong
level uh in my kind of early formative
years as a chess player so that was my
upbringing and after that of course uh I
had to at some point make a branch
between school and chess I had to make
that decision so I made that decision
pretty young and and from there I became
maybe not professional but started my
path towards becoming a professional
chess player how many how many hours
would you say you were spending on chess
studying various things early on it was
probably I didn't have much incentive on
my own I like to play but I didn't like
to study so if we count pure study then
it was probably like 2 hours a week just
working with my coaches I'm talking
about like when I was still in school
and playing I I did play pretty much
every day uh every evening after school
my dad would drive me to the Marshall
Marshall chess club and uh and we would
play there and then when I stopped going
to school then I was working on my own
quite significantly those were still in
the days where computers weren't too
strong so I think a lot that was very
important as well that I got that
experience of working over the board on
my own um and I I was very interested in
it in it I think if I hadn't had the
interest that I developed let's say when
I was 12 until my late teenage years
then I probably wouldn't have gotten
quite so strong I don't think I would
have improved so easily but I had an
interest that was very strong during
those years and that really helped me a
lot cuz I I could apply myself for hours
and hours every day so from like 12 till
let's say until I became like a strong
grandm like 16 17 I I was working a few
hours every day and when you say working
you mention that you had a few hours
with your coaches and then you worked on
your own was there a specific book that
uh you remember now that has had an
impact on your chess career yeah I
remember a lot of books I'm not sure
which one I would say has like a very
strong impact but all of them like gave
me something and and I do remember um
like I I I worked a lot with John
Watson's books when I was in like those
early teenage years and I would like go
through the examples of course it's hard
to say now like how much of that
knowledge would hold up to engine
analysis but I think just the process of
working on your own is is already very
beneficial even if let's say the all the
uh all the stuff that you look at isn't
correct that's not the main part the
main part is just that you're applying
yourself and you're thinking critically
about Chess and that that's going to
lead to Improvement so uh definitely the
material I looked at a lot of uh John
Watson's books a lot of Jonathan Ron's
books um of course kasparov's books uh
and and there were some old classics
that I also worked with quite a lot and
and with coaches uh a lot of like
studies I remember when I was working
with cherin for about 2 years he would
uh give me like entire palbo studies
which would take sometimes 2 hours to
fully go through and just sit there and
calculate things from beginning to end
so I do remember sitting and looking at
like one position for let's say 2 hours
straight um yeah of course a lot of that
is is like very root work but it really
can can make a difference when you're
when you're improving especially when
you're young a lot of those ideas sink
in a lot of the like um thought process
that you work on sinks in during your
games I love how you said that even if
specific books don't hold up maybe to
the engines these days they still have a
big impact in the development of a
person people sometimes forget about
that and it's very important to have a
strong player like yourself mention
those things because working on your own
it's it's really something that's
building up a strong understanding yeah
yeah I think that's the most important
thing cuz sometimes we focus on like you
work half an hour on a position and you
find out that the the book was wrong cuz
let's say it was written before computer
times and they're going to make mistakes
and then you think this whole process
was worthless but in fact I think that
just because you were sitting there
calculating is more worthwhile than
whatever like let's say objective value
of the position was of course and you're
coming in this year as the champion do
you feel any pressure um getting into
this competition considering that you
have to switch from classical chest to
Rapid 9lx do you feel any pressure PR
for this particular event to bring back
the championship I think normal amounts
of pressure because every year it's
pretty much a toss-up like anyone could
potentially win so I don't feel like um
like let's say all the pressure is on me
I think the pressure is kind of evenly
split among players who who all have
their hopes of winning and yeah very
often it comes down to um who's just
who's just uh on the best form during
the tournament so I mean we have guys
like Levon and Wesley and lenier uh and
also the the younger players are very
promising very dangerous now they're
growing up a bit so they're kind of
maturing more in their chess approach um
we saw like Sean was um was very
impressive in 9 LX um but also Jeffrey
and and Ray and all these players are
very capable so I don't feel like I have
so much pressure on me compared to other
players I think everyone will be dealing
with this a bit and and also the last
very serious tournament I played the
World Cup uh I don't think that the
pressure is going to compare to that
that's a bit more because it's like a
knockout and more um riding on a single
game or a single move that this pressure
is is probably going to be a bit more uh
Pleasant compared to that well thank you
Fabiana thank you very much I wish you
good luck and looking forward to seeing
your games thank
you
yeah um it's amazing what the club has
done for chess in general because I mean
it's already been 15 years and they've
done countless uh national championships
tournaments for juniors helping gr
around schools and they've just grown
the game so much across the United
States I think if I look at my own
career and I look at American chust in
general we're in a much better place
than we were 15 years ago and so the
contributions have been immense and of
course all thanks to Dr J singfield and
Rex
singfield I would say that St lucious
Club is like a rock in the ocean of
Chess and we know that it's it's there
it is there it will be there I think it
sense a hope that the game of chess will
always stay flat by the mere fact of its
existence I think it it it sends
positive waves across the
globe
the St Louis chess club is the Premier
chess facility in the United States we
bring the educational benefits of Chess
to thousands of students across the St
Louis area we also promote Chess at the
highest levels hosting all levels of the
US championships as well as high-profile
tournaments that attract the world's
best players become a member and enjoy
perks such as free classes and lectures
weekly tournaments and so much more
visit St Louis chess club.org to claim
your membership today the World Chess
Hall of Fame located in the heart of St
Louis's historic Central West End want
to know why chess has intrigued people
around the world for nearly 1,500 years
stop by and learn about the impact of
Chess from our three floors showcasing
the art culture and history of the game
the World Chess Hall of Fame has
something for everyone to enjoy for more
information on current exhibits please
visit World Chess h.org
[Music]
the St Louis chess club Scholastic
program brings the educational value of
Chess to kids and schools across the St
Louis area active in over 100 schools
throughout the St Louis city and county
the St Louis chess club has been able to
reach over 85,000 students in both in
school and after school programs we
created the select chess training
program and the junior select chess
training program in order to elevate the
skill level in students across the St
Louis area these students receive
professional training from Grandmaster
verua niobian other programs include
chess cops a partnership with the St
Louis Police Department looking to
improve relationships between atrisk
kids and police officers in the St Louis
area with over 600 students playing
chess over the board since
2019 the St Louis chess club has also
created a chess merit badge for the
scouts BSA quickly becoming one of the
most popular badges with more than
250,000 Scouts earning the badge since
2011 students of chess can also pick up
a copy of read and WR chess thanks to
Club co-founder Dr jeie Karen sinkfield
anyone can learn how to understand chess
notation in no time we view chess as a
valuable educational tool learn more
about our Scholastic programming by
visiting St Louis chess club.org
education
[Music]
hello everyone and welcome back to our
live coverage of the 2023 national
championships as expected a very
eventful round 10 is underway and let's
remind everybody about the standings
coming into the day's event as well as
the updated as well we have a few uh
results in the open section cake yeah
let's start with the open section we
still have IO Carana who is leading with
six and half and a very good position on
the board but then he is closely
followed by wesaw and lenir Dominguez
who both Drew and have six points
exactly but keep in mind fabbi is
playing against Mishra and that game is
so very vitally important I think also
we were going to go through the ladies
standings if uh the if those were
ready guess not now we see that the on
C3 disappeared well the whole Mishra
game uh Christian I'm going to turn it
over to you because we had just praised
Fabby to the skies as a a player who um
had
well unblemished he was playing
incredibly accurate chess he was a full
exchange ahead there was absolutely no
compensation at this position uh just a
few moves ago uh k spotted an absolute
killer idea H4 H5 he played Queen B4 and
he got his pieces a little dis
combobulated and now suddenly Mishra has
clipped a pawn no absolutely seems like
maybe he missed that move H4 um but
let's uh let's see what happens in the
next couple of moves because this is
move 39 Mishra has 15 seconds on his
right now 15 seconds yes so Queen to E
two by the way uh Rook D1 on my board
was my guess he goes for Queen to C2
with 15 seconds on his clock right now
he's on for
42 okay
so I mean that's Knight on E5 is really
strong it's a good
night The Rook I mean the Knight is
still pinned but the position is
excellent oh this serly this is not that
easy anymore and the problem is okay
maybe it's still winning but the trend
obviously favors Mishra for sure but
knew that he's a couple of moves away
from clinching the title and I would
assume nerves play the part in that
decision to go Queen to B4 you know what
if I go Rook E1 now with the idea to um
to just stay that Knight on E5 you want
to take that Knight yeah but the problem
is Queen C5 Queen takes D5 is that not
another Pawn that is a check that's a
problem for sure and that was what the
move Rook D1 was uh designed for I think
uh what you're going to have to do is
just chase the queen away if the queen
does go to C5 Queen will go to D4 you're
in a better ending but no means is it
winning uh or anything like that he has
played Rook F2 which means he made a 4th
move and he just left the board he needs
a break I think uh he's upset oh I I I
would say he's furious with himself like
is furious in the sense of what am I
doing
you know uh he was already ready to give
us victory
speech he had this game in the hand oh
yes he and oh boy it's really really I
mean we've all been there we've all
experienced what it's like we 5 Seconds
let uh a wind slip away uh Rook F2 Queen
E4 we were kind of looking at Queen C5 I
don't think it makes a big
difference it's just that these pieces
are too active right my queen on A1 is
on a good diagonal but you know no I'm
playing the move Queen D4 and I'm
seeking to trade queens and they seeking
to trade a pair of of Rooks and leave
you with a knight and a but how is is
that end game to be honest I'm not 100%
sure I like that oh I'm not saying I'm I
I I'm winning or something I'm just
saying that I need
to these pieces are too just too coord
well coordinated if I let black play B5
and
H5 why I so happy again I guess the one
of the questions is can I go he's he's
done it he's played A4 I I was thinking
that you know if I allow B5 H5 if I put
my Pawn on A5 yeah I'm I'm more pleased
with myself but this is strange I mean I
must say Fab's play here but did you see
his like body language he was not happy
Furious he played this move A4 and this
is very atypical of him he almost always
stins after he makes time control
exactly he uh stops thinks for a while
tries to understand the new position
right and then uh go from there he
played this move A4 and by the way he
has options I mean A4 is not the only he
could have played he could have
challenged for the C5 I was thinking you
know instead of A4 to play Queen B2 to
go for that idea Rook E2 and maybe grab
the Knight or just force the queen to go
away you have options right mhm and
that's the problem I mean he didn't
almost think at all uh for this move A4
Anderson is probably a good move
probably continues maintaining the
advantage but it's just very atypical to
see this body language from him he's not
happy with what transpired in the last
few moves no really not happy he should
not be he should actually be miffed at
himself um just to remind everybody
where we currently stand we've got um uh
Andrew tang and darush are
also uh in the open section still at
work here and they just reached 40th
move so both got extra
time first impression is with I love
this Rook on G6 just eyeballing both the
E6 and G7 pawns looks to me like if
Andrew can play a move like Queen E5
isn't he just I think that's what he's
looking at because Queen E5 you cannot
really sacrifice the queen for two Rook
no because there's Queen takes E6 coming
and exactly I mean there's extra
pressure on G7 and if I can capture on
E6 with a queen then that's it's great
it's game over right so Andrew looking
very very good there in the Ladi section
I wanted to jump into the game of
Jennifer and Alice Lee because we like
what Jennifer was doing earlier but the
current position is two nights for a
rook and well I have to say I like Alice
that's so I me two nights who doesn't
like two nights two nights and you're
getting mated I mean come on and oh well
no I didn't see this part I was I I was
looking yeah I mean no now this game is
actually just over I think she's about
to resign is J yes yes wait w so King
G1 she played King G G1 you probably
bring the next can I get the other
Knight in like Knight G6 and just don't
go Knight E6
yeah just don't don't don't blunder The
Rook that that's right but Knight Knight
G6 that yeah you're right it's just
you're it's completely winning material
and
compensation the compensation lies with
Alice as well as the as the extra mat
that's a very important win for Alice
because she's so far tied with Ina Crush
but if Ina crush is not going to manage
to win her game um then she's going to
be in clear third well let's check it
out uh we go to the game between Arena
and beum we left it and we were thinking
for some reason I'm not exactly sure but
we were looking at a position uh Kate
where the Rook was coming down to C3
instead the move Queen G4 was essayed
and
now
well is the has the
momentum shifted back to Arena because
for the moment this Pawn is now well and
truly stopped uh blockaded Bishop takes
B4 as well as Rook D4 is on Arena's
agenda these and by the way on the king
side I have five against three I was
about to say that's a massive majority
um uh for arena as well so but are we in
time to recapture that pent so what if I
go Rook
AB8 I think the Rook just came from B8
actually interestingly enough so Rook B4
I'm ready
to okay so Rook uh
ec8 Rook ec8 shall we trade a pair of
Rooks I don't have a way to like jump
around with the night well I was once
told when I had
material somebody whispered that into my
mind yeah I know why this on time
exactly it's uh even though wait wait
wait a minute I I really don't like this
Rook takes B4 can I take take Knight B5
no there's King
E3 takes takes Knight B5 let me show
Christian what he might that's fine King
E3 Knight C3 King E3 Knight C3 right so
hold on he's got a he's got some
devilish I have some ideas okay so I go
Bishop
E6 Bishop D6 hold
On's he's got Devils okay that's evil
and
intentions uh this Christian Fellow
oh okay okay it's not completely dead
but I think you can take with a bishop
right I mean why would this exactly yeah
just take with a bishop it was funny
um well thing is covering the sea file I
think BL yeah I was blinded by uh the
Knight coming to be file in this case I
can just play Rook C4 for some reason I
thought I was hanging the bishop but can
you go Knight B1 I thought that's well
that's nice now I am dominating the
Knight right the bishop all of the
squares are are good now I kind of like
your king E3 and maybe but I have again
Knight C3 oh no did I just walk into an
uppercut gosh darn it yes no no no wait
wait wait don't give up yet by Christian
yeah no well I mean in that case let me
at least if you're going to play Knight
C3 let me not do it with chck but that's
not a good end game five versus three
what actually that's a lot of parts no
that that is a lot of parts you're tell
how do you get five well I've got you go
B4 yeah yeah yeah I've got five yeah
this is good this is probably good
should be good enough according to Sam
shanklin's Rook endings five start you
studed okay versus three is a nice
majority actually I kind of curious do
you think that position is as easily
winning as you think it is five versus
three on only one side because because
two sets of double pawns make things a
little bit more tricky how is our French
defense doing tat stop it stop it no
first of all uh let's just discuss to
show you how she should have played
beging that is because she was
completely out of danger in fact she
missed a move yes she played the move A4
this is move 39 and this was the big
mistake in the position what you have to
do is and this is the the move that she
missed Bishop to C5 to attack that pawn
on B4 first just take away that weapon
from your opponent and you want to put
the Rook behind the pawn anyway so Rook
ec8 was way to go A4 King to E2 and then
you go A4 that's completely different
story it's very difficult to Coral this
Pawn on C2 or the pawn on B4 as well
this would have given begim I have to
say equal chances objectively but from a
practical perspective I'm starting to
like black right specifically because of
this Pawn on C2 she did not uh play that
she played the move A4 and allowed this
bishop C5 is a big problem because
you're losing the B4 pawn and once you
lose the B4 Pawn the problem is I'm
getting to your knight and that Knight
protects the uh all uh MVP in your
position the PA on C2 right a takes B3 a
takes B3 that's what we have right now
Rook to C8 and Bishop to B4 and we think
that Arena has really good chances to
win this one um so this is quite an
important one for arena as well because
you guys were mentioning she's with
Alice Lee that's the fight for third and
guess what tatv is in the fight for the
podium as well and uh she needs to
maintain the pace and she does in this
position I mean she's a pawn up she has
a beautiful structure I great I never
thought I would say that coming from a
French continue yeah but the French is
looking good
this yes yes beautiful night you cannot
get to my pawns I'm going to just simply
are pushing a mine on the king side at
the right moment H5 G5 King G7 things of
that nature and uh it's looking good
it's really looking good for TV and
that's a good sign for Karissa as well
ruang has had a good event up to a
couple of rounds ago yesterday against
be him Bishop takes B4 that was crazy
absolutely uh uh big big Miss in that
one understandably so people are getting
tired in this one but if you are Kissa
and you see her uh losing game after
game you know that okay that's momentum
right there that's negative momentum if
you think about it okay let's try take
advantage of that and by the way if
begim loses in this one and goes into
the final one a half a point lead well
that's going to be a pretty good spot
sweet spot for Kissa absolutely H5 I've
always felt like the French defense like
the Sicilian the Sicilian Defense you
take a lot of strategic risk but if you
ever get the advantage in the Sicilian
it's sort of like an avalanche it just
kind of propels forward same thing with
a French you you know you take some
strategic risk but if you do get in
control it's sort of like the question
is are you going to get into control
you're going to just suffer and suffer
and then you suffer it's miserable then
you die H7 H5 I like this uh by tatv and
she's putting her majority to work it
looks very very very very good fabbi uh
let's just jump to the game of Fabby
because again I mean he could clinch
with a victory today he just played the
move A2 A4 for those of you who are
joining as late we just kind of
mystified we had just um praised Fabby
to the skies for his extraordinarily
accurate play uh he he created the
double Pawn he attacked M just most
accurate most like 10 in a row indeed
and he he achieved this position a full
exchange there's just like no
compensation just no compensation uh and
the most direct and Powerful was H4 H5
H6 when the pawn gets to H5 if you take
the queen takes so H4 and the engine was
going berserk you know plus six and and
worse he played this move Queen B4 which
okay okay tags the pawn on D6 but after
the move Knight C4 the the queen and the
Rooks aren't really in harmony like you
would like to immediately take your move
back and triple if you will on the file
so you could invade with rook f8 and
Rook F7 and then things just kind of
went backwards and as things were going
backwards for white by the way the
surprising moment is here Queen D1 just
giving up that pawn on C3 what did you
expect I don't know Queen C2 or queen C2
defend that guy not bad I makes it makes
a lot of sense uh players were in time
trouble probably I'm going to have to go
back with my night anyway maybe you are
but it a lot of slippage occurred and as
you said there goes the pawn and it
wasn't even that because now it's sort
of
like black is coordinating The Rook
suddenly is on the open file the queen
is being annoying at the very least and
suddenly uh black is back black is back
but objectively it's still white that
it's doing quite well in fact complely
winning but again it's all about the
trend right it's all about the
psychology of the players there's so
much tension so much pressure on Fabiano
to finish the job right win the game win
the championship that plays that can
play with your mind uh quite uh severely
and that's what happening H5 Queen to A3
seems to be the right approach in the
position maybe Fabiano had this idea in
mind when he played the move A4 right
tickling the D6 Pawn it's important
right because you have to create some uh
active ideas in the position you don't
have those around this Knight I mean
this Knight on E5 was a beautiful piece
for a very long time the problem is it
didn't have a lot of things to do and in
fact you're just getting massacred on
the king side that H4 H5 that Kina
showed us that was very beautiful for he
should have done it he knows that he
should have done it Queen to A3 is
important get back into the game that's
important for Fabiano right now just uh
go to the bathroom wash your face with
some uh cold water and just try to
restart the process and that's the
difficult part and that's why he hates
the position that he's in right now
because he knows he had it in the back
right now he has to restart the process
and take it uh from the start by the way
how do you continue if Black Goes Rook
C5 let's say I simply want to defend
that pawn yes so what's the problem with
Rook C5 you're letting the seventh rank
empty so now I can start focusing on the
attack against the B7 Pawn maybe I can
start with A5 just to cement the
weakness as is so you don't mind giving
up that pawn on
D5 no okay I will grab it you will take
it I will take it the training is
working I'm proud of you k so let's try
Rook to C1
maybe not the best
Mo Rook F F1 that's not a okay you know
what I'll give it to you he's not going
to play moves such as Rook ff1 cuz if
you go like Rook C1 I will probably go
Rook D3 A5 by the way has been I like if
we go back for a moment Queen A3 Rook C5
I like this for white but play Queen B2
okay like if you want to play B5 and
open up the board that's fine I I
probably will have to do it open up some
files takes and rookie
two can I just disturb the the
coordination yeah yeah yeah yeah you can
play this or go Queen H4 I don't think
Rook takes C5 actually works yeah I know
I was ready to go Rook takes E5 and
D6 uh oops no I meant uh D6 immediately
but I know what you mean yeah it's not
happening it's not happening yet he
played A5 he played A5 yeah we have this
position on the board and to be honest I
sort of like this move A5 kind of with
the same idea that we were looking
at5 right now Rook C5 I go Queen B2 and
you probably have to go back in that
case you have to go back that's his plan
um I sort of like it again still very
much Fabiano's game to win in this one
the trend favors abim Manu but we know
Fabio has been in this position has
destroyed advantages in the past it's
not Pleasant it's one of the more
painful aspects of Chess but as a
professional he knows that he needs to
pull himself back up and get the victory
uh returning uh to our all important
clash in the lady section Arena Crush uh
up against beum uh they've gotten a
position kind of like what we were
looking at Bishop takes B5 Knight came
to B1 uh we're not
blundering stuff
here3 but one of the things things I
really like about this bishop is it
domination over the Knight and I do like
this move very much Rook D3 so long as
this Pawn is firmly blockaded then I've
got nothing to worry about and maybe
maybe only after further you know put my
king on E3 I'll put my Bishop on D6 and
um I don't know maybe even on a good day
I'll get to play H4 you know that's what
I'm thinking am I focused now on
capturing the Bon to or maybe I'm going
to be improving on the king side you
know it's it's wonderful that you should
say that because when you have an
advantage you just want to increase your
advantage and in this case increasing
your advantage on the king Side by
playing H4 H5 by playing F4 F5 by just
improving your pieces whether it be your
king your Rook put your Bishop on D6
always look for those improving moves
and yeah I I would definitely the
be going in that direction H4 H5 H4 F5
those types of things this looks like
arena is doing great here ruang versus
tatv again this is you know extra Pawn
for tatv she's seems to be in cruise
control Alice
Lee whoa whoa whoa whoa who we thought
there is some Checkmate coming up yes we
did uh normally speaking whenever you're
playing with the two knights versus a
rook the two knights really like
company uh they they want to have Queens
they want to have other pieces normally
speaking with the when it's just Knights
versus the Rooks Rooks can actually be
very strong and then when sometimes when
the knights are not well placed they can
out play the night having said that this
is one of those cases where black has
two knights and a pawn which means that
uh well
Alice is in control so Alice is nicely
waiting with capturing that pawn on B2
making sure the other Knight is there to
support a pawn once uh Jennifer starts
to attack the Knight exactly and here I
see that uh from Alice's point of view
she's ready to play Knight to D4 E4
E3 and the Knights
beautifully
escort uh the pawn you know she may even
start with E3 because after E3 you
cannot really play King E2 oh no that's
you're absolutely right
E3 uh so I have to start with Rook A8
I'm King E2
yeah oh you have Rook
check
fortunately otherwise it would be
resigns right because yeah I I I was
about to say if the Knight jumps to D4 I
could go Rook check and put the Rook to
stop the Knight um but this should be
Alice's this should be a technical uh
win for Alice and she has 40 minutes to
calculate do I want to catch her on B2
do I want to try to promote the E Pawn
uh I mean nice PL absolutely asria
versus atusa um what does this like a
theoretical what does Sam shanklin's uh
uh Magnus Opus have to say about this
one because if you look a little bit
back you see that the white king kind of
traveled or or already to the center but
the Rook was always giving it a chance
oh that's not a difficult one that's
that's just simply easy draw because
easy draw easy draw yeah because this
Pawn looks so menacing that's about it
like I go King E4 I go King E3 I go King
F3 King
E4 Ah that's it and you're always
threatening to play King F5 so it's and
you're cut your own King is cut you have
to go all the way to B7 to un cut
yourself right if that's a word uncut
yourself I guess in chess context I
guess you can uncut
yourself uncut yourself yeah king3 this
is shake hands very soon okay I draw on
that one again we are expecting Alice
Lee uh to win her game we do think that
arena
is well that it's not easy no no really
not easy because okay let's say why not
why isn't it not easy Rook to D3 Rook to
D3
already I just Rook to A2 Rook to A2
okay so I've got my king I'm asking you
what's your plan uh I don't know
seriously I don't know I'm just
improving my pieces I'm putting my king
on E3 so that in the near future I could
play
F4 F5 and maybe bishop to D6 and B4 I'll
wait I guess King G7 something like that
okay so I'll
Bishop okay let's have some fun let's go
F5 now you go F5 and see if I can't open
you okay captures captures twice tce why
not I can never allow you to go F6 so I
have to capture exactly so King F4 okay
now the king is kind of fur away that's
a good thing for me it it's actually
really funny because I was going to play
Rook G1 Shack and Rook H3 mate except
that's
illegal so that's why when so so I'm
playing King
F3 to Pardon Me King to F4 so that I can
take on F5 play F4 and then I announce
mate that's looking good yes okay let's
try to go back a little bit Rook to A2
maybe doesn't actually do
much um let's say on the B file okay
let's go so you go Rook D3 I go Rook B8
so sorry the you I think you started
with Rook D3 right I did so let's go
Rook B8 on The aou Rook A8 A8 yes okay
Bishop D6 right that's a Tempo nice
Tempo
B6 and it's funny I just I just feel
like I my king should be closed or what
do you think uh Kate should I be playing
for I want on E3 so there are no
discovered
I always managed to I always managed to
put my king on the wrong Square so that
I uh walk into a temple so what if I go
like oh I can go she has by the way
played King E3 okaying did uh she didn't
Arena did not play the move Rook
D3 but King E3 whoa whoa whoa so she
doesn't mind Knight
C3 whoa whoa whoa why what what
Rook
D4 she wants to go Rook D4 Rook to D4
yeah but Knight C3 weren't we here
before I think we were yes and maybe I
think she probably wants to take on C2
now and
allow a check
D5 I think you have to go D5 just
because Knight D1 and King D2 might be
enough and now perhaps D6 maybe this is
what she calculated I mean I agree uh
there's a lot of pawns for for an
exchange
and likely white is winning really yeah
Rook B2 D7 captures on
B3 King
F2 this is very strong I must say it's
going
yeah okay uh well it's well calculated
if it works so let's go back okay let's
try to dissect this position to the
maximum King King to
E3 can we start with Knight
C3 Knight C3 yes well here I I think I'm
ready to embrace the Rook ending with
open arms oh you are
okay I think per you're right yes
because I my king is so close to
rounding up this
peski okay I agre here just a second
okay let's let's let's keep it going for
one more move uh r
C8 C8 King D2 and now I go Rook C7 let's
see Rook C7 okay how do you make big
progress okay well they say that Rooks
belong behind past pawns push him of
course
and so let's give you Rook C4 and we
continue push him Baby Oh I thought he
going to just go B5 give you a check now
just to I'm not sure I'm not sure which
one let's go Rook d8 Rook d8 yes okay
you got
me I think I'm rounding this guy up and
I'm threatening this guy so we're going
to get in that five versus three three
yeah that's you're going to go here I'm
going to go here you're going to go here
we're going to trade and we get to this
position where I once saw Magnus Carlson
win rook and four versus rook and four
on the same
side that too that wasn't easy for
Magnus this would be a walk in the park
he's got five
PS so it shouldn't be that difficult no
if I go just King F2
G3 King F2 King G3 G4 and push F5
exactly
although again they're that you're going
to have to to do some preps by the way
we do have Rook B8 on the board and
we're going to see Rook D4 I don't think
there's anything
else yes Rook B8 Rook D4 she's played it
as you've predicted but then I think
beum needs to
avoid this Knight C3 Knight D5 though
right because we are thinking that
this is actually really good for white
let's make sure of it do we have
anything as black right now to try to
defend somehow I mean D7 B so fast right
is incredibly fast yeah I don't see it I
mean if Rook B2 doesn't work and it
doesn't work it seems like it doesn't
work at least exactly so how does bon
put up resistance then because this is
the current position so I went for this
Rook ending but that was when you played
Knight C3 at the start without the
inclusion of Rook B8 mhm okay so let's
say I go Rook B7 or B6 okay let's go B7
let's try fair
fair okay now the knight's trapped King
to D King to D3 so the Knight cannot
Escape I can go to A3 I can still go to
A3 that's a nice trick I don't want to
go to A3 I really don't want to go to A3
because I'm not going anywhere else
after that exactly you're not okay you
go to A3 but you're not threatening
necessarily to go to B5 because I have
Rook
C4 and we do believe that this game is a
draw yeah that's a draw that is a draw
as players already signing the score
sheet the players are indeed um okay
this this looks again like Arena Crush
should be having a a technical Victory
let me just jump to the game of Alice
Lee for a second okay Alice did the
sensible thing she took another Pawn I
mean we're talking about increase your
advantages whatever advantages you have
in a position so now she has two pawns
but she needs to make sure the knights
are supporting at least one of the pawns
so the pawns can go forward right but on
the other hand that's not that easy to
well well wait a minute what's better
what what did you ask just support the
pawn yes so I go Rook C8 well it's funny
if you go King here I was going to go
here and I thought that was a nice
geometry this Knight is supporting the
squares right and if you went King here
uh to E3 I was going to go C3 and again
if your Rook goes behind I was still
going to go KN already there supporting
so how are you going to meet Knight D4
I'll start with Rook C8 perfect Rook to
C8 Knight F3 check King E3 King
E3 now let me Munch a pawn okay I
capture on e4 yes on e4
so
i' I want to munch this one too how to
best do that not so simple not
coordinating I apologize I'm not coordin
somehow thought I was doing more than
just
that okay
apologies okay in that case I have to
involve my king no King okay I still go
Rook C8 and I don't want to lose this
one so I'll go Knight here so if your
king goes here I wanted to push this
Pawn this is a very good idea okay it's
rare but sometimes all right I have a
different idea no I think this is good
for blacks I'm going to play something
different okay instead of Rook C8 okay I
will go so you go King F6 okay and I go
Rook
A4 that is nice so that really puts the
kabash on my previous
idea we'll probably play something like
Knight E5 to defend that pawn yes I
think it's I'm not sure this is like
very very winning very very winning is
it that easy it's so easy seriously
there's no way you I can give you a C4
pawn and that that should see and then
you just Waltz in with the E Pawn Yeah
that may you might save uh this position
if I don't have the E and C Pawn though
even that is probably very difficult to
do so as why M but with thec Pawn
there's no way you can survive that guys
please this is a funny situation what's
going on I I just checked it with the
engine in fact this was the wrong way of
doing things as white for white guess
why so after Rook to D4 Rook to B7 or B6
let's say B7 right right you go King D3
yeah and now I go this Knight A3 we got
to this position yes or we're like okay
we don't like the Knight on A3 the thing
is it's a zean it's a mutual zean like
how do you improve your position H4
that's fine King
G7 um F5 let's just say okay once you go
F5 I'll pick that that one
up how improve your you cannot move the
Rook because C1 you cannot move the king
I mean you can but then I give you a
check and then we go to the same
position okay so what if I go King E3
then I go back to
B1 how do you improve your position you
can go to F4 but now Knight C3 is coming
right this is now this is already a
completely different situation yeah this
is getting a little bit uh out of hand
maybe so this is a critical situation if
she understands but this this is the
difficult part Knight A3 it looks like
it's you just wait you just wait after
Knight A3 that's peculiar you go Knight
A3 and then you just wait and it seems
like the way to try to get something out
of the position just simply Falls for
Knight B1 and then we repeat the
position and I just stay like this I
wait you go H4 that's fine I
wait I keep on waiting and how do you
make any progress because you set up
this position with the Rook on D4 and
the bishop on yeah this is cemented as
is because you cannot move the bishop I
take on B3 that's a check with direct
consequences so you cannot do that so
what do you do I just don't see it guys
um I understand white still should have
some sort of an advantage I just don't
see it after this idea of knight uh A3
and Knight B1 and to my eyes you're kind
of forced to go into it because you have
to wait right now King D3 comes that
attacks your Pawn and then if you don't
defend that pawn well you're losing it
and then you're losing the Knight as
well okay uh you're forced to find
Knight A3 and then you're like okay
something is going to have to give and
I'm going to lose but then you realize
it's some sort of a okay I I I I think I
realize that that what you're saying so
from the current position yes uh after
so let's say Rook B7 or Rook B6 Rook B7
King D3 Knight A3 right yes
I'm going to end up having to play for
F4 F5 F5 but my King has to be on F4 so
I'll go back King E3 or yeah Knight B1
you also have to be careful at Rook
Knight B5 at some okay from the current
position so where do you go no just the
current position this you mean yes okay
so Rook B7 so I have to play
F5 does Rook B8
is Rook b a threat I don't know uh I'm
just uh and I'll move my
bishop6 and K but it doesn't really
matter yeah okay and also you have Rook
D3 right mhm mhm mhm so I have to wait
that's the difficult part about this
position you just simply have to wait F5
I will take take take take take and then
Knight to see3 now right and I was
wondering my king always somehow
magically my King's in the wrong
position no matter what I seem to be
doing so the idea is that once the pawn
leaves the E4 square and there's no more
e takes D5 when Knight D5 comes then you
can go Knight C3 that's the point that
then I don't have I Cann take with a
pawn and push my Pawn play D6 right
that's that's not easy to understand
that is truly not easy to understand but
again Rook to D4 and by the way we're
going to have to keep a close eye on the
clocks Christian can I play just let's
say King
G7 right now just like do nothing King
G7 King
D3 and now Knight A3 yes Knight A3 King
E2 Knight
B1 ah no Bishop D6 where's my
Improvement where's my Improvement well
what we're going to do okay let's do the
same thing and then I go to E3 and then
what do you do now oh King G then you go
King
G
almost we are going to be taking a break
and we're going to come back and we when
we come back we'll see if we uh have the
conclusion of this penultimate round 10
we'll see you on the other side of our
[Music]
break
Karissa thank you so much for joining me
here today I want to ask you a little
bit about your chess upbringing so I
started when I was in elementary school
so I was seven when I first um started
playing tournament chess but I first was
interested in it when I was six um
there's like a flyer for the school
chess club and it met like before school
in the mornings and I really wanted to
to go and play uh but the problem was
like they didn't have any instructors
there it was just like to go and play
chess with each other and I had no idea
how the pieces move nothing um and so my
parents were just like ah it's okay
don't join the club and I was like okay
um and then like the year after I was
like Mom Dad can I join chess club and
then they were like oh this is something
that you know maybe she's like really
interested in and so my dad first taught
himself how to play and like how pieces
moved and stuff and then taught me um
and we used to play all the time when I
was a kid just like on the floor in the
living room
and I was always trying super hard to
beat him never really could until one
day a few months later um but yeah and
since we played so much eventually he
got like really tired of it and he's
like one night he's just like I'm just
going to take you to like a actual chess
club and that was where I played my
first tournament was there something
specific or specific person that
influenced you most or you looked up to
the most as you're growing up yeah so
definitely my dad was up there we spent
so many hours just like playing chess
together um you know I was always like
really fighting and struggling to beat
him which I think is probably where like
that Spirit comes from for me um another
big influence was when I was starting
out um I played in one Club WUSA chess
club and I remember so it met like every
Wednesday night and it would be like one
game a night it would be like one of
those uh month-long tournaments sort of
situations and everyone there was super
nice um I was the only kid there but
after all my games um they always
offered to like analyze it with me we'
go over all the moves and like all the
club members would be there and like
offering suggestions and helping me
improve my chest and they've also been
like a great source of support nice and
was there something specific that
attracted you to the game I think the
first time I was like really into chess
was when I was at my school chess club
and I was playing um a friend and this
friend was like probably the smartest
person I knew at the time she still is
like super smart maybe still smartest
person I know um and we were playing
chess and I beat her like three times in
a row to be fair we weren't really
playing with um actual chess rules it
was like this idea that if you put the
king in check and the other person
didn't notice and you just take the king
and win so doesn't really count but I
beat her three times in a row and I was
like wao maybe this is something that
I'm like kind of good at I see and since
then you went to college you're
combining chess and college and recently
you became World um Junior Vice Champion
for girls um how were you able to
balance your schoolwork and chess and
coming back to chess I know you had this
short period of time where you didn't
play as much yeah so um my school is
actually on the quarter system which is
super convenient because it doesn't
start until really late September almost
October really um and so I wasn't
missing um too many too much of the my
academic work when so playing these
tournaments but this is actually the
first tournament where I'll be like um
Missing full weeks of school along with
uh playing chess so we'll see how that
goes so this is the first time so I
can't ask you how you're balancing
everything but hopefully you did you did
a good job in planning everything so
that you don't have exams during the
event yeah no exams during uh just
homework and stuff like that and uh last
question for you Kisa I was wondering if
uh you are doing any other ex
extracurricular activities in your
University besides you know working on
chess and going to school nope nothing
nothing interesting no yeah well I'm
really looking forward to seeing you
back on the over the board I know you
haven't played last year so can't wait I
can't wait to see um how how you're
going to do thank you good luck thank
[Music]
you yeah um it's amazing what the club
has done for chess in general because I
mean it's already been 15 years and
they've done countless uh national
championships tournaments for juniors
helping your own schools and they've
just grown the game so much across the
United States I think if I look at my
own career and I look at American chest
in general we're in a much better place
than we were 15 years ago and so the
contributions have been immense and of
course it's all thanks to uh Dr juny
singfield and rock
singfield I would say that S luia Club
is like a rock in the tion of Chess and
we know that it's it's there it is there
it will be there I think it sense a hope
that the the game of chess will always
stay Float by the mere fact of its
existence I think it it it sends
positive waves across the
[Music]
globe the St Louis chess club is the
Premier chess facility in the United
States we bring the educational benefits
of Chess to thousands of students across
the St Louis area we also promote Chess
at the highest levels hosting all levels
of the US championships as well as
high-profile tournaments that attract
the world's best players become a member
and enjoy perks such as free classes and
lectures weekly tournaments and so much
more visit St Louis chess club.org to
claim your membership
today the World Chess Hall of Fame
located in the heart of St Louis's
historic Central West End want to know
why chess has intrigued people around
the world for nearly 15500 years stop by
and learn about the impact of Chess from
our three floors showcasing the art
culture and history of the game the
World Chess Hall of Fame has something
for everyone to enjoy for more
information on current exhibits please
visit World Chess h.org
the St Louis chess club Scholastic
program brings the educational value of
chess to kids and schools across the St
Louis area active in over 100 schools
throughout the St Louis city and county
the St Louis chess club has been able to
reach over 85,000 students in both in
school and after school programs we
created the select chess training
program and the junior select chess
training program in order to elevate the
skill level in students across the St
Louis area these students receive
professional training from Grandmaster
verua niobian other programs include
chess cops a partnership with the St
Louis Police Department looking to
improve relationships between atrisk
kids and police officers in the St Louis
area with over 600 students playing
chess over the board since
2019 the St Louis chess club has also
created a chess merit badge for the
scouts BSA quickly becoming one of the
most popular badges with more than
250,000 Scouts earning the badge since
2011 students of chess can also pick up
a copy of read and write chess thanks to
Club co-founder Dr jeie Karen sinkfield
anyone can learn how to understand chess
notation in no time we view chess as a
valuable educational tool learn more
about our Scholastic programming by
visiting St Louis chess club.org
[Music]
seducation St Louis the chess capital of
the United States boasts the worldclass
St Louis chess club and the World Chess
Hall of Fame it also plays host to an
award-winning shop dedicated to chess
merchandise All Occasion gifts and
plenty more at Q Boutique you can shop
both in store and online for chess
merchandise autograph Collectibles chess
campus souvenirs and much much more from
quirky greeting cards to luxury chess
sets there is something for everyone at
Q Boutique and all purchases go right to
benefiting new exhibitions and programs
at the World Chess Hall of Fame
dedicated to exploring chess and its
immense impact on art and culture
located on the first floor of the World
Chess Hall of Fame enjoy a shopping
experience like no other and become
everyone's favorite Gift Giver if you
can shop in store make sure to check out
Q Boutique stl.com for a wide variety of
gifts for everyone to
[Music]
enjoy the St Louis chess club is the
Premier chess facility in the United
States and is among the best in the
world thanks to co-founders Dr jeie
Karen sinkfield and Rex sinkfield the St
Louis chess club is a nonprofit
organization committed to promoting the
game of chess locally and
internationally we bring the educational
benefits of Chess to thousands of
students across the St Louis area
promoting cognitive development critical
thinking concentration and analytical
skills the St Louis chess club welcomes
chess lovers of of any age and skill
level to come and enjoy the game of
chess we also promote Chess at the
highest levels hosting all levels of the
US championships and the American Cup as
well as high-profile tournaments that
attract the world's best players
including the prestigious sinkfield cup
Karen's cup and many more all
tournaments can be streamed via our
YouTube and twitch channels that also
include over 2,000 chess lectures for
anyone to enjoy become a member and
enjoy perks such as free classes and
lectures weekly tournaments merchandise
discounts and so much more visit St
Louis chess club.org to claim your
membership
[Music]
today hello everyone and welcome back to
our live coverage of the 2023 national
championships well we think fobby has
right did the ship and what an important
uh result that would be if Fabby were to
win his game he' clinch the title and he
would be um uh successful in terms of
Defending his title back Tob back back
to back Champion Christian uh well it
wasn't easy no Mishra really put up some
great uh defense tell us uh because Mish
just captured this Pawn on D5 tell us
why this position so
not not easy at all let's take a look at
what happened in the last few moves it
was at this point I have to say Mishra
was really getting primed for nice
attack on the king side I was looking at
the lines offered by the engine they did
not look convincing at all Rook to F1 G4
and now you have to go King H1 allow G
takes H3 you don't do this with a title
on the line you almost never go for
these type of lines he played the very
practical Queen to B6 chop the Queens
off off let's let's get an end game
let's make the position a bit more
simple Queen takes B6 a takes B6 Rook to
C5 and now I understand the fact that
I'm going to lose one of these pawns
you're going to have two pawns for the
exchange but in the meantime what I'm
going to do is I'm going to set up some
checkmating ideas and that's exactly
what's happening King to G6 Rook to uh
F1 Rook takes D5 rook f8 and now we have
a G4 on the board do I want to your king
to get in absolutely check let's go with
H4 or the
move you like this one I like that one
cuz if you go back to H7 then I'm going
to go after the B7 Pawn that's yeah
that's right that's very nice that's
probably the key and the way to continue
this one um H4 is also a move in
position but I have to say Rook to G
lookss looks clean right CLE yeah King
to H6 how bad is this probably even
worse because now I'm looking at some
checkmates on the eighth rank as well
checkmating patter question is who's
giving the Checkmate first right King to
G7 probably I don't want to go here I
can go all the way back to F1 and in
fact yeah you're uh hunting my queen a
little bit Yeah my Rook excuse me so yes
I will go Rook to F1 right exactly
picking up the pawn with check but uh we
have a very young lady uh in studio um
Christian over to you and Alice Lee we
do uh we have Alice Lee Alice first of
all congratulations a difficult game
against the defending Champion Jennifer
U but with the black pieces you did not
slow down once again pile on the
pressure and it finally paid off you
were fighting for the podium right now
tell us a bit about today's
game um yeah so I played the qg which I
don't think that she expected because I
played like the slav upto um now it's in
this tournament uh so I think like uh my
position out of the opening was pretty
good um and I think uh I was like kind
of slowly able to play her until this
like around Before Time control there
was this like move 38 where I just
completely blundered like I like I'm
completely winning here and then here
she has Ras G7 and I was like oh I'm
like there's no way I can win this the
most I have is a
Perpetual so like this a
Prof yeah yeah and I don't have anything
how much time did she have but uh this
particular she only had a minute I think
okay yeah she only had a minute here so
of course it was hard but it was like uh
yeah I mean um I was completely winning
before that so I definitely shouldn't
have blundered that um but of course I
think uh it's hard for her to play
especially in time trouble so uh I think
after this I was able to win pretty
nicely absolutely and you've done so in
a remarkable fashion you never let go of
the advantage after this particular
moment congratulations Alis I have to
say that's a good performance in the the
second half of the event guys join the
conversation well you had a big you had
a bad start Alice and you had this very
very very nice comeback but two ladies
have just been doing extraordinarily
well from your perspective what is it
like uh watching uh beum and Karissa win
game after
game yeah I mean um so after my uh start
of course I had really no chance but to
see beum and chissa doing so well I mean
they're obviously both in really great
shape they're playing really great chess
um and I think uh the fight for first
place will certainly be very interesting
to watch absolutely exciting finish
round 11 will'll be forging a new
Champion Alice uh we'll see you tomorrow
and congratulations for your win today
over the defending
Champion I thank
youc she went she went
past I was waiting for the thank you it
was wasn't well you heard it yeah I
heard it you did hear
it wasn't there now let's go back to the
fobby again because uh I think this is
so consequential for you know the
championship this is the championship
game and it does feel like he's putting
the finishing touches so perhaps we can
analyze it on your board while we watch
these two Gladiators battle it all out
so we did see that important kind of
Rook G8 check the idea behind this move
by Fabby is to try to get the king to
step back to the seventh rank so that we
will be able to pick up this Pawn with
check and I think so where do he go yeah
okay well we tried as uh you just did
King H6 I don't think it really matters
because the Rook would go check and then
the Rook would come back to F1 King H7
immediately immediately responding with
Rook B8 yes and is time a factor they've
made time control control obviously but
definitely a fact so Fabiano has 11
minutes while abanu 5 minutes it's not a
lot with this position but okay let's
let's just see should what do you think
Kate looking for trying to set up some
check yeah yeah try to make some trouble
let's go with G3 we need that pawn there
that's the question do we uh for example
check King H6 or G6 G6 maybe uh I'm
thinking about the move Rook B1 as we
know Rook belongs behind pass pawns with
the idea of Rook C7 and B7 I think you
will have to give me that Knight for the
pawn at some point exactly so so for
example actually move G4 just you don't
have time for we start oh sorry let's
keep going in that position I don't
think it's complely over no Knight C4
Knight C4 you go Rook C7 I take on B6
that's fair okay you
once again I'm eyeballing Rook G8 and B7
and now do I have
something in the nick of time save me I
mean if you could if you could go
problem is I'm also losing the G3 Pawn
Yeah I've got this Rook G8 check
business again nothing nothing nothing
so I think G3 just we don't have the
time for Rook G for G3 we have to get
the Rook behind which is what Mishra did
takes King G6 King G6 and we'll probably
be up to date with the players right
here should we take on G4 just in
case
um normally speaking I'm trying to keep
as many pawns on the board as
possible with the with the two
Rooks
um so normally speaking I do want to
play the move H3 H4 so I can go like
Rook G5 check
uh ideas um by the way does Arena have
30 seconds on her clock say
what say
what uh just a second let me stop
whatever I was about to uh add because
in the ladies
Championship 30 seconds did you w she's
less than a minute while beckim has 10
minutes that's a giant time Advantage it
certainly is and
whenever uh you're down to 30 or less
seconds
I mean it it plays strange games with
your mind you start seeing a ghost and I
love the triple twist that Hans had
right like just the last second he just
saw that sacrifice on G6 went through
this variation quite a few times this
Knight B1 Knight A3 they've already
repeated the position I see that Knight
A3 Knight B1 Knight A3 begim understands
that she just needs to hold a position
with this Knight B1 Knight A3 and there
is no way for uh for Crush to to get
more out of this position I find that
extraordinary I just think how is that
even humanly possible I mean it's sort
of like again you know just uh big I'm
very very very lucky uh to be in a
situation where she's several pawns down
but somehow tricky tricky situation
again Knight B1 is going to come on the
board we know that right there's no
other
actually there is no other alternative I
am actually threatening to take that and
that would be a piece knight to B1 and
then what do you do do you push right
now do you push for a win cuz you have
one minute on the clock right if you go
King D3 I think that's a three-fold
repetition already well well well
strangely enough this wasn't the setup I
wanted for for arena I somehow I was
getting the Rook on D3 maybe the bishop
to um D6 so if I'm playing for the win
it has to be based upon the move F5
right right and this is the key right
now take take a knight to
C3 were you waiting for me to play King
F4 right I don't think I was no I think
I was just waiting for you to do a get
that pawn off the E4 Square okay so
takes takes and you were ready to go
Knight C3 in this in this
position and again uh if I take Knight
D5 Knight D5 take take and this guy is
hanging I do understand that
I'm for some strange reason I'm
attracted to or first check on the eight
forcing the king to go to H7 you don't
want to go to G7 and low me Bishop f8 I
capture on
G6 with the King I'm happy now my king
is out not getting married I'm happy
I've got
you have a lot but you're also losing
some by the way King D3 King D3 she had
only 5 seconds on the clock oh that's a
three-fold repetition right there so
with the
move with the move night
A3 can claim a draw which means there
that uh she will be tied with Karissa
going into tomorrow's round and she
didn't claim the draw no I'm not sure
why but she decided not to
I guess she's hoping I think she's
confident that Crush just needs to
repeat because she spent so much time at
looking at this position for like 20
minutes found nothing and always let her
clock go to 5 three seconds and then
just move back and
forth oh wow saying no so she could have
played hold on oh my goodness let me get
this straight again so beum could have
played to the Arbiter I will play Knight
A3 make a draw that's it yes and
everything to play for tomorrow the
title is on the line instead she played
Knight A3 and and ARA
said ah screw it I'm going to play for
the win she doesn't feel like she's
risking even allowing Arena crash to
play F5 very silly Behavior no no no she
should have not done this this is not
very professional of her but that was
her decision that was beg him's decision
right because she probably she must have
known that night A3 is a 3 repetition
right perhaps she you know got a bit
overly confident in the fact that maybe
your opponent having such a low time
situation she will blunder and I get
more than just a drw maybe I win this
game well that's the kind of attitude
you need to have uh at times this crazy
ambition of uh even when you're worse
looking foring for her in it has worked
for Carissa as well now the question is
after the move F5 who stands better in
why Christian explain the situation well
the problem is you cannot take on
F5 why not if you take you open that was
the that so if you take on F5 twice in
the worst possible way this is where bad
things happen it was the scenario you on
it right I was desperate to have it yes
Rook G1 you can't go to f8 because that
Bishop does Patrol that square so after
the move F5 you can't capture which is a
big deal from White's point of view
white whether she's going to take or
play the move F6 I personally I would
think F6 would set up checkmating uh
potential so if she goes back with the
Knight Knight B1 well that's Rook takes
C2 Rook takes C2 you can do that right
that was the whole point that the Knight
on A3 defends the pawn on C2 in the past
we were making these waiting moves right
remember those moves
King G G8 G7 G G7 G8 so what happens if
black just Waits uh Christian in this
game between Arena and
beam let's move for just a second to the
Andrew Tang versus Darius V because
Andrew has found an absolutely marvelous
way to finish this game oh wow Rook
sacrifice there is a rook sacrifice and
there is a Checkmate
coming okay King to F4 Queen to E5 now
on the board yeah oh this is so nice
Queen to
E5 King to G5 no now H4
H4 uh I don't want to play King F5 and
lose that one so give me that one so
King now Queen
F4
so captures MH and then Queen H3 oh wow
this is taking a long time but I will
check my that King well I I can also
just take the queen if I really want to
Tak oh that's true you take the queen
because you don't know if it's Checkmate
but you know that the queen okay so
let's go back to the game position we
saw Queen to E5 King G5 and H4 on the
board now I think the nice part comes
after King to uh G4 okay then you go
Queen
G3 King H5 Queen G5 Checkmate
Ah that's pretty finally The Rook on h8
is doing something why did you put your
Rook on h8 that's nice and if I go back
to G6 you go back to
G6 then you
go Queen to
E8 and that's a Checkmate like that or
you lose the queen yeah so King F6 and
Rook F this is some really nice geometry
yes very nice geometry and this is the
first win for understand so can you move
it back just to see where he sacrificed
The
Rook at that point after Queen to D6
Rook to C6 really nice
calculated very nicely calculated pretty
wow that's a brilliant surprise right
there you go yeah that's it that's a
beautiful finish all right and we do
have on the board King G5 the player
we've we've caught up with the
players
H4
wof nice finish for Andrew and from
darush he also is without a win he's
drawn a lot of games uh some games he's
lost that he was that close to making a
draw but for Andrew He he'll really be
this is his debut this is an amazing
event for him uh to get a win at the US
championships will will really give him
a very very uh nice feeling by the way
guys it's always nice to finish a game
with a really nice tactic absolutely
it's the best
uh by the way what huge blunder by begim
in her game yes take a look at this
after
F5 I mean how she didn't claim that draw
is beyond me right that's remarkable
indeed and she played the move Knight to
B5 which loses on the spot right now
because now I have Rook takes C2 and you
cannot take on C2 because of Rook to d8
right and that's it that's check then I
pick up the Rook on C2 I'm a lot of
Pawns up and you're in trouble not only
that but the mate is coming via F6 as
well they're not looking good right now
and Rook takes C2 came on the board Rook
to E8 played by begim but it all Arena
Crush right now back in the mix back in
this game she's winning once again and
to be honest the position is not that
difficult anymore yeah you got rid of
the biggest weapon in Black position the
pawn on C2 and right now all you have to
do is convert a niy oh my gosh and there
was the draw it was possible to just
finish that game CLA the dra 93 just
claim the draw absolutely look at we're
looking at this position so this is the
first time move 45 move 47 once again
the same position nothing is changing
move 49 Knight to a A3 so after King to
D3 you stop the clock you write down on
your score sheet that you are playing
Knight A3 you go to the Arbiter you WR
down move Knight to A3 you showed it to
the Arbiter hey with this move three for
repetition and that's
right you go back and you enter the
final championship round on equal terms
with Karissa back on equal terms with
Carissa and then you have a game with
the white pie against a struggling
Jennifer U she did not do that and right
now she's in a dire position
unfortunately for her and Karissa I mean
back at the hotel right now she's
looking at this game she's she's done it
she's done it she's taken on C2 she's
played Rook to C8 has Arena crush and
completely winning oh my gosh what a
what a turnaround this is those are two
extra pawns incredible twist in this one
absolutely incredible twists Rook takes
C4 pardon me Rook E8 Rook C4 takes on F5
so the idea for beum is she's looking to
play Rook takes E5 pause let me offer a
trade of Rooks if I have more BS I want
to trade pieces go to that end game as
fast as possible exactly and what do we
think of uh the fob game guys Rook C8 on
the board and we think uh well arena is
just in cruise control now it's just uh
too many extra pawns for also when you
look at the Knight it doesn't have too
many squares to go to the bishop is
really nice plac kind of not allowing
the Knight to be active anywhere
exactly uh all of the key squares are
covered um let's jump to the Fabby game
because again it's so uh
eventful that the two games that could
decide the outcome of the championship
or some of the longest lasting games of
course I refer to fabbi versus Mishra
when we left it we saw the move Rook B5
I was saying it's it's suggestable for
white that he would like to keep the
pawns he decided that is to say Fabby
decided to trade played King H2 that
that's a nice move King H like because
he don't want to allow the G3 to kind of
stop that King block it on the back Rank
and potentially have some checkmates
there and anytime you play G3 check I
get to go King H3 and the pawn on G3
instead of being an asset becomes a
liability Rook to C1 okay that's a
pretty straightforward idea check and I
want to put my Pawn on B7 and then move
my Rook with a gain of tempo and I think
this is basically all she wrote right
you just go Rook to Rook C Rook C7 with
the idea of Rook here and B7 be it yeah
unless you get checkmated which you not
getting checkmated G3 King H3 yeah G3
King H3 is the
key yeah and that's it so Rook C7 a time
a factor Kate I don't see my clock 5
minutes and 20 seconds for Fabiano and a
minute and 57 seconds for abiani so
definitely starting to become a factor
okay let's try to find something I maybe
there is
something where Rook C7 King E6 Rook C 7
he has done it King E6 you say B7 King
D5 King D5 now Rook C8 is over yeah
Rook I was trying to go Knight C6 but
yeah yes Rook C8 just finishes the game
yeah I I cannot create that
mating threat that mating net on the
king side no the moment white played
King H2 he like all of those threats uh
to to his his King just disappear so
instead of King D5 can I go um King F
King G5 okay I want to go King King G5
Knight G6 and then G3 okay is Knight G6
Rook
G8 G3 King H3 I don't have that
Checkmate on F4 this is what I might
call uh you've got a a a 66% chance of
winning with black cuz I've got three
moves two lose but behind curtain number
one king wait do I have no Rook B4 just
Knight G6 he's going for it but Rook C7
I think after B7 this might be just so
he starts with Knight G6 instead of King
G5 right he does Knight
G6 so some ideas of Knight
F4 that's the only thing that he can try
for okay so last chap POS uh B7 if
Knight F4 Rook f8 that's right the
problem is like just imagine that I
queen yeah and you go G3 check the
Checkmate that you want to deliver is
actually protected by the queen it's not
available even now a I tried so hard I
know and we do have a result in the
Andrew T game did he allow Queen H5 mate
no no no it was Rook H6 Rook H6 finished
the game the que a really beautiful
sacrifice Rook C6 that's going to be in
some books as well exactly I mean I'm
with you Kate you finish a tournament in
style you win a nice game you forget
about the first nine rounds you know it
would never happened let me show you the
wi and you publish that article this is
my game championships exactly all I
remember about the US Championship is my
penultimate round game G6 on the
board do we have B7 we do a minute less
than a minute for ABI Manu right now but
the time is not the problem is the
position that just simply collapses
there's a coordination coming yep for
the queen on B8 there's also a
coordination coming for Fabiano Carana
who will be winning his third National
Championship right here right now with
around spare G3 check on the board King
H3 not falling for
the
66% and uh again any night checks the
king absolutely takes a walk King to G5
hoping for Knight F4 M mate the last
Cheapo that you can maybe King H5 is the
last Cheo the last Cheapo I like that
Knight F4 okay okay you went for Knight
F4 I think King H5 was the last Chapo
there and then Rook H7 yeah let me just
refresh my board nice one yeah as uh
last Cheapo no King
G5 but uh Knight F4 King G4 what does he
want to do uh Kate Knight takes
G2 Knight takes
G2 yeah maybe Knight E6 E6 try and say
that okay I'm at least avoiding I
looking for a cheaper well first of all
we don't have and very importantly that
we don't have the move Rook f a
check okay I think this is the best way
to to fight yes right Rook D7 I think
we're going to see some Knight C5 maybe
but then D6 you give up yeah I think I
have to at this point
um King E5 maybe
mhm oh we going lose that
pawn it should still be very much
winning even after Rook takes Rook to
C6 yeah just because the Knight is in
some terribly nasty pins right Rook C7
is probably just fine yes even going
into this end game Knight A5 we exchange
the Rooks and then King takes G3 that
should be an easy win yes I agree with
that that is nice I suspect I have
something a little bit even more
convincing but we do I'm just going to
refresh my board apologies this Knight
E6 MH
we expect Rook D7 Kate you were about to
say something no I I was thinking just
at the end that we can grab instead of
Rook C7 we can grab that B on A6 so we
like the move Rook D7 we like the move
Knight C5 we like check and we like this
move yes and after they just Rook takes
A6 absolutely yes I like I like it Rook
D7 is on the board so despite his little
bit of a wobble there when he played the
move Queen B4 I mean was a
straightforward game it very
strategically illustrative of like the
open file the par development the
maroine structure yeah all of the
marvelous positives the bc3 kind of
unexpected and I like that PES B takes
C3 very nice by the way Knight
C5 we do expect we're expecting Rook
takes D6
check mhm Rook takes
D6
and again it's so easy for us we're
sitting here in studio we take our
breaks uh we have our nice CFE we
blunder here and there we blunder here
and there these guys have been playing 5
hours straight and for the last couple
of weeks yeah very very
intense uh game stressful
games and uh wow they play so well so we
do expect Rook C6 yes although it
wouldn't surprise surpris me if there
there there were
other you feel like you have something
else but H6 is so so so convincing right
but I actually don't see I mean probably
you can go like Rook H6 still allowed
the capture but I can start running
A5 I like Rook C6 yeah that just goes
that goes very very nicely because it
threatens check Rook takes C5 check Even
If you defend the Knight let's try to be
resilient okay Rook Knight d D7 Knight
D7 okay I will fall for King D5 King D5
Rook C7 Knight F6 Knight yes I managed
to lose this wow it wasn't easy
K yes yes oh my goodness that was my
Rook takes C6 on Knight D7 is coming you
know he's got to try it why not okay he
went Knight D7 you got to try come on oh
wow okay where's the win let's let's
find the win I'm really happy the
commentary and not playing exactly
exactly let's not play around anymore
okay where's the
win how do you finish the
game I I'm still uh thinking of the
darush game at the very end where Fabby
allowed a a stal mating idea and he was
saying afterwards like okay I've got
stop looking at chess um I guess you
actually don't have more than Rook E8
and
rook and then King takes G3 and play
that position well I mean it is winning
it is completely winning yes but it it
is a bit of a surprise that you don't
have a forc trade forcible trade of the
Rook for's playing a rookie eight Check
Yes a forcible a winner of the night and
now if C7 comes on the board I mean this
is this would be the Kate will Kate will
Jinx the Kate will have Jinxed the
players and Rook takes A6 I'm sure is is
his uh plan he just done it by the way
Rook takes A6 on the board but that's a
crazy part you have to be accurate until
really you shake hands not that you are
just winning POS you have a winning
position and you can play whatever you
want
exactly no these are very strong Grand
Masters that are going to be resilient
all the way until last moment they I
mean if there's a resource in the
position I must say that they yeah the
players and look at Bobby give me that
last Pawn too King takes G3 now even if
you take one of my Rooks at least I have
to draw exactly I'm not losing
this water right right I'm not losing
this one no really winning winning
positions is just very difficult it's
not as easy as one my think not at
all not at all but right now just have
to move the pawn move the king to H pile
and just run with the pawn yeah so do we
have any other games in the women's
section oh we can look
at okay and still stay with this
game by the way just give you an update
uh Irena is putting the finishing
touches on that one um and she doesn't
seem to have any technical
difficulties TV as well TV as well yes
yeah okay so King H4 and it's all about
the G paon by the way there should be
mating Nets you know the white the
pardon me the black king stuck in the
middle of the board and you can see it
Fabby is still you know there's that
tension still m in him you can see uh
him not
being completely sure perhaps Knight to
C5 by the way Rook to A5 and Rook take
C5
that's that looks pretty decent that's
the technical win mhm because the king
the black king will be so far away from
the G Pawn I know I felt like he wants
to play G4 but once you said it he was
like hm maybe I have something different
to play here Rook A5 King D6 and again
Rook
takes followed by G E4 and the black
king is just so far away that G4 G5 G6
and the white king will just escort the
pawn up the board now having said that
uh G4 no I think he's going to grab the
Knight and play grab because where can
the Knight really move the problem is oh
I can KN actually doesn't move any yeah
the the the the Knight really can't move
to a square because if you go to E6 I'm
going to give a check on A6 grab a free
Knight that's right exactly you're going
to grab a free Knight if you go to the
D3 Square I can always once again give
up one of my Rooks and escort the pawn
home but yeah this is the problem um I
don't have to get back the exchange and
G4 uh asked the sing question what are
you doing about the gpon
yeah there's no answer to that crickets
crickets and by the way T won her game
King those French defense players when
oh
stop stop when you want to win with the
black pieces you know what I mean you
don't play the
French by the way like just keeping my
Rook out of Harm's Way Rook E2 just so
that you can't move your knight again I
like it Rook e to and if you move your
knight to D3 I can always give up the
exchange that way no at least you one
score more forward yeah you're already
on G4 exactly more advanced that's
exactly what I was thinking as well that
uh you you you smuggle a Tempo yes maybe
even two uh in that case but Rook e two
whoa Rook e
one you know you kind of give uh well
the problem is
Knight I can still play Rook D5 and then
give the rook and then play G5 got it I
am finally giving that Rook up yes no
reason to allow the Knight to survive on
the board
right Mishra no understanding feel like
he doesn't want to play there because he
sees that The Rook can go to D5 and C
the problem is the the Knight just has
no squares knight6 check or even this
check I have to say guys convinc in
performance by Fabiano to close the show
with one round to spare at the US
Championship that's not an easy task no
no that that is truly not an easy task
Knight B7 and again where is that Knight
actually ending up we can play again
yeah Rook D5 or Rook A7 Rook A7 I I
think Rook D5 is going to go for
probably
right just because some somewhat it
feels cleaner okay
I guess I don't know I don't know SC it
was like a 5050 shot you were really
close on this one too
yes but the next one it's easy just G5
King H5 G6 King H6 by the way we might
see a handshake in Arena versus begim as
well if you guys want
to check that one out um well we're
vultures just to see the handshake
basically exactly well we think the
handshake may be coming here too that's
the problem problem and well yeah beam's
kind of filling out the score sheet so
that is a pretty strong
indication that
uh yeah right now just Rook C5 to keep
that pawn on the board she's done it and
big him just a small Grimace there as
wow that something very bizarre just
happened here uh with beam's uh and
Arena's game because that realize night3
was how do you not realize that you're
in a three three-fold repetition you
have 10 minutes right it wasn't like you
can you can claim it and the if you're
wrong your Arbiter is going to award
your opponent an extra two minutes you
have a lot of time to check your score
sheet I feel like she was just trusting
her position that Irena is going to
repeat again or maybe she wanted her to
risk she got greedy yes yes I think that
was just her getting gedy thinking that
maybe she will be able to win that so at
last uh
fby has given up his exchange and he is
about to play G6 and escort his Pawn up
the board with the King
and Misha still playing a little little
surprised there fighting on
G7 Fabby just checking if he can move
that Pawn King
G5 H5 guess King G5 centralization and
handshake and there we have it
handshake our
congratulations to uh the defending
Champion backto back Champion incredible
performance very impressive and the
winner of the open section very very
very impressive here we go the 2023 us
chess champion Fabiano Carana $60,000
richer wow that's dinner's on you
tonight
fa all right we're going to the tonight
okay okay
got and uh in in studio we have a I'm
anxiously awaiting Andrew Tang to share
his victory with you Christian Andrew
sorry for uh making you wait in the
studio but I'm sure you were watching
that game as well first of all
congratulations this is your first
victory at the USS championships um and
it couldn't come in a sweeter way just
an incredible final finishing touches
with that brilliant attack tell us a bit
about that your emotions right
now thanks yeah I mean going into the
tournament my goal is to get at least
one win so I'm just relieved that I
managed to near the end of the
tournament and I mean yeah as you said
it was just such a sweet way to do it
that's probably like the nicest
combination I've ever gotten to play
over the board so just really really
happy about it absolutely and let's
review that because it was so uh
beautiful it was at this point all the
way towards the end where you finally
realize that and this was by the way not
an easy game it was back and forth sure
you had a better position but he was
making things very difficult for you and
finally you uh found this beautiful
ideas after Rook to C3 setting up this
Checkmate and then he thought that he's
going to uh trade the Queens off and go
into a rook end game which is probably
going to be a draw at this first of all
when did you spot this idea with Rook to
C6 that came after Rook to h8 and Rook
to C6 how many moves ago yeah yeah I saw
after well when I was playing Rook C8 I
had to make sure that it was working but
I actually saw the idea by then so I was
just like really really having to check
like five times because there are so
many things that can go wrong but yeah
after um I mean Rook C I have to be 100%
sure otherwise he's just trading the
Queens yeah right uh but yeah I mean
yeah it's just crazy every single piece
on the board is used in this mating
attack absolutely the geometry is is so
beautiful because he cannot cover he
would love to cover with a rook on F7 he
loses the queen everything works in your
favor and you did finally get it on the
board get the win on the board
congratulations Andrew tell us about
your assessment of this Championship
with one round to go this is the first
time you're participating at the USS
championships tell us a bit about your
experience yeah I'd say it's been a
success um definitely started a bit
slowly cuz I haven't been playing or
working much on chess these days so uh I
needed a warmup for sure but yeah I'm
I'm pretty happy with the way I've
played it's just that my openings are
really not up to par with the rest of
the the field as I'm not a professional
and everybody else has just really solid
openings so I just I've been just trying
to get games and this game I managed to
outplay them but and after uh Sweet
Victory I'm sure you want to give some
shout outs uh to the people that have
been supporting you throughout the event
would you like to do that sure yeah I'd
like to thank my coach Nicole mitkov
for helping me throughout the tournament
even though I haven't had much time to
work on chess I'd like to thank
everybody watching uh the people in my
Discord as well for playing video games
with me after each round and yeah well
thank you very much Andrew now I want to
ask yaser a question yaser do you know
what the Discord is yeah I I I have some
knowledge but I'm not a Discord fan
maybe you should get on Andrew's disc
Andrew if you want to invite me uh to
your uh group you know I I'm
terrible video games but uh
congratulations Andrew seriously we like
the geometry and we saw one Checkmate
where your Rook was actually on
h8 where uh you had uh a queen G5
Checkmate which we we we thought was
really sweet right here
uh you know if your coach asked you yeah
if your coach asked you why did you put
your Rook on h8 you could show him this
variation uh congratulations a very very
nice very very uh picturest finish yeah
we were talking about brilliancy
surprises for games this will be
definitely one of the candidates
absolutely congratulations
Andrew thanks absolutely and where do we
stand uh it's over
it's over it's over I'm still the 10th
round is over we're setting up for some
interviews maybe we can look at the
standings once again give the flowers to
our champion because uh he did win with
a round spare we have one Champion right
now we're still waiting to uh determine
who's going to be the champion in the
ladies section but a lot of things have
changed in this round it is Karissa who
is leading the tournament she won
today's game and switched with the
script over bon bon came in today's
round with a half a point lead over
Carissa Carissa won bam loses and that
sets up for very
eventful ultimate round uh round there
is this one and a half Point difference
between the third place who who is tied
for arena crash and Alice Lee so really
it's about the championship between
these two ladies who are going to fight
it off tomorrow fight for the bronze
look at that bronze fight I mean Arena
and Alice uh and it's still tough have
there with six points oh she's there
yeah yeah and I think she won the last
three games that that potentially or two
yes I think so definitely the last two
but I think you might be on something
with the last three for sure and here we
go Fabiano Carana with seven and a half
out of 10 winning the championship with
one round to spare and then two players
tied for second Wesley saw and lener
Dominguez we know that Wesley was going
to play against Bobby tomorrow Wesley
will have the white pieces we don't know
who young is going to play tomorrow
andig congratulations to Fabiano karwana
the 2023 us just Champion impressive
Fabby back-to-back Champion fantastic
through the tournament exactly uh kept
his mistakes to a minimum it's sort of
like he wobbled a bit today but I have
to say he played such a very good game
overall I mean he was the one pushing
the action throughout uh Christian no
absolutely but we do have and we will
speak with Fabiano in just a few minutes
as well we do have Arena
with us Arena welcome back to the show
yesterday when you came here and you
said you're fighting for the podium but
more importantly you're just feeling
good about yourself your friendships
that you have been developing and it
definitely showed in this game this was
not an easy task with the white piece
sure it's a player that you have been
enjoying uh success against but she was
on a tear and you stopped her tell us a
bit about
that yeah um I felt like this game was
was really quite good um from the
beginning like there were a few things
that I did that I was quite happy with
um in the opening when I played this 95
move um stopping her E5 plans and then I
played Bishop B3 and neither of those
moves were obvious at all yeah like they
kind of took me a lot of time and I mean
certainly 95 like you can try to play
that position in a much more standard
way but 95 I was like you know I can
actually fight against the E5 idea and
Bishop B3 also like very you know
prophylactic because the idea is every
time she takes on E5 she's not going to
get B5 with Tempo I'm going to threaten
Knight E4 so I was really quite happy
with this oh and the other point to
Bishop B3 is that if she takes on D4 and
I take on D4 she doesn't have Knight B6
right and sort of like yeah um this type
of idea yeah so she's not going to hit
the bishop in the pawn um at the same
time so those things like were actually
really important to me building up this
game and obviously you know at some
point I had just like a most wonderful
position I also think like the plan of
uh you know doubling on the defile while
of course you know everyone knows Rooks
should come to the open file it wasn't
completely obvious to me in the game
just because there are so many other
opportunities to play on the king side
um but yeah once I got to this position
I knew I was doing well um and of course
I had you know very uh very poor
technique in in winning this position so
you know um what you saw was not very
clean at all because once I took the
pawn in age six it must have been
completely
winning and unfortunately we have some
problems with the board we will Rectify
that in just second maybe you can take
it from here yes yeah just go go through
where you felt um it was great Queen
takes H6 you're a happy
camper and then what happened I mean mhm
well okay maybe maybe starting from here
I just I I kind of Wonder right because
Queen D Queen H3 seems so obvious but
then she got her Queen out because I
couldn't take with the Rook because of
Knight E2 and once the queen came out I
actually realized it was not easy so it
was really just like in some very short
amount of time I wonder if maybe even
Queen H3 was a mistake maybe I should
have played Queen H4 that way I can take
with a rook on D3 um actually yeah Queen
H4 yeah why not I mean um it makes a big
difference yeah right and then she can
never really trade because the rook's
coming to H3 was kind of unpleasant so I
mean something like this should have
been should have been convincing right
but I really I just thought my position
was so winning I kind of didn't feel
that she could come back into the game
but once Queen H6 happened I knew she
was back in and I saw this Knight B5 C4
idea so you know really kind of losing
control but not completely at this stage
as we're getting into the first time
trouble um obviously you know I thought
this position was stable for me after B3
like I you know it seems very
unfortunate to let the black pawn get to
C3 but um you know I'm kind of holding
everything with my control of the
defile um and okay okay here feeling
sort of okay about how things were going
still had to make the time control um
Queen F3 I don't know if that was a good
decision or not it was seems okay uh to
go for this end game and basically here
I was at least feeling pretty safe about
my position like I knew this Pawn was
not going to promote and I thought there
were de decent chances to win this end
game and of course the really
interesting moment happened you know a
few few moves later and here I I feel
like maybe I messed up right um
so I was looking at you know Knight C3
was sort of my main calculation after
Rook B8 Rook
D4 um I can show you uh yeah Rook D4 if
Knight C3 then I was going to take on C2
and allow Knight D5 and play e takes D5
uh Rook takes C2 and D6 and I thought
that this should be a winning position
for
me um it is it is Rook to B2 D7 and you
get the
win but she found this I kind of missed
KN 2 A3 and that shocked us as well
because it doesn't seem like you have a
way to make any progress in the position
and in fact this was a critical moment
because you allowed the three-fold
repetition and in fact yeah I know she
did not stop the clock and she played
this move night to A3 this would have
been the third time and at this point
with only a few seconds on the clock you
made that decision to continue the game
you could have played King E3 that's
going to be a draw you made the decision
to continue the game with F5 what was
going through your mind at that point
you know I had finally seen this idea of
F5 right because my whole attention had
been on the queen side when I realized
like I just couldn't win the game on the
queen side def despite the fact that all
my pieces were there um all the action
would seem to be on the queen side and I
couldn't win so that was really uh quite
quite disappointing for me that this you
know King D3 idea just doesn't work um
and then finally you know and I'm
running down on the clock you know I
kind of saw F5 I was like oh actually
I'm not just giving away a pawn because
she gets M it if she takes it so this is
like some sort of possibility for me to
you know play u you know maybe get rid
of one of the double pawns so I had seen
this idea but I needed the king I guess
I needed the King on like in this
position this is where I wanted to do it
and you know you know when you're down
to 5 Seconds like I knew I I was
allowing the repetition but at the same
time I already had seen this idea and I
was like once she didn't take it I was
like okay and now I'm going for it and I
was really happy that I I found this
because obviously I didn't really want
the draw you know it was more a
situation of just like running down on
the clock and you know making sure you
don't lose on time which I could easily
do as I'm sure you guys you know know
know so um you know F5 was yeah probably
my best moments of the game because you
know you're already sort of supposed to
be acquiescing to the three move
repetition you got no time compared to
your opponent but you know you pull out
that little bit inside of you to play
for the win and um you know that's kind
of in my opinion the best moment of the
game for me absolutely and it definitely
paid off congratulations Arena big
victory for you and you're throwing the
gauntlet in this tournament because the
standings once again changed
congratulations we'll see you
tomorrow thank you Christian absolutely
our congratulations as well and I think
she's right that move F five but on the
other hand what the heck B why why
aren't you I still understand what
happened there you're several pwns down
why not just uh claimed the draw your
last moves have been Knight A3 Knight B1
clearly you're reaching for a draw you
have it but you know again talk about it
right long tournament there are some
just glitches sometimes it's a blunder
and sometimes maybe you really forget or
you get too greedy exactly uh let's peek
ahead and take a look at tomorrow's
pairings and here they
are woman section Lee playing asaran to
here janova is going to Jennifer you
yeah exactly very important match for
Jif spoil the party as well abrahamian
playing Crash both players winning today
by the way exactly then we have Karissa
of the leader playing
ruangan cantes playing zatonski and P
kashian playing P now we know that U pby
has already won the open tournament but
nonetheless we've got very important
games to go right wesle so is going to
challenge Fabiano Carana to tomorrow but
again for Fabby the result is not going
to matter that much for this tournament
big fight for second Dominguez Dominguez
against neand then we have sh against
Robson saan playing tank shankland
playing Jong and Mishra playing aroan
also becoming a a big fight for the
fourth place there too leavon thanks to
his victory today his first Victory uh
getting back in and Christian you have a
special guest in studio tatv tatv uh a
lot of things went well for you today
one thing that I'm a little bit
suspicious about you once again play the
French you shouldn't do that you're my
hero tat well done yaser loves it the
last time in this tournament I don't
have to see a friend or a Catalan for at
least a month well you can play the
Catalan tomorrow perhaps anyway tell us
about today's game where did you feel
like you're finally taking over the
initiative and uh tell us the critical
moments uh uh yeah the opening I thought
went well for me with all these pieces
coming off I thought I was comfortable I
was happy to see that she went F5 and
for a fighting position I was a little
worried she might play Knight D3 and try
to play an end game and try to be more
solid because I wasn't sure if I could
try to push that position because okay I
can go Knight E4 but maybe she can go
Knight F2 I'm I'm not sure can I press
here yeah yeah yeah I mean I don't want
to do this of course so I was very happy
that she wanted to fight and you know
she created did a double-edge position
which felt scary for me I think
objectively even during the game I had a
feeling it should be okay for me but um
you know it's a French so you always
have to think about am I getting
checkmated very good
point very good point but once my Rook
got to G6 I was safe I just saw that I
missed a nice tactic it didn't occur to
me that I had this moment but I could
have trapped her night which is um at
what point
really uh I think here
H5 Queen H5 F5 at some point
H5 H5 F5 the problem is The Rook on G6
right no no no they okay but there was a
moment where I could have done
this I just checked on my phone I don't
know maybe I'm
missing perhaps I don't see it yeah but
once we got to the end game then I was
quite happy and the whole time again I
was telling myself you're up a pawn
don't lose control somehow you'll
convert and I think today I didn't
really give any chances absolutely and
you did convert quite successfully after
that you're still in the fight for the
podium and uh that's a big fight because
both Alis Lee and Arena Crush have won
their respective games today what do you
have to do tomorrow to uh finish on the
podium well I'm playing Irena so I have
my chances there I'm playing with the
white pieces I mean historically she's
been a very difficult opponent for me
well she's been a difficult opponent for
everyone here uh but I do have the white
pieces um and she's also fighting for
third place so she will definitely try
to beat me but Alice is um I don't know
who she's playing but okay that one is
out of my control but I think I have my
fifth place guaranteed so I don't really
have much to lose MoneyWise but I can
try to fight for higher place of course
but T didn't you play Arena Crush few
years back in the US championships also
in the last round also with white pieces
and then managing to
win I think I won last year against her
if I'm not
mistaken in the last round with the
white P I don't
remember many games that still a big
game that's going to be a big game T go
get your rest get your preparation in
big game tomorrow and uh we'll see you
tomorrow thank you our congratulations
to you as well T by the way today's game
I mean we've denigrated the French but
uh it felt uh like tatf didn't have have
any trouble she got through the opening
pretty okay she uh traded off the light
Square bishop and kind of cruised to
Victory by the way I mean we have chess
in St Louis and boy do we have a lot of
events still to go the grand chest tour
the finale Kate so St Louis rapid and
Blades coming on November 12th to 19
then the S field cup the giant event of
the Year November 19th to December 3rd
granddaddy of the mall will decide the
welome of the grand chess tour I must
say I'm looking ahead reading the tea
leaves will ding Len the uh world
champion join us of course he's in the
grand chest store but he hasn't played
in quite some months so wait for that
yeah you got to tune in and wait for uh
the grand chest t as we're waiting for
one very special guest to come up that's
the one this is the one that's the one
right there you see that the director
listens
yes exactly exactly big congratulations
to the 2023 US champion Fabiano Carana
yes $60,000 richer as he's in studio
Christian well Fabby first of all big
congratulations uh from the studio here
you are the 2023 USS Champion how are
you feeling right now this was not an
easy task from the beginning to defend
the title in fact we don't remember last
time somebody defended the title in the
open section how are you feeling right
now s for us yeah overall it's a great
feeling uh I am very tired at the moment
and today I really didn't play a good
game but uh but the result is great I
couldn't be happier about uh about
repeating repeating the the win from
last year tell us about today's game
because uh it was a nerve-wracking
Affair it felt like you had everything
under control under WPS you were ready
to put the finishing touches and then
something went wrong at some point with
that move Queen to B before tell us
about that
move well I think I have some sort of
disease because whenever I whenever I
play with my queen I I usually put it in
a place where it's completely trapped I
did this against Sam I've done this many
times in the past I I self tra my queen
and I did it again today uh Queen B4 and
then suddenly I realized like Knight C4
my queen is it can't move it can't go to
B1 uh like I I complicated my life so
much and then probably I even spoiled
the majority of the advantage at some
moment but I mean any move besides Queen
B4 I win the game it's just like any
anything it's uh this game should be
over in 5 minutes instead of whatever it
was like two hours and um yeah and how
do you how do you come back from that
because we saw your body language we
understood that you were quite
disappointed when you made the time
control at the same time you must have
known that you still have great chances
and maybe even a concretely uh decisive
Advantage how did you recover from that
how did you put yourself back into the
mindset that you have to finish the
job actually I was I was not too upset
after the time control I felt like he
maybe missed chances to make it even um
to get even more compensation like after
the time control I lost upon Pawn but I
got my coordination so I I did feel like
I had a big Advantage but somewhere when
we were both low on time I really wasn't
sure if I had almost completely spoiled
it or not and okay I probably I did keep
an advantage the entirety of the the
game but
um but yeah it was very I was very
unsure because my queen was going to
some weird places and he was very active
and um yeah after just have control I I
I had already seen this A4 idea I was
actually surprised he went Queen E4
because I thought other moves the queen
is better placed and uh yeah after A4 I
thought I have a very good chance to win
anyway uh still it was because I was I
think the the position you never let go
of uh the advantage fully by any means
yeah this number is really not
indicative of what I was feeling at the
moment but uh but I'm glad to see that
it was plus three like over the board it
really felt like um of course I'm I'm
pressing with no risk but still Anything
could happen in terms of uh if I'm
actually going to win this game and only
after he played G5 I was pretty
confident like this G5 felt very wrong I
I don't think that he's attacking this
position and yeah I felt like there
should be uh several ways to to refute
this move but Queen B6 I thought was
just a forced win like I didn't see any
chance for him after that yeah just had
to look see that after Rook f8 basically
um he yeah he can he can take on D5 but
then he can't play Rook B5 because
there's Rook
F6 it even felt like there's like a
margin uh other rook and and King G7
Rook D6 it even felt like maybe there's
some other ways to win as well but okay
this this was clean enough and otherwise
yeah it's my Rooks become active uh
that's that's really the the question is
not the material in this position the
question is how active my Rooks are and
and once Rook of eight comes they're
very active well I have to ask you Fabby
everything has been going swimmingly for
you this year you qualified for the
candidates you got once again back to
that
2800 uh level it feels like you're fully
back in this one and also you defend the
national championship who do you have to
blame for this
success well I I think I have myself to
blame for some of my my uh failures in
past few years especially the candidates
last candidates was was of course a huge
failure um it was a rough period for for
some time I mean things seem to be a bit
better now I I seem to be playing better
or at least maybe the quality isn't
always there but definitely taking uh
some chances that I in tournaments when
I can and usually fighting for first
place in in most of my tournaments that
I've played and uh and also I've been
working very hard in general like not
not just in in in between tournaments
but during tournaments I've been uh
fighting very hard which is uh usually
better than um than the the alternative
which is like let's say some players
they lose motivation and and I was also
in that position where I was at some
point losing motivation a bit so uh
definitely it's very important to keep
uh to keep that like I don't know what
the word exactly for it is but uh let's
say to keep that gumption that you're
always fighting
um as much as you can dur in the
tournament sometimes it doesn't work out
like I had some very disappointing
results this year as well but but in
this tournament it it did work out
pretty well guys any questions for our
champion yes indeed Fabby first of all
our congratulations absolutely backto
back Stellar performance well done today
was an absolutely huge game you're
playing against Mishra this 14-year-old
phen um it's scary right whenever you
play a project G who's capable of taking
down anybody uh I don't know if you are
satisfied your with your position at
move 13 you just played this move Queen
E2 and again you won a very smooth game
thereafter Queen E2 rook
fc8 and uh basically you kept the
advantage throughout now again just
thinking about your mindset going back
at the start of the position you're
playing against Mishra he had this
opportunity to play the move F7 F5 at
first glance maybe it wasn't something
that you feared but on the other hand
you're playing the guy who's in second
place who needs to beat you and if he
had played the move F5 did you consider
F5 seriously uh did you have an
intention if he had played which is a
pretty aggressive uh approach by
black well to be honest I didn't like my
position in general uh that's that's the
thing so basically I was already
unsatisfied on the third move because he
usually plays Knight D7 I had something
in mind there and then he plays Bishop
D7 for the first time
and you had prepared against Knight D7
not against Bishop to D7 his choice so
you were dissatisfied right here yeah I
wasn't too happy and then I remembered
okay first I remembered there was some
game uh where Richie played C4 I think
against Max Sean it was like C4 E5
Knight C3 Knight E7 I was thinking okay
against against him maybe it's fun to
play a closed position which is very
tense and um in general I have a lot of
experience in these types of structures
so uh then he quickly played I was
hoping C4 takes him by surprise and he
quickly plays this and then I remembered
that there was some game of G of nepo
against giri and it it was like it
wasn't with Queen D4 but at some point
he played Knight D4 then he played
Knight F3 and then he played uh Queen E2
Bishop D2 and Rook B1 in some sort of
order it was like Knight C6 Knight F3
Castle Bishop
D2 uh something like A6 Queen E2 Rook B8
Rook B1 and the point is black shouldn't
play B5 because um white gets like Rook
A8 Rook ab1 B5 take everything Knight E4
Queen
E4
um yeah Knight B5 Knight E4 Queen E4
Rook B5 and and White's Pawn start to
move this is sort of what I remembered
but I couldn't remember what the move
order is and then I thought why don't I
play Queen D4 and um
and basically it seems to win a Tempo
and then I confused myself entirely
because on the one hand I I thought like
maybe H3 is more natural here to prepare
Bishop B3 but then I was like okay I'll
play Bishop D2 after A6 I'll play Rook
B1 and after Rook B8 I was thinking okay
maybe I'll play Queen E2 and we get that
game and then he played Knight G4 I'm
like what's the point of my play I don't
understand
it so so my thoughts were all over the
place at some point I was just like okay
just make a move I mean I I don't
understand this position clearly so yeah
I was a bit worried about F5 and if EF5
gf5 I guess is the only logical way to
kind of continue it and then then to put
the Knight on E5 and take back with the
pawn and try to get those like I mean I
didn't think I was worse but uh I
certainly wasn't happy with the result
of the opening because uh I mean clearly
he he got an interesting position and
and I got under a little bit of
pressure I I thought that yeah his Rook
FCA was a bizarre move I didn't
understand it uh like I kind of
understood it but I thought why why is
he doing this and then Bishop C3 I also
didn't understand why he took on C3 I
thought like maybe Knight G5 is normal
um like Bishop C3 bc3 I I suddenly I'm
in safety I first of all I have a drain
um mechanism if I ever want it you have
a repetition which we've seen yeah yeah
which is nice just psychologically and
then very quickly I saw C5 is a very
dangerous idea right because if he takes
the pawn I put Knight on B6 Rook C7 I I
wasn't sure which Rook to go to D1 but
let's say Rook fd1 he has to go to E8
with the queen and then E5 and okay I
don't know maybe black is not uh losing
here but it it certainly looks very
dangerous it it seemed that in fact
black was losing here yeah it was a
really really bad position for black so
your judgment was
spoton so I thought what he should have
done was Knight G5 after C5 I wasn't
sure how big my advantage is is here
after after C5 already I mean clearly
I'm I'm better after C5 but Knight G5
and then he takes with the
pawn and it looks very weird oh no no
not not CD I think Knight E5 is
necessary ah Knight takes CD I don't
want to play of course and now D5 so
Knight E5 would be the game but D5 is
and then he tries to get Queen E8 Knight
d8 Knight E6 and I didn't see exactly
how I continue I mean certainly I'm I'm
again very safe position but
do I have a big Advantage I wasn't 100%
sure although it does feel like black is
in danger
here well once again uh Fabby our
congratulations
Kate for our champion no just
congratulations really amazing
tournament and I like this game I know
you probably don't have great feelings
about the game but I feel like B takes
A3 and then just pushing all the pieces
away and then just having a win and
maybe missing it with that Queen before
but otherwise a very straightforward
game yeah very very impressive Fabby U
get your rest still a big game tomorrow
don't don't don't let this success go to
your
head like nepo last round of the
candidates right you know you won it
with a round to spare but our
congratulations indeed Fabby andk what a
penultimate round this turned out to be
uh Christian oh absolutely just uh we
sort of anticipated something along
these lines but we weren't really sure
what's going to happen I have to say
change of leaders in the ladies section
that's the big one oh by okay good job
congratulations job all right all right
all right all right all right I'll I'll
I'll come to you guys I'll face bump you
at some point uh but yes I have to say
uh you guys picked well congrats I yeah
well I must say that's a tough one
that's a tough one you guys are out of
competition already we didn't see Alice
getting off to such a a slow start we I
see the other girls just flying away
with their points wow wow but you were
you're you're good again in the open
section I have to say we've had a leader
I believe since day three of something
along those lines Mishra I think was a
leader at day three and Hans was also in
the mix at the right moment but
unfortunately wasn't able to keep uh up
with Fabiano and I have to say this was
a maddening Pace that he said he was
just like winning game after game after
game and lenier was also saying the same
thing he was like okay look I'm winning
some games but how am I supposed to keep
Pace with a guy that's just beating
everybody and that was Fabby in this one
so congratulations once again from our
side for just an amazing performance not
only that you're winning the USS
Championship you've qualified to the
candidates but you're also getting close
that 2800 barrier that's a very
difficult one to hang around so
definitely a good event for Fabiano a
good year but still everything to play
for in terms of the podium coming up
tomorrow and we'll be here at call the
action thank you Christian I love
hearing Fabby saying that he has a
discipline when he's not in these
tournaments to really push himself so
that's really really nice Kate it was
great calling the action with you and
Christian both seriously Christian no I
love it come on come on I'm getting
there I'm getting there I'm getting
there right right right there there we
go we go okay okay okay wanted it I I
wanted everybody it's been really really
a lot of fun calling the action we
really hope that you have enjoyed our
show join us tomorrow for the 11th and
Final Round important round in the
women's section exactly we could be
crowning a champion we could be playing
playoffs on Wednesday but any case we'll
be here calling all the action we hope
you'll join us see you tomorrow good
night good night
everyone
[Music]
he
this has been a presentation of the St
Louis chess club any reproduction or
distribution of this content without the
express written consent of the St Louis
chess club is
prohibited